Well, good morning, everybody. Seeing that board members are now present, Brooks, would
you please call the roll to establish a quorum for the September State Board Meeting on Education?
Member Sun. Here.
Vice President Strauss. Here.
Member Rucker. Here.
Member Rodriguez. Here.
Member Petillo-Brownson. Here.
Member McQuillan. Good morning, here.
Member Glover-Woods. Here.
Member Escobedo. Here.
Member Burr. Here.
Member Benanca. Here.
We have a quorum.
So I'd like to commence by splitting the flag, and we'd like to ask our student board member,
Ronna Benanca, to please lead us in the Pledge of Allegiance. So we'll wait for a minute for the
flag to be visible on the screen, and then Ronna, if you'll lead us, that would be great.
Please salute. I pledge allegiance to the flag of the United States of America and to the Republic
for which it stands, one nation under God, indivisible, with liberty and justice for all.
Okay. So I'm wondering, Executive Director Allen, whether we want to wait for President
Erling Hammond to do the oath, or whether you'd like maybe myself or Superintendent Thurmond?
I think you can move ahead and administer the oath, Vice President Strauss. Thank you.
Okay. So we're going to administer the oath for our two newest board members, which are delighted
to have them join us. So first, I'm going to do it one at a time. So Dr. Francisco Escobedo
will be first, and then Ronna Benanca will be our second. So Francisco, if you'll raise your
right hand and repeat after me. I, and state your name. I, Francisco Escobedo. Do solemnly swear.
Do solemnly swear. That I will support and defend the Constitution of the United States.
That I will support and defend the Constitution of the United States. Against all enemies,
foreign and domestic. Against all enemies, foreign and domestic. That I will bear true
faith and allegiance. That I will bear true faith and allegiance. To the Constitution of the United
States and the Constitution of the State of California. To the Constitution of the United
States and the Constitution of the State of California. That I take this obligation freely
without any mental reservation or purpose of evasion. That I will take this obligation freely
without any mental reservation or purpose of evasion. And that I will well and faithfully
discharge the duties upon which I'm about to enter. And that I will well and faithfully
discharge the duties upon which I am about to enter. Well, thank you and congratulations,
and welcome to the board, Dr. Escobedo. We're going to introduce you in a minute. I want to
do the, I think, actually, let's welcome you first and then we'll swear and run. So we're
delighted to welcome Dr. Francisco Escobedo as our new board member today. He served actually until
very recently as the superintendent of Chula Vista Elementary School District since 2010 until his
retirement last week. He was the superintendent of the year for the Association of California
School Administrators, region 18. Dr. Escobedo's experience includes working as an assistant
superintendent for educational leadership in the South Bay Union School District and principal
research analyst from the American Institute for Research. Since 2001, Dr. Escobedo has been
adjunct professor of educational administration at San Diego State University and he's currently
a member of the doctoral faculty. He was appointed to serve on the West Ed Board of
Directors by Dr. Darlingham last year. So please join me in welcoming Dr. Escobedo to our state
board of education. Francisco, would you like to say a few words? Sure, I'll say a few words. Again,
I am so thrilled being part of this illustrious group and look forward to working together to
make just an amazing what I call learning environment for our students, great working
environment for our teachers and definitely want to help California just continue leading the way
in educating our students. So thank you for the kind introduction and again looking forward to this
school year. Thank you. So now I'm going to administer the oath to Rana Banaka. Rana was
selected I would say from a very, very rigorous group of applicants last year. She was incredibly
impressive which I'm sure you'll learn. So Rana, would you please raise your right hand and repeat
after me? So I and state your name. I, Rana Banaka. Do solemnly swear. Do solemnly swear.
That I will support and defend. That I will support and defend. The Constitution of the
United States against all enemies, foreign and domestic. The Constitution of the United States
against all enemies, foreign and domestic. That I will bear true faith and allegiance to the
Constitution of the United States and the Constitution of the State of California.
That I will bear true faith and allegiance to the Constitution of the United States
and the Constitution of the State of California. That I take this obligation freely without any
mental reservation or purpose of evasion. That I take this obligation freely without any mental
reservation or purpose of evasion. That I will well and faithfully discharge the duties upon
which I'm about to enter. That I will well and faithfully discharge the duties upon which I'm
about to enter. Well so let let me tell you a little about our amazing new student board member.
She's a senior at Modesto high school in the international baccalaureate program
and in addition to serving on the state board of education she serves as a student board member
in the Modesto city schools so she's had some good practice. In her district she is a student
represented on her district's LCAP committee and wellness committee and as a member of the
district student advisory council and inter-high council. So Ronna would you like to say a few words?
Yeah well first and foremost thank you so much for administering my oath of office vice president
Strauss. Good morning esteemed board members and members of the public. My name is Ronna Beninka
and I'm a senior at Modesto high school in Modesto California and it is truly my absolute honor
and privilege to serve as the student board member on the state board of education this year
and I want to just thank the board and the state of California for ensuring that students truly
have a full vote and a full seat at the table when it comes to these critical decisions regarding
education policy at the statewide level. I know that not many states have a position as unique
as this one so I'm incredibly grateful for this opportunity and just to give a little bit of
background about myself I first became interested in education policy when I was a freshman through
a classmate of mine in a journalism class who happened to be our district's student board member
and ever since then I've been really interested in learning about the policies that shape our
classroom and thinking about ways that we can potentially improve them to better student outcomes
and so I think that my experiences of serving on my district councils like the LCAP committee
as you mentioned and the wellness committee and the student advisory council coupled with
my experience of serving as my district student board member have really served to refine the lens
with which I view education policy. Again, I am truly honored to serve in this position and I'm
looking forward to representing all of California's 6.3 million students this year. Thank you.
Wow well welcome to our board, Rana and Francisco. We are so delighted to have you join us.
Member, President Dronehammon, would you like me to turn it backward just at the beginning of I
guess comments from the board and then moving to general announcements?
Let me add my congratulations and yes let's invite comments from the board
on both of these wonderful appointments and thank you so much Vice President Strauss for
kicking us off this morning. My pleasure. I'll just say Dr. Esquivado we're going to have a lot
to talk about on doctoral classes and instructional leadership and I'm excited to hear about the
center that you're leading at San Diego at the university and I just think you'll add a lot.
I actually have read your the LPI study on the work that you did in Trimula Vista and I think
we're just fortunate to have you and I'll just say to Rana in the interviews last year we had
like twice as many candidates as we've ever had and you were incredible. We just heard your voice
now and I think we will look forward to continuing to hear it. I think you play a very important role
for us to make sure we keep that at the center of our work and we're excited and hopefully we'll
get to work with you in person this year at some point but thank you for being with us today and
for what you're going to do for students in California. Terrific. Are there other
uh comments from members of the board? Hi this is Ting. I just wanted to say Rana welcome to the
board. I was on the initial interview panel and we interviewed Rana and some really great students
and I was just thrilled to hear that the announcement that you were selected so
congratulations and welcome. Terrific. We are delighted to have you Rana. It's
I'm glad I was able to tune in in time to hear your comments and Dr. Escobedo it's a treat to have you
on the board as well. We're doing our second LPI study on Chula Vista as you as you are exiting
and going into your new new job and really appreciate all of the fine leadership you have
exhibited both in that district and in the state and looking forward to the months ahead
in your participation on the board. I want to apologize for my late arrival there was a
miscommunication about things on my end and so I'm delighted that we got going and that we are
off and running on what's going to be a pretty robust board meeting today. We have what could
be a nine-hour agenda. We'll see how we manage to be both thorough and efficient in dispatching
all of our business. As I announced at our July meeting we've launched the fall recruitment and
selection process for the following state board commissions the advisory commission on charter
schools the California practitioners advisory group and instructional quality commission.
The state board office is accepting applications until the close of business
on Friday September 24th so please submit the completed applications as soon as possible.
I also announced in July that the kickoff for the recruitment and selection process
for the 2022-23 state board student member is in operation. The state board is accepting
applications until five o'clock p.m. on Friday October 8th so we encourage all eligible students
will be seniors next school year to apply. We have one addendum the following item item eight
the request to ratify California's American Rescue Plan elementary and secondary school emergency
relief homeless children and youth application addendum is in your computer files or packets.
There is one public hearing on the agenda item five is an appeal from an action of the Riverside
County Committee on school district organization to approve a petition to transfer territory
from the Coachella Valley Unified School District to the Desert Sands Unified School District.
On the consent calendar the proposed waiver consent items are W1 through 15 and the proposed
regular consent items are items six through nine. We do have a couple of changes in the agenda
we'll begin with item two which is our mega assessment item then we'll take up item one
to hear the state superintendents and board presidents reports we'll reopen this item later
this afternoon to take action on the July minutes and receive the state board liaison reports.
We'll also take up item 11 just after item one this morning you need a score card to keep track
but I'll keep announcing where we're going as we're going there. In terms of public input
members of the public wishing to call in for public comment should view the live stream of
the meeting to know at what time public comment will occur for each item. Public comment may be
provided by dialing the phone number entering a participant access code and then following each
of the operator's prompts upon dialing in callers will be added to a caller queue the operator will
notify callers when it is their turn to provide public comment we will also ask callers to please
turn down the speaker volume of their computers if they are following the live webcast to avoid an
echoing effect. Public comment will be limited to one minute per speaker. Item 10 is the general
public comment item during which members of the public may provide comment on matters that are
not specifically listed on the board's agenda. Board members please mute your microphones when
you're not speaking and keep your cameras at all times on except during the scheduled breaks
and any brief personal breaks you might need to ensure that we maintain a quorum throughout today's
virtual meeting. If you need to take a brief personal break please text our executive director
Brooks Allen so he will know and can help us maintain a quorum. For each item on the agenda
there will be an opportunity for you to raise your hand using the zoom participant window
if you would like to ask a question or make a comment. So we're going to move on to
agenda item two which is the California assessment of student performance and progress system
and English language proficiency assessments with California the request for approval of the
Smarter Balanced summative assessments for English language arts literacy and mathematics
blueprints and an update on assessment program activities. As a spoiler alert the CDE is
recommending that the state board approve the Smarter Balanced summative assessments for ELA
and math blueprints as described in tables one and two for the 2021-22 administration
and this item will be presented by Mao Vang of the CDE. Mao please take it away.
We are not hearing you yet.
Thank you. I have to get myself oriented here into my new environment. So thank you President
Darlin-Hammond. Again this item is item number two the assessment updates. Good morning. I am
our Superintendent Thurman, President Darlin-Hammond and our esteemed board members.
I am Mao Vang the director for the assessment development and administration division.
Again this is the mega assessment update item. Before I go into this formal presentation though
I would like to let you know about some staffing changes in the assessment development and
administration division of the California Department of Education. I want to just take
a moment to congratulate Dr. Eric Zilbert our associate director who has recently retired.
Just want to share a little bit about his contribution to California's the Department
of Education and California students and teachers. Over the last 20 years Dr. Zilbert
has contributed tremendously through the multiple roles that he has had in our division
and he has provided educational measurement or psychometric expertise for all of our statewide
programs such as the California English language development test, the California assessment of
student performance and progress, the English language proficiency assessments for California
or LPAC just to name a few and he has guided the test development, analyzed data, developed systems
for reporting test results and participated on the CDE technical design group and contributed to as
well as collaborated with the analysis measurement and accountability reporting division on the
growth model work. Furthermore he facilitated our CASP and LPAC technical advisory group meetings
to ensure that CDE has the access and California has access to expert guidance of leaders in the
field of assessment to assure the highest quality assessment program possible and Dr. Zilbert
certainly has made a deep and lasting impact on assessments in California. Thank you Dr. Zilbert.
One other change I would like to update you on is to remember Michelle Glipa. She was an associate
governmental program analyst in our division who lost her life due to COVID-19 in November 2020.
For the last 14 years Michelle Glipa's work spanned across four different assessment programs
in our division and she was on a team of three people to support the work of eight units
consisting of about 50 staff members and multiple contractors facilitating the review and approval
process of over a thousand assessment deliverables per year and that's only the ones that are numbered.
In each of the positions that she has held she has excelled in everything that she did
she held herself and others to the highest standards she demonstrated an exceptional work
ethic she was professional punctual and reliable and she has had it she has an excellent eye for
detail and she kept helped keep all the project deliverables of the division moving along so her
death was devastating and painful for our division as well as all those who knew her and due to the
impacts of COVID-19 there was not much we could do however this summer we were able to share in
the celebration of her life with her family and friends and we we certainly did lose a great
employee friend and overall beautiful person inside out and although she is no longer with us
she is not forgotten. So here I will begin my formal presentation
uh this is the again the assessment item and I will be joined later by Cindy Kazanas the director
of the assessment the analysis measurement and accountability reporting division in addition we
have Mary our Mary Ann Aracela the executive director of ETS or educational testing service
and Tony Alpert the executive director of the smarter balance assessment consortium are available
to assist with questions during this item so the item before you is both action and information
item in the presentation I will provide an overview of the recommendation for approval
Cindy will join me and in presenting the use of assessments for accountability in the upcoming
years and then I will circle back and give you some key updates in the California assessment of
student performance and progress or CASP and English language proficiency assessments for
California or ALPAC updates and wrap it up with the national and international assessments update
and then bring us back to the action of the recommendation and here is the recommendation
the California department of education recommends that the California state board of education
approve the smarter balance summative assessments for English language arts literacy
or ELA and mathematics blueprints as described in tables one and two for the 21-22 administration
and in future years as laid out in tables one and two in the item
um
so just to give a little background I will provide this overview and background on our
recommendation remember that the the every student succeeds act is our uh has section
111 b2 which requires that states uh that a statement administer annual assessments so
um in in reading language arts and mathematics and um to students in grades three through eight
and once in high school and then science uh which is for grades bands once in grade spans three
through five six six through nine and once in high school and then um English language the English
language proficiency assessment which is to all eligible students in grade in kindergarten through
grade 12 so under our uh California assessment system we have the cast as defined in education
code sections 60601 through 60649 and that includes the smarter balance summative assessments for
English language arts and math our science uh California science test and the California
alternate assessments for English language arts math and science and we have an optional
California Spanish assessment for Spanish reading language arts and this is to meet our
state as well as federal requirements under ESSA and then including the ALPAC as defined in our
education code sections 313 and 60810 and that includes our initial ALPAC the summative ALPAC
and the alternate ALPAC so again providing a little background in the last school year 2020-21
the U.S. Department of Education did provide some flexibilities to support the administration of
assessments due to the impact of the COVID-19 pandemic so the state board of education our
SBE did support the flexibilities and approved adjusted blueprints for the smarter balance
summative assessments for ELA math to be used for one year only so the CDE continues to
um seek opportunities to maximize flexibility for our local educational agencies in California
and also trying to keep the critical elements of the infrastructure intact so so for us to
use the adjusted blueprints and preserve that maximum flexibility for our local educational
agencies for this spring 2022 testing the SBE would need to approve the continued use of the
adjusted blueprints for both the ELA and mathematics per our state education code
and at this time the CDE does not recommend changes to other non-smarter balanced blueprints
so the rationale for this for the adjusted blueprints and continuing to use them is that
they are derived from the adopted smarter balance summative assessments for ELA math
and this the there's a reduction in the computer adapted test portion or the cat portion by about
50 percent for each claim and this will also maintain comparable proportion of content across
all the claims and i'll say a little bit more about claims later for example a claim is
in english language arts in mathematics i'll just give a little background is you'll have the claims
such as reading listening research inquiry writing those are claims under a content area
and it'll also maintain proportion of depth of knowledge of the depth of knowledge being assessed
and this will keep the performance tasks intact because they are integrated tasks
so some advantages for continuing to use the adjusted blueprints are that they do reduce the
amount of time students spend on the english language arts and math summative assessments
so to allow more time to really fully utilize our comprehensive assessment system which includes the
use of other resources that support the formative assessment process such as our tools for teachers
that have resources in english math and science and then our interim assessments throughout the
year and this will also maximize connectivity as well as minimize the potential for having network
issues since all of our assessments are online so this form length
change will support the needs of specific groups of students allowing for such things as fewer breaks
more flexibility in scheduling for local educational agencies and also reduce the
potential for test security incidents just to name a few
and then continuing with some additional advantages lea's will continue to meet state and federal
testing requirements for english language arts and math the overall scores the scale scores and
achievement levels are still reported at the individual student level and they will continue
to be reported in support of the growth model calculations as well so all the claims as i
mentioned such as like reading writing listening research inquiry results will continue to be
provided for groups of 30 or more students on the public reporting website and this does in terms of
reclassification or usage for reclassification of the english language arts results the
reclassification guidance will not for english learners is not expected to be changed or impacted
so some advantages or disadvantages are that again i just want to reiterate that the individuals
claim categories will not be available this year the 21 22 school year and the summative
assessment target reports for groups of students will not be available as well however we will
conduct further analysis and it is anticipate that we can create or work with the smarter balance
assessment consortium that we could come up with composite claim categories for individual students
and the target reports for groups of students will be available in the following year the 22 23
school year so the recommended adjusted blueprint this table provides the recommended
adjusted blueprint for the english language arts test again the total number of items are provided
for reference at the top the first row indicates how many items the adopted for full form consisted
of and the second row indicates what is in the adjusted form so using the same rationale the
performance task item counts remain the same the difference is in the computer adapted items
and here are the claims first claim is reading second is writing a third is listening and the
fourth is research inquiry for the english language arts assessment
okay and then moving on to the estimated the recommended for math
again the total items by grade are provided for reference at the top
and again the first row indicates or shows how many items are in the adopted form for
the full form for math and then the second row indicates what is in the adjusted form
and in math the claims are concepts and procedures problem solving communicating reasoning modeling
and data analysis again the difference is in the computer adapted items or the cat portions
so i want to give some context to the estimated testing times for the smart balance summative
assessments we have shared this in the past i would like to revisit this table displays the
estimated testing times in hours and minutes by grade for both english language arts and
mathematics and then the combined time of both assessments as we cover there are no
projected shorter times for the performance tasks as they are unchanged however the testing
time is in the cat portion across all grades and tests and the last two columns show the
comparison of estimated testing times for the full form and the adjusted form so there's no
there is significant time savings especially at the upper grades and the second row is the
upper grades and although we have provided estimated testing times here these tests are
untimed that means you could take them and stop at a certain point pause the test and continue
where you left off in a different on a different day as i mentioned earlier the cde does not
recommend changes to other non-smarter balanced cask summative assessment blueprints as they are
much shorter so this table displays the estimated testing times in hours and minutes for the
california alternate assessments or caas for english language arts math and science and then
the california spanish assessment as well and the cast there is our regular science test
and this table here is the estimated testing times for summative lpac this test is already much
shorter in terms of estimated testing times summative lpac is about two hours or less than
two hours in the lower grades and about three hours for the upper grades
for the upper grades
so before we go on to the next steps i know that there have been concerns about the reduction of
proposing a continue to use the reduction in the in the adjusted blueprint i just want to
say that overall a reduction in the test blueprint does not mean a decrease in accuracy
all right we're very thoughtful about this process the assessments will continue to measure what it
is designed to measure the parents and guardians will continue to receive reports as one measure
or one data source of their students performance and schools and staff and families will continue
to be able to make observations and identify achievement gaps among groups of students
the overall student scores will continue to support the calculation of the growth model measures
and in discussing our next steps here we are recommending that the cd is recommending that
the spe approved the continued use of the smarter balance summative assessments for english language
arts and mathematics adjusted blueprints for this school year the 2021 and 22 with the intent that
we are going to use this in future years too it's just that at this temporary time we want to make
sure that we continue to further analyze the blueprints and evaluate and identify if there's
any additional changes that may be needed but at this point in time this is the adjusted blueprint
that we will continue to use and we will prioritize the comparability of data in future
years you know using as we use the adjusted blueprint and we'll continue to analyze the
data and propose the approach to maximize its use in growth model calculations
again the cd will continue to collaborate with the smarter balance assessment consortium because
that's how we get our english language arts and math assessments and this is a multi-year approach
and process we are going to explore the reporting of composite claim categories based on the analysis
of our of the content standards and the consortium wide data we are members of a consortium so these
composite claim categories are expected to allow california to meet peer review requirements and
expectations in english language arts and mathematics
and at this point i'm going to pause for a bit and have in bring up cindy kazanis the cde director
for our analysis measurement and accountability reporting division thank you mal good good morning
members of the board and welcome to our new members see my head's cut off there okay
i need to to be mouse size i am here today to talk a little bit about the interaction between
assessments and accountability and of course we are in constant communication and i just want to
acknowledge mal and the work of their division and helping us with so many things over the last
couple years specifically just in the context of assessments and our accountability system
for this year the 2020 california school dashboard just to make sure that we're on the same page we
are not producing state indicator data of course that's in direct response to the federal waiver
that we received as well as assembly bill 130 that was passed by the legislature and signed into law
by governor newsom we are committed and as an ab 130 does require us to post data that we determined
to be valid and reliable for the school year to support lea's in development of their local control
and accountability plans and so we'll do that through a variety of means including our dashboard
additional reports data quest or other reporting websites as we look ahead to 2022 and the dashboard
for this current school year we are looking at a state indicator display of status only based on of
course just the data from this school year and of course we're required under that federal waiver
to identify schools and ab 130 requires us to look at identifying districts using that data set
we will bring that to the board as we have more information next year and then with 2023 again
looking ahead a couple years the state indicators will go back to normal will produce not only status
but change and we'll have the performance colors based on the data from the two years because you
need the two years of data to create a color and why this is important is because we're headed
towards a student growth model and in giving just a brief update again for for new members especially
the board adopted the methodology for a student growth model this past may the model captures
academic growth for schools lea's and student groups for grades four through eight in both
english language arts and mathematics we used data historical data to construct this model
from the 2016 17 2017 18 and 2018 19 school years we are we did produce individual student
growth scores which have been shared with districts through our assessment operation
system called toms that was done at the beginning of summer we are working towards a public release
of our aggregate growth scores in later this month specifically this coming monday if you're
interested we're hosting a webinar to talk about our communications toolkit for the student growth
model as well as what to expect with the public release specifically how this affects that this
item affects growth model right now is that we need to have three years of consecutive data to
produce the growth model of course that's for the same students in our english using our english
language arts and mathematics assessment scores with this frame of reference in mind the soonest
we could produce this model would be 2024 that said we are already in the beginning of a school
year that is experiencing a lot of change a lot of turmoil and i just want to point out that we
are very dependent on the fact that students have to test come spring if we don't have a full testing
regiment of smarter balance this will be at risk so the participation rate is really important when
we think about producing a growth model three years from now but that said we are working really
closely with now we're working really closely with a testing contractor to make sure that any
adjustments to the assessments will not will not deter us from the goal of producing our first
growth scores using real data not historical data in 2024 but i'm happy to turn it back over to mal
thank you cindy
so with that i will give you a quick overview of our castman lpac updates because we're
constantly working and and developing and administering and communicating with the field
so we want to share some updates with you as well as you know the science
us test the california science test or cast is constantly being developed and having additions
just want to make you aware that we have some new cast range achievement level descriptors
webpage developed and deployed and the range alds or achievement level descriptors are really
detailed descriptions of observable evidence of student performance by grade and content
and they do they were developed to provide evidence of how students knowledge skills and
abilities change and become more advanced across the achievement levels so that is available
another update is that we have updated the item content specifications and with that we have about
175 let me see something the i like something that's wrong with the computer oh
yeah remind me tomorrow we're a little busy here so
yes and so we have about 175 item specifications for the cast and they do provide details on each
assessed dimension of a california next generation science standards or ngs as performance
expectation so the revisions were made to the science and engineering sub practice assessment
targets and the possible phenomena or context sessions sections another thing is that we're
implementing this year we are implementing the state board of education approved cast revised
blueprint that you had approved in january of 2020 but we were not able to implement it yet
due to what happened in 2019 as well as 2020-21 school years
another update is that we have the california alternate assessment for assessment for science
updates here i just want to let you know that this assessment already opened on september 7
remember they're embedded tasks that are administered close to instruction we have also
made some improvements in the area of the directions for administration to give
consistency across all the alternate assessments starting with this assessment and then we revised
the practice test to include two science connectors and to correspond with that structure
with the structure of the operational assessment so that they will be able to use that teachers
and students will be able to use that in the field and then there's also a new response
options for alternate assessments resource that was developed for test examiners and we encourage
educators and examiners to look at these resources so that it will help them have a smooth
administration another update that we bring to you on a regular basis are our interim
assessments for ele math it is part of our comprehensive assessment system and the three
types of the smarter balance interim assessments that are available are like i mentioned that
there are three types so there is the interim assessment comprehensive
the interim comprehensive assessments or we call icas sorry there's a lot of acronyms thrown at
you here but hopefully i will tell you what they are here the interim assessment blocks these are
smaller chunks of assessments based on assessment targets and then there's the focus ibs that are
also smaller blocks of assessment interim assessments but they are a little bit more
focused on a few assessment targets and we have for the whole state to use is we have over 200
interim assessments including 38 new focus ibs and they have been available since august 18th
the tools for teachers are formative assessment resource resources website is just want to share
a few or a couple formative assessment resource workshops that we've done with educators over the
summer and this is really to develop a formative assessment resource for the tools for teachers
resource for the tools for teachers we have the science workshops that were held in may and june
and 43 california science educators participated i'm happy to say that my staff here at the
division worked really hard to plan and lead this workshop along with the assistance of local
educational agency staff who served as team leads and coaches and then during the workshops the
educators participated educator participants they really worked in teams to develop new science
formative assessment resources for kindergarten through grade five for inclusion in the
tools for teachers website so again a few other little things each of the science resource was
developed was peer reviewed by other participants and coaches so they did a lot of work just wanted
to you know do a little shout out to our state because california is the first state to add
science resources to the smarter balance tools for teachers resources and more than 50 science
resources are available now in terms of the
english language arts and math workshops we did hold a few or in june and july as well
and there were 15 california state network of educator members we have a network of educators
when we say things like sne state network of educators we have a team of them across the
state they participated and then we also have three cde state lead leadership uh state leadership
team members that participated at this time we have more than 75 new english language arts and
math formative assessment resources developed at these workshops and they'll be available
later this fall in the tools for teachers
so
another um update that wanted to share with you is that in oh sorry i'm a little ahead of myself
is the alternate alpac um as a reminder the alternate alpac is designed specifically for
students with the most significant cognitive disabilities and um this assessment is aligned
with the 2012 california english language development or eld standards through the eld
connectors so the eld connectors provide an aligned expectation of students english language
proficiency that has been reduced in depth breadth and complexity to make sure they are
appropriate for english learners students with the most significant cognitive disabilities
so they the alternate alpac serve two purposes and the initial alternate alpac determines a
student's initial classification of either english learner or initial fluent english proficient
and the summative alternate alpac provides a measure of a student's annual progress toward
english language proficiency and support for decisions made on students reclassification
reclassification so once both the initial and summative alternate alpac are operationalized they
will replace the locally determined alternate assessments and we and will provide the statewide
consistent measurement of english language proficiency for this eligible group the alternate
alpac operational field test sorry i'm kind of flying by a lot of things but we have a lot to
cover today so why don't let you know and make you aware that we are as last year we we plan to
have the alternate alpac operational field test but due to conditions that you are aware of we
had to postpone this alternate alpac operational field test to this school year they will open on
november 1st through february 15th that is the window and to prepare for the field test we have
made online training available in our in the Moodle training site since last november and for this
fall we have scheduled question and answer sessions to provide local educational agencies
additional support and once the field test has been completed educators will participate in a
standard setting or in standard setting meetings in early spring of 2022 so the proposed threshold
scores are anticipated to come to the board of education in may of 2022 and then by july of next
year our hope is that the initial alternate alpac will launch and the summative alternate alpac will
launch in february of 2023
i mentioned a little bit about that about peer review earlier on our
blueprint section but this is really a peer review federal peer review update for you
on the federal peer review is really a process through which a state documents that it has met
federal law and requirements so under essa in the development and administration of its
assessments california has provided and submitted evidence for federal peer review for our english
language arts and mathematics assessments and for the alternate assessments for english language
arts and math as well and then we will provide an update with the results of the reviews when
they become available another thing is the first submission of the cast or the california science
test was initially scheduled for this summer but has been postponed till december of this calendar
year so another change that we wanted to be aware of is that there are california alternate
assessments are developed for students with the most significant cognitive disabilities and
and if a an individualized education plan team or ip team deems it's appropriate for a student
to take an alternate assessment the student is eligible for all the alternate assessments
so to assist the local educational agencies with this we have made some systems enhancements
to ensure uniformity of assignment of alternate assessments for the students who qualify
in our test operations management system so this is across the board for all the alternate
assessments and we have worked with our the multilingual support division as well as the
special education division in coming to this guidance almost there you're still with me
we're we're going to cover a little bit of the national and international assessments
updates in this next section
so one of the first assessments is our national assessment of educational progress or nape
nape is the largest nationally represented assessment and continuing assessment of what
us students know and can do in various subjects so since 1969 nape has been mandated by congress
and our california students do participate in nape every year and nape results are reported as
the nation's report card so depending on the assessment results may be at the national state
or large district level three of our california school districts participate in district level
nape and that is a fresno san diego and los angeles
so for this school year for 2022 approximately 550 schools are selected to participate
um grades four and eight will be participating in math and reading
and then grade eight will be participating in civics and u.s history and then there's also
nape also consists of age there's a age nine long-term trend math and reading assessments
um being administered just prior they this was supposed to be administered prior to the
covid pandemic however um we it was not so it's postponed until this year and results from this
2022 long-term trend assessment will allow for pre and post pandemic comparisons and then the
nape 2022 testing window is mid-january through march
uh an international assessment of reading it's called the progress
in international reading literacy survey or pearls um it is administered every five years in grade
four and pearls um did draw students from over uh 50 countries and the results are uh from this
assessment are used by researchers and policymakers to inform discussions of international
competitiveness uh 30 california schools have been selected to participate in pearls
and um it takes about three to three hours to complete so it's a it's not that uh short of a
assessment either and we'll be a minister in october so given the current conditions we're
not sure um how everything will be rolled out as well but we want to you be aware of this assessment
and then the program for international student assessment or pisa uh this is for 15 year olds
in reading math and science and financial literacy just to highlight some things 80 countries
participate or administer it every three years and again they are used to look at and form
international competitiveness when they can compare us to other countries and it really
takes about four hours for students to complete this one so there will be a field test this fall
however again about 10 schools are are selected to participate in this field test
and then the last international test we will cover is the trends in international mathematics
and science if you hear tim studies and comparing us to other countries the assessment is really
for fourth and eighth grade students in math and science uh over 65 countries participate
and um again it is really to inform us about international competitiveness in these uh
content areas this one takes about three hours so again this field test is planned for spring of
2022 and 10 schools have been selected to participate so um just i'm wrapping up here
um just reminding you to join us and follow us on the um assessment cde assessments twitter account
i will stop here for any questions or turn it over to our board president
thank you so much mao uh we'll um put up the slide for public comment now and we will take
some clarifying questions but we want to get the queue going for public comment uh members of the
public wishing to provide comment on this item can do so by calling the phone number and using
the access code provided on the slide that is shown now while we're waiting for members of the
public to call in i want to ask member sun if she has any initial comments before me and then
i'll check for clarifying questions before we go to public comment um member sun do you have
thank you thank you so thank you mal for a very thorough um presentation so i wanted just to speak
to the action portion of this item um with regard to the blueprints and the
action portion of this item um with regard to the blueprints um i fully support um a shorter
testing period time so um at the same time you know my my concern when i spoke to staff around
this was that it seemed like we had taken so much time to build up the blueprints and that it seems
very quickly that we are reducing the items so i was very glad to hear um mal and her team will
continue to do um analysis and to continue reviewing and looking at um the accuracy of these
uh the items and the reduction of the blueprint items um i also and working with the smarter
balance consortium as well um what i also wanted just to emphasize and that we're very clear to
lea's and to schools um that uh we had a pretty significant disruption after 2019 and so what
cindy was speaking to around looking at the growth sword not starting and resetting basically in 2020
2021 22 um i think that is right so for those schools and lea's that have did take the um casp
ele and math in the spring last year if they are looking at well our scores went higher or lower
than 2019 i think that uh there was enough disruption that we can't really say that you
can compare that these were apples to apples comparisons and so we want to make sure that
we understand that um that we had a significant change in this last year and that we should not
be trying to look back at the past and doing comparisons moving forward especially with
the changes in blueprints and everything else thank you appreciate that i want to thank mal
for not only her leadership on this item but her leadership over the whole year it's been an
intense and difficult year there's been a lot of adjustment needed mal you've done a terrific job
in helping us through uh wind our way through uh this process and appreciate the work to queue
us up for this year um i do uh favor the recommendation that is being brought to us to
adopt this shorter form i am very familiar with the technical advisory group that advises
the smarter balanced consortium they're an excellent and thoughtful group of
psychometricians they have looked at this and i know we can ask more questions of tony since
he's here if we need to uh but they um you know i feel confident in their judgment about the
stability and the reliability of the scores and i appreciate you having articulated the advantages
i do also want to note that um to the point that cindy kazanis made we are uh you know off to a
good start in the face of covid's delta variant this year relative to many other states and i'll
say more about that later but there is no um we've all become humble in terms of predicting the
future in the face of this this virus there are other variants yet to come and we want to
be able to use the test this year it's i think a sound judgment to go with the shorter form which
will make it more feasible more doable more manageable in whatever circumstances we have
this spring to ensure that we are able to assess students learning so i'm very much in favor of
this this um i think uh prescient um uh act and uh we will um hear more from the public and
get clarifying questions on the table before we deliberate i think that there may be a clarifying
question from member rucker yeah i thank you very much board president um darling ham and i have a
clarifying question for mal and also for cindy now when you were going through in explaining
the assessment times for the shortened smarter balanced assessment based on the blueprint you
identified the amount of time the administration of the items would of the assessment items would be
in each grade since the tests themselves are not timed for the students during the administration
if there are students who actually do take longer than the times that are shown in your chart they
will still be allowed that additional time they will if they want that they won't be cut off is
that true now we're sorry uh yes absolutely you have as much time as they need to take the test
within the window that their uh their district has determined yeah so i understand that so if
the assessment so within the assessment window if they want more time then what's shown on your
chart that's fine thank you i appreciate that clarification and then cindy my question to you
on clarification you spoke to when we anticipate the first time the growth model would actually be
able to give a report based on the idea that we would need three years of statewide assessment
data for the to use the growth model and so you said that that could happen in 2024 and if i
heard correctly i want to make sure i heard this correctly the only obstacle to that a likely
timeline could be some disruption or some problem with statewide assessments the changes that mal
talked about on the change in the blueprint or the length of the assessment itself or shortening
the smarter balance assessments have nothing to do with the timeline for implementing the growth
model is that correct yes and just a prior point about um the only the only thing would be the
disruption i i think to um president darlin hammon's comment earlier i i'm not going to
commit to anything on on that piece we are doing our best to make sure that you know we have as
little disruption as possible but you're absolutely right as far as the the test length and such that
should not impact the growth model it's something that we've been keeping an eye on like i said
with mal and the psychometricians and the experts growth model experts at ets so
we are we are all you know forward looking um ready to produce something come 2024
assuming that again we have testing for three consecutive years okay thank you very much
i do see other hands and i just want to remind all of our members that we are only doing clarifying
questions right now so anything that is more deliberative we're going to wait till after
public comment but i do have hands here for member burr and member patil bralsen
member burr
and you are on mute
i was so articulate too i know thank you um i just want to clarify first just to point out
in the item itself the the written item there i feel like there's a lot more rationale for the
recommendation that i would just want to call people's attention to but in that right right up
i just also wanted to clarify that the blueprints we're being asked to approve here are identical
to the blueprints that we used last year again in the face of a raging pandemic that we have no way
of predicting whether or not it's going to end this spring so that that was my clarifying question
are those identical the second one and maybe is a question for tony but i think mal could answer it
as well how many other states in the consortium are have gone to a shortened uh assessment thank
you i believe tony is on but the question to your the first part of your the answer to the first
question you have is yes oh the uh answer to the first question that you had is yes the the
adjusted blueprint we're bringing forward is identical to the one we used in 2021
and tony i don't have the number committed to memory so if you are available if you could
share how many other member states yeah thank you oh go ahead go ahead brooks
oh thank you mal um uh for the record this is tony alpert uh president darling hammond and and
members uh member burr i believe i i don't have the exact number but i believe seven states
used the uh some form of the adjusted blueprint uh last year we anticipate that many if not all
of those states are going to continue the use of the adjusted blueprint this spring but we haven't
we haven't surveyed that and i think a lot of states are in a similar position still trying
to have those conversations with uh critical policymakers and
and uh and stakeholders uh about what should happen this spring
and um did did we get all of your questions answered
okay i'll go ahead then to member proteo bronson thank you um i just was looking um back at slides
11 and 12 um around uh both what parents would receive and then also what reporting would happen
for groups of 30 or more so if if you could share your thoughts on that and then we'll move on to
and then also what reporting would happen for groups of 30 or more so if you could just clarify
what would parents receive in 21 22 um versus what they'd receive in 22 23 um and then on
slide 11 i think it says that the claims um would be uh released for groups of 30
um but then on slide swell 12 it says that the assess summative assessments for groups
of 30 won't be available and i just if you could clarify the timeline for that as well
yes i can do that what parents and students will receive the overall uh performance scores
the scale scores as well as the achievement level um scores at the individual student level
while we continue to look at reporting out at the composite claims in 2023 the following year
so the claim results when we group them by groups of students of 30 or more on the public reporting
site you'll see in the claims of reading writing research inquiry or listening for under english
language arts they can't be done at the individual level for the adjusted form
in this current state however we can do that at the group level at the state level to give you
an indication of how students um performed in those areas and that will be publicly reported
so sorry for purposes of what parents would receive in 21 22 does that mean they'd get for
example school level data and aggregate state level data yeah those will be public information
but in terms of their individual student score reports they will um they'll be able to see how
their students perform um and the scale score that the student received and their achievement level
the levels of you know um not met standard at or near standard met standard and exceeded standard
so they'll still receive those achievement levels as well as the scale score and where
the student score landed on the on the range of scale in and that would happen in 21 22 still
yes it will happen in the 2021 we are providing that to parents thank you and maybe just to add
to the clarification there the the scores that would not be available for this year only are
the claim scores which are the sub scores for particular sub elements of the broader ela and
math uh let's move to public comment then uh and so uh do we have any public comment
yes we do have public comment
very good
good
hello caller please state your name and affiliation for the record
you have one minute your time begins now
caller ending in eight nine four five your time begins now
so
are you there caller
hello caller please state your name and affiliation for the record
you have one minute your time begins now
now
my name is brexie low price from ed voice ed voice recommends the board reject a proposed
blueprint and request other options be presented to reduce test taking time losing key summative
data makes it more difficult to gauge performance on key standards and more difficult to tackle
equity of opportunity and identify achievement gaps across subgroups this is not a wise balance
of testing time with actionable data for teachers and parents there are other ways to balance
testing time in item constructs to collect meaningful summative data the proposed blueprint
will likely force lea's into redundant summative testing at the end of the year when loss of
instructional time is of greatest concern lack of comparable data could also delay the implementation
of the student growth model during these times schools should be providing parents with more
information about student performance not less thank you
hello caller please state your name and affiliation for the record
you have one minute your time begins now
good morning jessica saco on behalf of children now welcome new board members
i'd also like to learn the comments with the previous speaker i'd also like to thank you
for the inclusion of the presentations and his casanova to the potential impact of this
recommendation on the development of the growth model while i appreciate the assurance that the
assessment results from the short form are accurate they do not yield results with the
same level of position as the full form particularly as it relates to the crane category
currently the starting smarter website refers to these parents offers resources and information
to families on supporting their students based on the distinct crane categories children now is
concerned that the continued use of the short form will not provide families with the detailed
level of information they need as well as it's becoming a more permanent change i asked the
board to recall that the decision to administer a short form assessment was made in a time of
emergency and was never intended to be made permanent i will conclude with the question
which is will the short form assessment yoga laxile and quantile scores yielded from the
full form assessment that were to be added to the student score report thank you
hello caller please state your name and affiliation for the record you have one minute your time begins
now good morning my name is michael juba and i'm a classroom teacher representing the california
teachers association cta strongly supports the cde's recommendation to continue to use a shorter
adjusted blueprint for the smarter balance some of the assessments in dla and mathematics
for the 2021-22 administration and beyond the cde's recommendation will provide several benefits
for students and teachers first reducing the number of questions in the computer adaptive
portions of the test will shorten the overall length of the test and reduce testing time
second shorter testing blocks will give teachers and schools additional flexibility in how they
administer the same assessments and finally we believe that the most accurate and actionable
indicators of an individual student's mastery standards will come from the multiple local
measures used by teachers that are embedded within the classroom thank you
hello caller please state your name and affiliation for the record you have one minute your time begins
now i am not just members of telephone news together i also welcome new board members
our organization supports the intent of using shorter assessments which would reduce the amount
of time students stand on the summative assessment providing for increased instructional time
especially this year as well as more flexibility and scheduling for adequate monitoring we
understand that the adaptive portion and the integrated performance task of each task will
be maintained and overall scale scores and achievement levels will be comparable to those
of prior year however we need a better understanding of the impact that implementation
of a shorter test would have on the implementation of the growth model specifically if we revert to
the full test next year will we be able to use the two versions of the test to confuse the growth
model the board should not take any action that would further delay the implementation of the
growth model thank you
hello caller please state your name and affiliation for the record
you have one minute your time begins now
good morning dr darlin handing the board members i'm going to do the association of california
school administrators acts of force what cde's recommendation to meet the s back suggested
and for the 21 22 administration the jessica blueprint for strike the right balance at this
time as the covid 19 pandemic continues to do the short assessment educators will have additional
time to focus on accelerating student learning improving student mental and social emotional
health while also collecting the necessary data to enhance student learning thank you
you
hello caller please state your name and affiliation for the record you have one
minute your time begins now
so
caller ending in nine five seven one it is your time to speak
speak
hello caller please state your name and affiliation for the record you have one
minute your time begins now
now
this is see van couie of the charter schools development center we support the goals of the
shortened test and appreciate the consideration of strains on schools at this time we are
concerned about achieving confidence in the data as well as clarity about what various
cast metrics do and do not mean confidence and clarity are important to understanding schools
successes and opportunities system-wide does the metric show students absolute performance
growth or schools relative value added to school here's an example of how lack of clarity
has high stakes impacts last spring a charter school was closed that actually achieved growth
scores above the state average almost across the board the school had been labeled low performing
however based on distance from standard scores this led to confusion and ultimately to the
closure of a school achieving above average growth for 800 students this is a sign that we need to
do more to achieve system-wide understanding about this data we ask that the board direct
the cde to improve clarity about what metrics do and don't do to achieve greater system-wide
hello caller please
hello caller please state your name and affiliation for the record you have one minute
your time begins now
good morning my name is raselli simian and i'm with the fairing organization network
i'm calling to recommend for the board to reject the proposed actions and shorting the math and
english language of art assessments for spring 2022 as an organization that represents parents
we want full and accurate information about the the performance of our students and that's critical
this year especially when a lot of families are experiencing variance in the quality of education
depending on the program depending on whether they chose for their children to return to school
return to in person or whether they chose um at any point they choose independent studies
and so having a full information is key so that we can better support students
and so we recommend doing the full assessments as usual thank you
that is the end of our public callers
all right thank you very much um we'll now begin board discussion uh and board members please
remember to raise your hand in the participant panel of zoom if you have a question or comment
i see a couple of them are uh raised i do want to start uh and ask one clarifying question myself
before we get going with uh the full board discussion and this is for cindy kazanis um cindy uh
earlier you talked about the importance of having stable growth measures my understanding
i believe that you were heard to be uh by some callers to be in opposition to this
recommendation in that concern but i thought i understood that if we did this we would also
be considering continuing the short form in the future so they would be comparable
so i just want you to clarify uh if i understood correctly and um what your um major point was
happy to clarify my major my major point was we are absolutely in support of this recommendation
we are working very closely with our assessments division and our testing contractor to ensure that
any future changes to these assessments will have as little impact as possible on the growth
model so that we can use the consecutive years of data to produce something in 2024
great thank you um i will now um start um the board discussion and we have uh member escapado
and member patil bronson um in the queue so member escapado great thank you president darling hammon
um you just just a a thought about i know one of the major disadvantages of going to a certain
assessment is the individual claim scores i'm just a thought i applaud what we're doing informative
assessments and i just wonder if we can amplify those workshops so that these claims scores can
be created through the format assessment and and and i think we can never um as an organization
we also have to magnify formative assessment as much as our summative assessments that
it is truly during these formative assessments when we actually will be able to
monitor student growth and second um with parents i i know um there's always
a lack of understanding of sometimes the results i know our organizations have have clips to help
parents understand the scores and i i just hope that there's
messaging for parents and the changes and what are these changes and what these changes mean
and then how can parents help their students giving them ideas and how to help their students
once they receive these assessments thank you thank you and and i thank you for mentioning
the formative and i'll also add a mention of the interim assessments smarter balance has built out
quite extraordinary repertoire of both formative and interim assessments that do allow educators
to drill down and see how students are doing you know within those individual claims and even
below that level within particular content and topic areas so we do have those tools we are
working hard to make sure that people can use them effectively and so that is a an important
part of the system as a whole member glover woods it looks like um member batia brunson you
took your hand down because it was still up from before is that right okay member glover woods
thank you president darlin ham and good morning again i just wanted to share my support as well
for the shortened form i know it's been mentioned that we approved that shortened blueprint
really as a response to the emergent situation with the pandemic and what we do know is that
even though students have returned to in-person instruction which is absolutely wonderful
the school year has had a varying type of start if you will as unfortunately students and staff
have contracted the virus or people have needed to be quarantined so there's still a lot of
uncertainty as was mentioned in president darlin ham and comments being able to approve the
shortened form of the shortened blueprint really provides lea's with the opportunity to start
planning now what those testing schedules would need to look like in the spring in case there
needs to be some mitigation and result to making sure that everybody is safe so i definitely want
to be sure that we keep that in mind and also as has been mentioned in some other comments
the fact that there are local assessments as well formative assessments that are being
administered at schools that will continue to provide additional information to students and
their performance so we're excited we want to be able to have the smarter balance assessments
administered in the spring we know those summative assessments are important that
combined with the interim assessments and formative assessments at the local level
should provide schools as well as parents a lot of good information on how children are doing this
year thank you very much and just for those who may not have been present during our deliberations
last spring one of the challenges we had was the length of the smarter balance tests in terms of
being able to get them accomplished during the pandemic so given that we can't entirely predict
that is an important part of being sure we can move forward with assessments this year i have
many folks who want to get in the conversation i'll just let you know we're a little behind
schedule so i'll ask you to keep your remarks to the point so we can get to a motion
the member rucker member rodriguez member bananca and member strouse
thank you very much i will just say i was also struck by the report from now about the other
assessments that will be added to the assessment schedule in school so there's the pisa the pearls
the tems and all of these are for purposes of research and developing comparative information
about the performance of our school instructional plant programs as well as the attainment of skills
and knowledge among our students and so with all of these assessments and given the length of them
in addition to the local assessment activities as well as the formative assessment activities
it seems that as we go into this school year where there's a lot of changes that students
are tasked to cope with what has not changed is the multiple assessment environment that students
also need to contend with so let me just suggest that as we as this school year goes forward and
districts are doing the struggle of dealing with the struggles that they are coping with in reality
and in real time on a day-to-day and hour-by-hour basis that we also understand that while we sit
here and operate at the 5 000 foot level the reality of all these additional assessments
and the assessment environment that we are asking students to function well in we need to consider
not only what we're tasking students to do but what we are taxing students in doing all of these
assessments so i do have that concern even though it is something that is important
and significant i would just ask us to consider the question is all of this additional frenetic
activity for assessment and testing actually required and necessary that is an important
question for all of us to consider let me just clarify if in case people are counting up all of
those assessments that anyone involve any schools the small number of schools involved in tims or
pisa or nape are not the same schools so we will not have any children taking all of those tests
we will have a small number of schools each taking one of them but it is a valid point always to
worry about the total impact of assessment member rodriguez thank you president darlene hamond
and i want to echo what's already been said so i won't repeat it and i'll just say that with my
experience as a classroom teacher currently working with students i i'm in support of this
recommendation and i appreciate this recommendation very much because i have you know firsthand
information of the assessments that we as teachers are giving our students right now
and also what our students are going through and i'd like to thank mao definitely and cindy for
their presentation and also wish dr zilbert a great retirement and thank you for your contributions
and offer my deepest condolences to michelle glippa michelle glippa's family members and
thank you thank you very much member bananca yeah so first of all i want to thank the cd for
putting together such an informative and detailed presentation and just to add along to the support
on this recommendation with like a student perspective of someone who did take the cask
test last year with the shortened blueprints i found that this shortened test was absolutely
beneficial to my class from what i observed many students especially those connecting from home
had trouble with tech issues or internet issues which definitely slowed them down and i was one of
those students that did get slowed down i started my test about halfway through the class period
so this shortened period or this shortened version of the test gave us the flexibility though
to account for that that loss of time because of these internet issues which allowed more
students to fully complete the test in the time that we were given in class so i think that it is
important to note that while there might be somewhat of a trade-off in how detailed the reports are
this is offset by the fact that more students are able to fully complete their tests in class
in addition if some students and some districts were to go back to quarantine obviously we can't
predict covid so this might happen i think that this blueprint would be more equitable in that
the students with internet issues are probably going to be disproportionately
socioeconomically disadvantaged and rural students so in terms of equity i think this
recommendation would definitely improve the equity among students so all in all i really
support this recommendation and i think it would be a great benefit to students this year
thank you so much member strouse
so i want to thank the ct team for an amazing thorough and comprehensive presentation and i
do think ensuring this out with county offices and out with districts we could help them
and understand all the information that was part of this item and just for the public to know that
this presentation is available but i think we have a responsibility to communicate out to the field
i think we have a responsibility to communicate out to the field the comprehensiveness and the
variety of assessment options and all the work that we're doing secondly i appreciate the
clarification around the growth model which we've been working on for five years and the intent that
we are going forward with the growth model i think there was some questions from the letters
about that and i just wanted to clarify that we have every intent of using this for the growth
model this reliable data is going to provide us important information and i just appreciate
dr excavator's comments as well as dr global woods comments on formative assessments and how
important that is in the process this is going to give us a point in time that schools use for lots
of instructional reflection and planning but the work that we do ongoing with students every day
to inform their the instructional decisions and support for students who need help that's the
whole picture and i think that we have to remember that this is one type of assessment and the
formative assessments and the opportunities to inform our teaching and learning are really
critical particularly as everyone has noted that this coming back we didn't come back fully the
way we expected to and that this year is continuing to be challenging for everybody so again i want to
thank you for a thorough presentation and i support the recommendation thank you thank you
and i'll just take the opportunity to reinforce the point that you made that the growth model is
an ongoing commitment and the reliability of the total score on the smarter balanced
assessments will not be affected by this decision and we were never going to use the claim scores
for the growth model so that does not this does not undermine our ability to continue our plans
for the use of the growth model uh but uh member petio bronson your hand is up again right yeah
that's correct thank you um so thank you to to mel for uh the presentation and for also um
clarifying so much of of uh material that is quite dense um uh i i particularly wanted to
lift up i think one of the points that board member escapado had just lifted which is that
there are multiple measures and there are formative and interim assessments that are
being made available at the level of school community leaders who are on the instructional
side and i think we just need to be more intentional about how we share that same information with
parents and with community members because the multiple measures the richness of what multiple
measures offers is sometimes not reaching parents and community members and in the same way that
we were just uh hearing from um board member strauss about the need to and responsibility
to communicate out all of that information to the school community that has to also crest into
families into community members um as well thank you sorry i'll also just say i i very much
appreciate um many of the uh comments that were uh mailed in and emailed in about how this also
reclaims more instructional time which i think is just absolutely necessary given given the last year
thank you so much so i'm going to see if someone wants to make a motion
member rodriguez yes i would like to make a motion and i'll second i was too late to get my
off mute all right we have a motion to uh i assume to accept the recommendation of the cde yes and a
second to that motion uh is there any further discussion uh hearing none uh we'll take a
roll call vote brooks can you call the roll member son aye vice president strauss
aye member rucker yes member rodriguez yes member patillo brownson yes member mcquillan yes
member glover woods yes member escobedo yes president darlinham yes member burr
aye member bonanca aye motion passes unanimously all right thank you so much and thank you mal for
that presentation uh and we're now going to go back to agenda item number one which is our
state board priorities item and i'm going to turn it over to state superintendent tony thurman to
provide his report superintendent thank you president darlinham and members of the board
mr alan i would like to welcome the new board members dr escobedo who we've had the chance
to visit many times in his role as superintendent at chula vista one of the bright spots recognized
by dr darlinham and and others for incredible work on closing learning gaps and a great partner
for us in showing the way on how our schools can get open and keep our students safe great to see
you and congratulations dr escobedo and congratulations to our board member bonanca it's
here we are congratulating you at this meeting but it feels like you've already begun your service
long underway incredible leadership that you have provided including the opportunity to work with
you and many other youth leaders in our conversations about engaging young people
to get a vaccine thank you for your thoughtful comments it is a pleasure to have you here i'd
like to ask the board members if we could just take a moment to acknowledge that on this week
we will celebrate the anniversary of september the 11th and to recognize many who lost their lives
including many californians who lost their lives and to recognize those in public safety who also
lost their lives trying to secure safety and security for those so if we could with your
concurrence madam president just a moment a brief moment of silence as we celebrate that anniversary
thank you for your recognition as you all know this is the first board meeting since all of our
california schools have opened 10 000 of them it has been as you all have noted quite the experience
let me just be strength-based and start out by saying i've had a chance to visit a dozen or so
districts in the state of california and i've had a chance to visit a dozen or so districts
saying i've had a chance to visit a dozen or so districts going back to july since they've opened
including julia vista elementary school district to see great things and i have to tell you
even with the challenges that we're experiencing with the delta variant the in the energy for a new
school year has been incredible i have to tell you that at every single district that i have visited
and i know that dr darling hammon has done as well upwards of 90 to 95 percent of the students
have returned their families eager to get our students back for in-person instruction there's
no question that we have to continue to monitor the impacts that the delta variant can have and
we have to do everything that we can to accelerate the uptake of vaccines in this state and in this
country to help keep everyone safe but what our schools are doing is just beyond heroic and
i just want to acknowledge every educator first with our students for their resilience their
teachers and classified staff our administrators our parents our volunteers everyone is working
hard to make this work the legislature has given new guidance for how i would say the almost five
percent of california students who are requesting some form of remote education the legislature has
given us ab 130 which allows them to do that through independent study and the independent
study guidelines have been refreshed to allow for additional ways to ensure that students get
support that as as member bonanca said that students have access to computers and high
speed internet that someone is monitoring their progress as you probably have heard
independent study has quickly become the way for families that need to quarantine
to stay connected with their schools and it's been difficult i'll just acknowledge that none
of us has ever lived through a pandemic before there's no blueprint for how to do this it has
been difficult at times and we must acknowledge that but again also acknowledge their heroic
efforts of everyone to get our schools open and to keep everyone safe including all of our public
health advocates the california department of public health who we've worked with in the
governor's office to secure five million rapid covid tests that our schools can use for free by
the way they've all been used up and now we're working closely with the department of public
health to get more of those tests and of course the legislature and the governor have provided
billions to our schools to purchase all the covid mitigations that they need we've gone through many
webinars showing schools how to get open how to do outdoor classrooms how to use more ventilation
how to sanitize the campuses at the end of the day this is the moment and there is nothing more
important than what we do around covid mitigations and of course putting in place the kind of mental
health and social emotional resources that we must provide our students and our educators
and our families to deal with the trauma that covid 19 has created we'll talk more about that
but obviously the state budget has provided some four billion dollars for mental health
three billion dollars for community schools and it is an honor for the california department
of education and state board and others to be working to implement how these programs will be
there to support our students just a word on vaccinations it's a game changer we continue
to work on how to increase the rates to vaccination in our state we've made this
a mainstay of our conversations about how to get schools open keep them open keep us all safe
we've held a number of town halls focused on vaccines we've had a number of vips and celebrities
helping us get the word out a man a number of elected officials help us get the word out
we held a town hall where we reached out to more than half a million people in los angeles county
which has some of the highest rates of covid infection and we literally held a vaccine town
hall with more than 60 000 participants where we talked about vaccines where we've offered vaccine
incentives for those to get a vaccine we continue to support the efforts of everyone
to get a vaccine for everyone who is 12 and older at the same time that we're dealing with delta
variant many of our families are dealing with the devastation of wildfire and i just have to
acknowledge so many who've been impacted by wildfire and we've had the opportunity on last week
to visit with students and families and educators in eldorado county and in particular those who've
been impacted by the calador fire and it is devastating to be in communities where an entire
community has been leveled and where schools have been burned down and homes have been burned down
but i want to commend our students and their families and their educators for their resilience
and their creativity in finding ways to support student learning even under the most difficult
circumstances and of course i have to acknowledge our first responders our firefighters who have
been working relentlessly to stem and contain these fires and congratulate them on their most
recent progress in the tahoe area and in many other communities and allowing some families
to return i want to thank our our partners at the california department of education foundation
california is dedicated to education foundation for helping us to raise dollars to bring resources
to those families we were able to provide them with gas cards hotel vouchers food and of course
books and our visit to eldorado county our students were in the library they were reading
they were learning they were having support and so even in the face of adversity our students
persist and continue to learn let us continue to do all that we can to support our families
who are impacted by wildfire who are impacted by the many challenges that has been presented to us
by covet 19 in these last 18 months i want to acknowledge that during the pandemic we have
created a new youth advisory council a statewide youth advisory council we've launched this to
create voice to hear from our students on all matters related to education i'm asking these
students to advise me and my staff to advise the governor and the legislature in all matters and of
course we would like to create an opportunity for our newly forming statewide advisory council
youth advisory council to have a chance to present and have dialogue with you the members of the
state board to discuss policies and to amplify the great messages that you're already getting
from board members like board member ananka we will also be launching a first ever statewide
parent advisory council to create a formal structure for parents to give more voice on
matters related to education and we're excited to partner with many education advocates we're
excited to have created during the pandemic our first ever family engagement division families
let us know what you heard from board member banaka how during the pandemic technology issues
were a challenge how families weren't always connected to school and so we've created this
family engagement unit to help us think about how to steer through some of the big challenges that
we're seeing including enrollment decline how do we help students maximize attendance support our
families with the resources that they need get access to tools and resources more to come on
those subjects i want to acknowledge some transitions our general counsel keith yamanaka
retired after 42 years of state service thank you keith for your incredible service i want to let
you know that our new general counsel is someone who is not new to cde and has incredible experience
and has worked closely with the state board none other than our own amy holloway who returns to the
office who served at cde for more than two decades in our legal division and already is making great
things happen as many of you know two familiar faces that you've worked closely with at the
state board have taken new jobs and have gotten great new opportunities rachel maves is now in
leadership at the tennessee department of education in dr shaneen coats has taken a position
at the sacramento county office of education also in leadership we want to thank them for their
work on you know the model ethnic studies curriculum guide and as you heard from president
darling ham and all the work that's happened on assessments during the pandemic i can't imagine a
more intense way big shout out to rachel maves and of course to you now and to your entire team
and cindy kazanis and others who've done this work with these changes we've taken the opportunity
to make some changes to how our branches are laid out to create some efficiency and greater
alignment i want to just tell you a little bit about it and just remind you of some of the faces
of folks who will be leading that work we introducing you to some deputies who've already
met who've already been at cde who will be taking on some of the work that comes from what was our
primary our teaching and learning branch i'd like to reintroduce you to dr daniel lee who will be
heading up what is a newly created equity branch we've taken this opportunity to create a branch
on equity and to create within that a whole child division these are first for cde and it's a
pleasure to introduce to you will reintroduce to you dr lee who is now heading up formally that
equity branch as you know he is both a clinical psychologist a school psychologist an educator
for more than two decades i'm gonna give him a few minutes to share just a few thoughts about
the work that he will now be leading in this equity branch which will include our our college
and career transitions division and our student achievement and support division dr lee a word
well good morning and thank you president i'm darlin hammond and board members for this moment
i want to thank the superintendent for the opportunity to sort of organize our first equity
branch at the department you know i think most of the faces i don't feel as new because i looked
around and said i know most of the faces on the screen so that feels good and i'm looking forward
to working with everyone on other projects as we move forward i think one of the pieces i do want
to highlight oops is that we are working on some major projects in our branch primarily community
schools is a big one and and with the governor's investment and we're also working with layla and
other school board members to think through the behavioral health initiatives so i'm really
excited about the work we can do to center education around all of these major initiatives
so we can promote healthy learning environments and positive school communities and and have great
outcomes for students so thank you for your time thank you dr lee and for those of you who remember
dr lee and pam kodaki led during the height of the pandemic a new initiative under the equity
branch called education to end hate how do we use training around implicit bias to address bias in
our schools and of course we started with our own organization at the california department of
education thank you dr lee for that word about community schools thank you dr linda darling
hammond for your advocacy to help us get to what has become three billion dollars for community
schools i think we'll be talking about a lot uh next up i'd like to invite uh cheryl cotton who's
been deputy superintendent for human resources um to just have a quick word among other things she
uh is overseeing our state special schools where we serve deaf and blind students and she can give
you a word about how we've been able to stand up these schools even in the face of the delta
variant but i want to remind you that cheryl cotton is an educator for more than two decades
she has served as a classroom teacher she has served as a principal she has served as a county
level administrator and she is committed to the principles of teaching and learning and equity
and she will also now oversee the divisions that focus on assessment and curriculum frameworks just
to name a few but a quick word from cheryl cotton hello um to our state superintendent
um of public construction tony thurman it's not on yes we can hear you cheryl
okay um i just want to say thank you both to our state superintendent of public instruction
for this opportunity as well as to our president of the state board of education linda darling
hammon and our state board members our staff and members of the public i just want to say thank you
for this moment i do support our state special schools and services division i'm delighted to
report to you that our state special schools and diagnostic centers have reopened this fall
including the school for the deaf in riverside the school for the deaf in fremont this school
for the blind in fremont also as well as the diagnostic centers north central and south
i'd like to note that the state special schools did reopen in the spring and they held summer
programs as well residential and day students are excited to be back for in-person instruction and
we're taking all necessary precautions to safely return to in-person instruction our safety
precautions were established our partnerships with cdph and local public health agencies
we've instituted a twice weekly covid testing cadence particularly for unvaccinated students
and staff but also it's available to all with testing support from bestra we have the indoor
use of face coverings appropriate air filtration regular hand washing and intensive cleaning
we've ensured that vaccinations were available to all of our students and staff as well
we continue to monitor and support in-person instruction at our state special schools thank you
thank you cheryl uh and next i just want to reintroduce you to mary nicely uh who many
you have known who has worked closely with me on the task force on closing the digital divide she
literally helped to source uh upwards of a million devices for our school districts at a time
when there just weren't any available from the manufacturers in in the month of august
she became she had been leading our superintendent special initiatives office in the month of august
she became deputy superintendent with a focus on technology and innovation also in the month of
august i named her as our co-chief deputy superintendent and you gracefully hopefully
will be confirming her today in an item that is on this agenda i'll just say this that mary has
taken on the task of helping to address our cradle to career needs for technology for our
students at cde she's working very closely with our technology division that is i think far
beyond any in terms of what they have done during this pandemic to give us the platforms to speak
to listen to and educate our state but technology requires all kinds of vision and support and she's
someone who has a background in working in data management and so for those reasons we were excited
that she will be working very closely with our analysis and measurement division our educational
data division and our technology services division a quick word uh from mary nicely
thank you state board members and superintendent thurman for this opportunity
today i'd like to just give you a quick update on as cd moves forward as the cornerstone of the
california cradle to career data system supplying 70 percent of the data through our calpads data
collection system during the 18 months of meetings almost all via zoom i'd like to thank wested for
facilitating all of these meetings incredible work was done by every education segment and 15
state agencies to develop a governance structure build a data dictionary discuss legal agreements
cyber security as well as take in massive amounts of input from partners across the state
and lay out the technical groundwork for moving this cradle to career system thanks to my fellow
work group members cindy kazanis sarah neville morgan and sarah petrowski for representing our
agencies so well and ensuring our voices were heard loud and clear thank you to the dozens
of cd staff that sat on the numerous subcommittees and prepared us well for these meetings
and i'd like to say that jerry winkler director of cd's data education data management division
will represent cd on the the cradle to career governing board as we move forward into the
more technical aspects of the cradle to career cd has formed a information and technology branch
as the superintendent mentioned to not only ensure the most efficient and forward thinking
implementation of technology and data and data for the cradle to career system but to modernize
cd's internal and external facing systems i look forward to regularly updating the board on progress
of the cradle to career data system and other efforts to update our technology to better
serve our families students educators and staff thank you for this opportunity
thank you mary so many things have happened during the since even just the last meeting
and i want to acknowledge that on yesterday the ab101 a bill that we sponsored to bring
ethnic studies as a graduation requirement has now been passed in both houses and want to thank
you all for ratifying the model ethnic studies curriculum guide that guide had created the
had created the pathway for there to be an ethnic studies graduation requirement in our state and so
we want to thank you for that we know that there'll be much work that will need to be done to help in
implementing that there's also so much work that has happened to have the incredible successes that
we heard about in the announcement of the state budget like universal pk and i know that's important
to so many of you who work in the field i see you beaming and smiling board member patil gronson
i you know i know that many of you know that we could not have steered some of that without
incredible leadership of everyone in our early learning and care division under the direction
of our deputy superintendent sarah neville morgan who has just put this on her shoulders all at a
time when there was a major transition happening in programs with all child care programs moving
to the department of social services a difficult move but an opportunity to create alignment that's
going to mean more efficiency for families who are supported by the various programs that are
subsidized child care programs connect to just have to acknowledge incredible leadership of sarah
neville morgan and of lisa constancio and her teams all these conversations about how to create
independent study how to address the issues of ada all of those come from places like our school
and fiscal services division incredible work by elizabeth deirstein by our fazzy division i mean
budget work that has been done by lisa and her staff and fazzy we have to acknowledge you we
have to acknowledge our newly created emergency team that has worked with all of our communities
that have been impacted by wildfire it has been incredible the work that wan and his team have
led and we just have to acknowledge how difficult this time has been for everyone and i just want
to thank and acknowledge the entire cde team for the way that you all continue to respond the way
that you show up it's a hard job and it's hard for me to share this with you but i also have to
acknowledge one more transition and that is for our chief our other chief co-chief deputy
superintendent dr stephanie grexon who some of you may have heard has taken a position at cce
you'll be missed dr grexon dr grexon is in the chamber and so i want to acknowledge her
in the presence of all of you many of you have worked with her over the course of her five years
going all the way back to her helping to shape the work on the history of social sciences framework
to help launch what became our model ethnic studies curriculum guide to work on the health
frameworks to work on literacy and of course the last 18 months of trying to help steer districts
in the right direction on how to manage survive and continue to educate during the pandemic she's
written an incredible guide for school reopening and has taken countless meetings with stakeholders
on how we support them what's not known about cde is that it is just a job unto itself managing
what is 2 000 employees focusing on reporting for focusing on support on technical assistance
and the chief deputy is someone who has to manage all of that i'm grateful to you dr grexon for
managing that we'll miss you but we hope that your new role at cce as the deputy executive director
gives us an opportunity to work even more closely with you and with cce and so would you all please
join me in acknowledging our chief deputy superintendent dr grexon maybe she's smiling
this is her last board meeting but we'll invite you back so that you can be on the dais again and
have to present to this group but we want to all thank you for your incredible service and leadership
at the california department of education we look forward to working closely with you
in your new role congratulations dr grexon and and with that president darling hammond i'd like
to turn it back to you if you and the board members wish to have a word for dr grexon
self off of mute i'll see if any board members would like to
make their own thanks and i'll start with member burr and then vice president strouse
thank you president darling hammond um i actually have a dual responsibility here
as the chair of cce to say how delighted we are to have dr grexon join the collaborative
um as superintendent thurman said i think this will only strengthen what is already a very strong
relationship between the two organizations i want to express my appreciation to the superintendent
to the superintendent for his renewed commitment for the to the cce we really look forward to his
participation as we move forward but stephanie i think you know how much i think of you i've had
the pleasure of working with stephanie over all of the years on the board and prior to that as
executive director and her talents in curriculum instruction and professional development are
really uh without compare and especially her her relationships with people make it so important
to get these very difficult issues resolved and coherent policies created so stephanie delighted
to welcome you i will miss you in this role but i look forward to seeing you in my other role
thank you vice president strouse so um first of all stephanie um so i just would say
you have had quite a ride in the last five years as um superintendent thurman was discussing the
health framework the ethnic studies history social sciences were not easy processes and i
just so appreciate your leadership and calmness to pursue through the process and to get us where
we are today we actually have some really wonderful guidance documents that will really help the field
going forward and i think your commitment from theory to practice will really translate well at
cce so you helped develop the theory and the policy documents and with your work as a school
principal and a district administrator and a state administrator i think you just bring so much to
cce as we help districts decide how to manage and move forward in their challenges as well so
i just want to thank you for your commitment to the students of california and your continued
commitment in your new role i think new opportunities always give us new challenges
and kind of renewed opportunities um both in the organization you're going to and and then the or
the staff who remains to think about the legacy you leave i'll just make one other comment um i
just want to thank i know rachel mays was only with us for 18 months but she did a tremendous
job during the pandemic her voice and experience as a small district superintendent county
super administrator at the state board was wonderful and helping cd and i i wish her only
the best in tennessee as she helps them um go forward and she quotes i could not say enough
about her amazing competency and calmness in managing the frameworks particularly ethnic
studies and i think she will continue to impact student growth and improvement and i think
sacramento county is really lucky to have her joining their team so i just couldn't stop by
saying how those of us in curriculum instruction have so appreciated shane's work and we're very
fortunate she stays committed to the communities in sacramento thank you thank you and i'm gonna
add my thanks and congratulations and then slide into my president's report so i do want to add
deepest gratitude to that expressed by the superintendent for the important contributions
made to our work by dr stephanie gregson who has led with grace and intelligence in these
most trying times i'm delighted that she will continue to support this work from the vantage
point of cce where she will help strengthen our system of support and i also want to recognize
the wonderful work of rachel mays and chanine coats who enabled so many important initiatives
to come to the state board rachel's headed off to tennessee where she has new colleagues
that await her i have alerted my friends there to support her in her journey and i'm delighted
that chanine will remain a colleague as director of strategic initiatives in sacramento county
office of education so she's right next door she'll still be part of the support system that you
know california offers to its schools and counties i do want to welcome dr lee cheryl cotton marry
nicely and add my thanks to sarah neville morgan lisa castanjo and many others in the department
who've just done enormous work to lift not only the work of this over this pandemic year but also
to lift all these new initiatives that are beginning and really redefining and reinventing
the system of education in california so it's a trying time it's a challenging time it's an
exciting time it's a time for a lot of hard work and joining of hands i thank superintendent tony
thurman for all of the good colleagueship in figuring out how we move forward and then in
helping it happen and i'm i'm excited about the year ahead i do want to recognize and thank all
of the educators and staff and districts across the state of california for their amazing efforts
to launch this new in-person school year just as the delta variant is sweeping the country
like superintendent thurman i have seen and many of you have seen and experienced the excitement
and the joy of people coming back to school our educators have shown extraordinary planning skills
and deep levels of commitment to create that joyful and purposeful opening in 100 percent of
our districts while at the same time putting in place the mitigation strategies that allow
our opening to be safe the wide range of social and emotional programs and engagement activities
that allow the opening to be personalized and supportive for our young people and of course you
know delta has complicated the well-laid plans of our school leaders it's required expanded testing
there have been some quarantines but i want to tell you that in contrast to many other states
the path to opening schools in california has been extremely promising thus far thanks to all
of those focused efforts of principals teachers support staff parents students superintendents
and all of the folks in the department and the county office with continued vigilance
and state policy support our path promises to be even smoother in the coming months as of this
week our 20 largest districts plus more than a thousand smaller districts have opened on schedule
there have been community-based infections identified by schools testing programs
it's required some quarantines as students return schools have largely made the necessary
preparations to manage those processes and those that were taken by surprise have been getting
help from the state school outbreak response teams that are offering testing and vaccine resources
connecting them to the state's COVID-19 providers who offer multiple options for different types of
no-cost testing systems to meet community needs nearly 700 of the state's 1,000 districts
had already taken advantage of these programs before the start of school and more are setting
up their programs every day and schools are continuing the great work they did this past
summer when nine out of ten did offer summer programming and they have been doing an excellent
job of keeping students safe with improved ventilation and teaching students to wear their
masks with pride and practice good hygiene parents have most voiced support and gratitude for these
safety measures in most districts more than 95 percent of students have returned for in-person
instruction again in most districts i want to give you a little national perspective on where we are
there's a service called burbio that reports school closings and tracks those things across
the country and they report that 1,400 schools in 35 states have closed for quarantining or
reverted to distance learning across the country fewer than 10 of them have been in california
and all of those have reopened quickly or are set to do so with the support of the state
we educate about 12 percent of the nation's school children our schools open earlier than
many parts of the country for example in the midwest and the northeast and still we account
for far less than one percent of the school closings in the country and while covid case
rates have been climbing to very high rates in most parts of the country california's rates of
cases are not only among the lowest and far below the national average but they've been
sharply declining for the last three weeks and so we are in a much better position because of the
policies that have been undertaken here places like georgia and florida and texas and so on have
rates of covid infection that are four times higher they have rates of pediatric infection that are
five six seven times higher than in california and it's important for us to understand why this
is and how we can continue to make progress toward ending the pandemic back in july california was
the very first state in the nation to issue a renewed masking mandate for all adults and
children in schools as well as for adults in indoor settings even before the cdc did so
since then at least 16 other states have done so in the last week or so as they were overwhelmed
by covid cases in their schools on august 11th california became the first state to require
vaccines or weekly testing of all school employees on the heels of a similar requirement for
government workers now other states and cities across the country are beginning to follow suit
since last spring we have at least partially vaccinated more than 80 percent of our eligible
population the state is supporting school located vaccine clinics for every school that will host
them offering 50 000 to support schools who do who will do so this can be an especially
critical strategy for getting both students and families vaccinated and as you know the governor
with our state public health and education leaders legislative leaders our state superintendent
has been laser focused on providing the tools or resources that would be needed for safe school
reopening we had that six billion dollar package last march to fund safety measures such as ppe
and ventilation upgrades and covid 19 testing more than 98 of districts have used those funds
with the the funds to kick off the school year with expanded mental health after school learning
supports like high dose tutoring keenly aware of the students who've experienced trauma and lost
instructional time in the last year and a half since covid has hit and educators themselves of
course have experienced sources of trauma in their own families giving so much of themselves to take
care of our children and their own children often at the same time in a version of multitasking that
has never before been so complex or so remarkable so i just want to say to all of the committed
educators and school staff who are handling all of the complexities of the school year and to the
parents and students who are doing the same that if we can stay the course things will be much
easier in the weeks and months ahead the science clearly shows that the multi-layered mitigation
strategies diligent masking testing screening hand washing ventilation are effective at
preventing infection we have a lot of studies that show that in schools and child care centers
where that is the case there is very little transmission even when there are cases in the
community as a whole we're making progress on vaccines like half of our 12 to 17 year olds are
vaccinated a vaccine is expected for five to 11 year olds by early winter we should see a vaccine
for two to four year olds within a few months after that for those of us who have children and
our grandchildren in day care and preschool so as we continue on this path with purpose
and with diligence we will see cases and illnesses continue to decline and we'll see
fewer needs for quarantining state board and cde are working to get schools the latest information
from cde and the department of public health clarifying that even if cases do appear vaccinated
students and adults who might have been exposed do not need to quarantine as long as they have
no symptoms nor do unvaccinated children if both parties are wearing masks at the time of the
exposure with testing they can be in school safely we can support in-person teaching and learning with
minimum disruptions and so while there is a long way to go and many challenging moments ahead
California's policies and our hard work and expert educators and committed parents and students
can continue to lead the way through this pandemic to a safer future that supports children
in their learning their development their relationships their friendships their social
and emotional well-being and their educational progress and with that I want to turn the
podium back to superintendent Thurman for one more announcement and final staff blessing
as we move forward superintendent Thurman thank you darling ham and I think it needs to be said
that our state board president is the smartest and hardest working state board president anywhere
I think you can see that Dr. Darling-Hammond is at the intersection of all aspects of what we're
doing to support teaching and learning and to support all the COVID mitigations and all the
ways to ensure that our students are getting an opportunity to have what they deserve a quality
education it's an honor to partner with you Dr. Darling-Hammond and I think your report puts in
context just how much California is doing and I gotta say I'm proud to be a California and so
thank you Dr. Darling-Hammond for your partnership thank you for this opportunity just to provide
some final remarks and of course I'll take questions from the board members I did want to
also just share the mic with Dr. Stephanie Gregson if she wanted to have some final words this is her
last time sitting on the dais at least for now Dr. Gregson did you want to have some remarks
thank you superintendent Thurman and thank you for president Linda Darling-Hammond for your remarks
and vice president Eileen Strauss and thank you also to the other board members who have reached
out and shared some very kind words they are very much appreciated it has been a journey the past
five years for myself and with you as state board members and I've appreciated all of the supports
the questions and the challenges that we faced together over those past five years going through
frameworks and structural materials adoptions and most recently these past 18 months and supporting
all of our districts as they navigated the challenges of the pandemic I also want to thank
the CDE team they are amazing and phenomenal hard working people and we could not do what we do
without each and every one of them and so I just want to have a big shout out to our CDE team
and also much appreciation to our state superintendent Tony Thurman who provided
me this opportunity and without this experience and learning I wouldn't have figured out what I
want to do when I grow up and I am honored and privileged to have learned so much and to be able
to join the CCE because that's what I want to do when I grow up and supporting districts
who are struggling and taking all of the great work from CDE and helping them and so I thank you
for all of your support and guidance over the past years and I will look forward to working
with all of you in my new role thank you so much thank you Dr. Gregson again congratulations we're
looking forward to working with you in your new role one of the things that I learned from Dr.
Gregson is that the needs of the Department of Education are great many of them go unseen but
they are important to how we support districts and how we show up for districts and it is for
that purpose and for that reason that in August I named Mary Nicely as a co-chief deputy superintendent
now I'm teeing up Mary for you to come to the podium so that I can present you to the state
board for the board to take action on the item related to approval of a chief deputy
superintendent elect or designee of Mary Nicely you know the workload is intense and so in the
next days and weeks I'll also be sharing with you updates about two new positions that we'll be
creating on the executive team at the Department of Education there'll be grant-funded positions
that allow us to have additional deputies who can work on many many of the challenges that our
districts are facing as they continue to work so hard to serve our kids and stay open and keep them
open safely and I want to make sure to acknowledge our incredible communications director Maria
Clayton who's been helping you know those dozen districts that we get to the media is in tow
chasing us down every step of the way Dr. Escobedo can attest to that getting the message
out about the importance of vaccines has been our communications team and of course our incredible
government affairs team now led by a veteran CDE member and Amy Tang Paterno 13 years
working on fiscal policy at CDE we have big challenges ahead obviously managing COVID
providing supports and emotional supports to our students and closing learning gaps
gratefully we have a budget that has millions for mental health for community schools for universal
tk for universal meals for professional development and diversifying our workforce
and for expanded learning and of course record in historic investments for special education
and our ability to serve students with disabilities I'm pleased to present to you
someone who I've had the pleasure of knowing for more than a decade who has supported me in every
aspect of my public service and who is just committed to young people Mary Nicely has served
at the department of education first as senior advisor to me and also leading our office of
superintendents initiatives again in the work to close the digital divide again in the work to help
close the opportunity gap and our work to diversify our workforce especially our efforts to
expand the number of male educators of color who work in our schools I'm very proud of a
bill that we sponsored this year on male expanding male educators of color that has now become
part of the state budget and the hundreds of millions of dollars available for teacher
recruitment and we look forward to speaking with you about those and so we have many tools
to help us build better than we've ever done before and build an education system that works
for all of our students that cuts across equity gaps and envisions ways to help all of our students
and I'm pleased to present to you a special leader who can help us and join our executive
team in leadership and work closely with our state board on many of the aspects in addition to
having worked at CDE Mary Nicely has served with me when I was in the state assembly
versus my district director and as my chief of staff before that Mary Nicely ran a data
management company that specializes in supporting schools in how they manage their data and has
worked for many years in the technology sector and so it is amazing and exciting to see the vision
that she has for helping CDE and schools in California to close the digital divide I borrow
this phrase from her that she often says that internet connectivity should flow like electricity
and she is right Mary Nicely is a compassionate leader who is detailed oriented who finds a way
in her trademark way to GSD get stuff done she's an incredible leader who is compassionate and it
is a pleasure to present her to you now members of the state board for your action as it relates
to the item related to appointing a chief deputy superintendent I present to you Mary Nicely
and Mary before you speak I have to do a moment of a protocol vote because we need to vote twice
this item was added to the agenda on September 7th and because the need for action came to the
attention of the board after the agenda was posted on August 30th we need to take these two votes
first we have to vote to allow ourselves to vote on Mary and I do want to hear Mary's comments
before we vote on her but we do need to unfortunately take a minute open up the
uh phone line for public comment for this item so that if somebody could put the public comment
slide up we will be able to allow for that to happen I'll ask board members if they have any
comments they wish to make then we're going to vote to make the determination that there is a
need to take immediate action on this item and then we'll hear from Mary and then we will be
able to vote on her and so are there any comments from board members while we're waiting
for public comment if there is any to queue up
I'm not seeing any hands raised on that so I will ask is there any public comment
there is not at this time all right thank you please interrupt me if there is anyone who comes
to the floor and so now I want to ask if there's a motion for the state board to make a determination
that there's a need to take immediate action on this item and that the need came to the attention
of the CDE and the state board after the posting of the agenda this motion requires a two-thirds
vote so we need eight affirming votes of the state board of education do I have a motion
motion so moved thank you very much do I have a second I will second thank you very much
we'll now hold a roll call vote Brooks would you please call the roll member son
aye vice president Strauss yes member Rucker yes member Rodriguez yes member Petillo-Brownson
yes member McCwillin yes member Glover-Woods yes member Escobedo yes President Darlene Hammond
yes member Burr aye member Bonacca aye motion passes unanimously thank you so much
and Mary we are delighted to hear from you before we take a vote on your appointment
and I'm going to go back to the drum roll that the superintendent had so nicely queued up
and please come to the podium and address us.
Thank you board members and Dr. Darling-Hammond and Superintendent Thurmond for this opportunity.
I am very excited to be able to take on these challenges and look forward to working with you
all in the future so thank you very much for this opportunity. Thank you and we're excited to be able
to hold this vote and I now need a motion to approve CDE's recommendation to appoint Mary
Nicely as chief deputy superintendent. Can I have a motion? So moved. Moved. Oh
I'll second. All right thank you very much we have a motion and a second.
We'll now hold a roll call vote. Member Sun.
Aye. Vice President Strauss. Yes. Member Rucker. Yes. Member Rodriguez.
Yes. Member Patillo-Brownson. Yes. Member McQuillan. Yes. Member Glover-Woods. Yes.
Member Escobedo. Yes. President Darling-Hammond. Yes. Member Burr. Aye. Member Bonacca. Aye.
Aye. Motion passes unanimously.
All right congratulations. Mary thanks for joining the team. Thank you Superintendent Thurmond for
those wonderful remarks. We're now going to take a 10-minute break and I'll ask you to please turn
off your cameras and microphones and turn your cameras back on after the break to reestablish
the quorum. It's 1106. Why don't we be a little bit generous and give you until 1120.
14 minutes. We will move expeditiously after that. We're about an hour behind our plan schedule so
we're going to be very very efficient in our business during the rest of the day and
I'll see you in 14 minutes.
I'd like to ask that the State Board provide feedback regarding the draft
LCAP template and instructions that incorporate the requirements outlined in SB 98 and AB 130
as well as the draft for the 2021-22 supplement template and instructions.
And the item will be presented by Lindsay Tornatore and Josh Strong of the CDE. Lindsay and
Josh please begin. Thank you very much. Sound check good. Okay good morning President Darling
Hammond, Vice President Strauss, Chief Deputies Gregson and Nicely and members of the board.
My name is Lindsay Tornatore and I am the Director of the Student Achievement and Support Division.
I am joined today by my colleague Josh Strong who is the Administrator of the Local Agency
System Support Office otherwise known as LASO. Josh and I are here today to present five proposed
revisions to the Local Control and Accountability Plan as prescribed by SB 98 and AB 130.
But before we dive into today's item I want to take a few minutes to acknowledge and appreciate
two great leaders who have made a strong positive impact on the LCAP and have been instrumental in
helping all of us get to where we are today with the LCAP. So as Superintendent Thurman shared
earlier our former Deputy Superintendent on the Instruction and Measurement Branch Rachel Maze
left the CDE last month to pursue an opportunity with the Tennessee Department of Education.
Rachel came to us from the County Office of Education and prior to that as a Superintendent
of a rural district where she was the author of her district's LCAP. Rachel's experience and
respect for the LCAP and the process helped my team and I get the initial engagement period
with our educational partners off to a productive start and the lessons learned from working with
Rachel inspire us inspire our commitment to make the LCAP a process that is accessible
and achievable for all LEAs and I also want to acknowledge and appreciate Dr. Gregson.
Stephanie thank you for your leadership you have called all of us to action by challenging
everyone at the CDE to approach our work with compassion in every process and procedure that
we implement. You will be missed and we look forward to working continuing to work with you
as we know you will continue to identify and close gaps that are keeping our students from
reaching their fullest potentials. And so with that the purpose of today's item so the purpose
of today's item as President Darling-Hammond mentioned is not action but discussion and
feedback. This is the first of two meetings that we will discuss this the LCAP revised revisions
today and also at the November 2021 meeting. The state board discussion and feedback will
inform our ongoing revisions that we will continue to make between now and November.
During the November meeting we will ask the state board to take action to adopt the revised LCAP
template and instructions and also the one-time supplement to the annual update to the 21-22
LCAP. Our educational partner input will continue to be collected throughout this process and will
continue to inform the proposed revisions we will bring to the board in November.
A timeline of significant events that brought us here today in June of 2020 SB 98 was chapter
and in July of 2021 AB 130 was chaptered. These two bills brought forth four of the five proposed
revisions that we are bringing to the board today. We also brought the LCAP advisory group
together Wednesday July 28th of 2021 and we will again reconvene later this month to continue
to discuss the revisions being proposed to the template and instructions. We held a Tuesday at
two on August 10th of 2021 and we have another one scheduled for October 5th. We presented these
proposed revisions that we will discuss today at the California practitioners advisory group meeting
on August 20th of 2021. Their input feedback informed our approach to this presentation today.
We also are continuing with ongoing partner educational partner engagement
continuously collecting input and feedback and also reaching out to meet with partner organizations.
We will bring this item back to the November meeting and once adopted the anticipated adoption
in November we will then roll out comprehensive guidance to the field to navigate the new
requirements. So let's just take a few seconds and ground ourselves in the LCAP itself. So
adopted in 2014 the local control and accountability plan is a three-year plan that describes the goals
actions services and expenditures to support positive student outcomes that address state
and local priorities. The LCAP provides an opportunity for LEAs to share their stories
of how what and why programs and services are selected to meet their local needs.
Prior improvements that have been made to the LCAP template since its adoption
include the addition of the annual update a move to a three-year template
and the addition of summary tables displayed in a database format.
So for those of you who are following along at home we have several items posted and linked to
this agenda. So of course we have our actual item and then we have four attachments. The first
attachment is a summary or sort of a primer of the required and proposed changes the why, when,
who, what, how. Attachment two is the current LCAP template and instructions provided for reference.
Attachment three and four are the proposed drafts. The attachment three is the LCAP template and
instructions and attachment four the proposed draft of the one-time annual one-time supplement
to the annual update to the 21-22 LCAP. In attachments three and four you'll notice that
highlighted in yellow throughout the document are our proposed changes.
So the summary of revisions. We have five revisions that we're going to discuss today.
We're going to take one at a time and talk through them in a subsection. During each of
these subsections we're going to answer five big questions. Why is this revision being proposed?
When does the requirement begin? Who will this impact? What do they need to do? And how will
they do it? In the how sections Josh will walk us through the proposed revisions to the LCAP
template and instructions which again can be found in attachments three and four.
After we discuss each of the five revisions we will close out the presentation of this item by
sharing what is next for CDE's efforts to continue to engage with our educational partners
until the November board meeting and beyond. We also have a crosswalk of all LEA required plans
to share today and we hope that this crosswalk will show how the one-time supplement to the
annual update is intended to give LEAs an opportunity to share their story of how they
are spending their LCFF and federal emergency relief funds in a manner that is consistent with
their 21-22 LCAP. All right so revision number one. Requirement to include specific goals in
the LCAP. Let's start with the why. The why is twofold. First to ensure that LEAs are addressing
the needs of consistently low performing student groups and to ensure that higher performing LEAs
are addressing the needs of low performing schools within the LEA.
So when does this requirement take place? For eligible LEAs and COEs the specific required
goals will be included beginning with the 22-23 LCAP. CDE staff will annually prepare files that
indicate for all applicable LEAs which student groups and schools will be required to have goals
based on these new instructions. So there are two groups of who because this requirement is
twofold. So the first group is the LEAs that have received technical assistance for the same student
group or groups for three or more consecutive years as reported on the dashboard. The LEAs who
meet the above criteria must include a goal in the LCAP focused on improving the performance
of that student group or groups.
The second group that this requirement impacts are high performing LEAs with low performing schools.
Specifically it's LEAs who for two consecutive consecutive years have a school or schools that
have received the two lowest performance levels on the dashboard on all but one of the state
indicators for which the school receives performance levels. And the all students
student group for the LEA is at least one performance level higher than the school's
performance level. What this grouping of LEAs needs to do is to write a goal in the LCAP
focused on improving the performance of the school or schools that meet this criteria.
And so the proposed instructions for these requirements can be found on pages 21 and 22
of attachment 3 and I'm going to turn it over to Josh Strong to walk us through the how for the
requirement oh sorry excuse me missed a page and I'm going to 21 to 22 of of attachment 3 and I'm
going to turn it over to Josh to walk us through the attachment of the requirement to include
specific goals in the LCAP. So we can stop screen share and allow Josh to share his screen please.
Thank you Lindsay.
Good morning board president and board members. I'm Joshua Strong,
administrator of the local AGC system support office and here is the attachment 3 showing the
current proposed LCAP template and instructions. As as many of you are aware within the LCAP
template and instructions an LEA provides it presents its goals in the goals and actions section
utilizing this template and and so in terms of addressing this particular requirement to
add these two required goals to the instructions of the plan we didn't feel that there was a need
to provide specific goals sections for those requirements within the template itself
rather those are expressly provided within the instructions as as Lindsay has already stated on
pages 21 and 22 and the approach that we've taken or that we're suggesting at this point in time
is to within the instructions first provide what the criteria are related to each of the
goal each of the requirements and then to provide specific instructions for how the LEA would
would then create that goal and what the goal should address so in terms of the first requirement
related to the LEAs that have been identified for assistance based on the performance of
one or more student subgroups for three consecutive years we've provided that criteria
here at the beginning for the consistently low performing student groups and then the
instructions related to the specific goal noting that there have the focus of the goal needs to be
on improving performance of the student group or groups that led to the LEA's eligibility
and specifying that the goal must include metrics outcomes actions and expenditures
that are specific to addressing these needs to the identified needs and improving outcomes for
these the student group or groups that led to that eligibility and then similarly we have we were
providing criteria related to the low performing school component and then as before the specific
instructions related to what that goal needs to focus on and include within the LCAP and then
as part of of implementing these goals the LCAP the LEA would include one of the goal in which
they're eligible for or required to include in their LCAP as a regular as as a goal along
with the other goals within the plan so that's the proposal at at this point in time and I'll
turn it back over to Lindsay and allow her to move forward. Thank you Josh.
Okay so now at this you get the sound so at this time we can pause
President Darling-Hammond for clarifying questions about this specific requirement.
All right are there any
we also should probably put up the public comment slide so that we can queue up and
we'll take clarifying questions while we do that if you're at the point for
for public comment. We actually well I think that we have four more revisions so we could if it's
okay we'll wait for public comment. We'll wait for that okay so we could take some clarifying
questions.
It appears that we may have a connection issue so let's start with our first clarifying question.
Looks like Member McQuillan you're first up. Okay thank you. Just wondering about the timeline
if this amendment is approved what would be the rollout timeline on it? Thank you.
So the as far as as far as the timeline SB 98 has prescribed that LEAs who fall into either of these
two criteria must include a specific goal in their LCAP starting with the 22-23 LCAP so we will include
this in the instructions and template for the 22-23 LCAP. As far as one piece to add is as far
as notifying LEAs who will be required to add these goals we plan to have that data pulled
around the time of the November board meeting. Cindy Casanas and her team will be working on that
data set. So I'm going to take over because Dr. Berlingham is in no end down so until she's back
on again. Member Burr you're next.
Member Burr you're muted. Thank you. So my question really relates to not only this item
but the item that we talked about around assessments. If I understand this correctly
these specific goals have to be included in the case of sort of persistently under performance
over three years and so can you talk about and maybe this is a question for Cindy
what indicators will be used to determine whether a district and or an LEA within a district is
persistently underperforming if we don't have any assessment data that's comparable over three years?
So we are using historical data for this first data poll and then moving forward once we have
a full dashboard with all the data indicators we'll use the dashboard. So for this first year
we'll be using historical data. So we'll be using test scores that are how old?
I think 2017, 18, and 19.
Okay. Member Glover-Woods.
Just a question as far as when the goal or goals are put in the template how will a reader
differentiate or know that that specific goal or goals is aligned to this particular requirement
since all of the goals are going to be in the same area on the template?
Actually you know what can I pass this over to Josh to address?
Sure thank you. Member Glover-Woods that would be something that would be explained as part of the
why statement for why the LEA has developed the goal within the goals and actions section. So as
part of that explanation of why the LEA developed the goal the LEA would include
the identification that this is a required goal.
So Josh just another follow-up question on that. Is it going to be required that the LEA put that
information in the explanation? Is that in the directions that they must put that in the explanation
so that again it can be clear that this goal is developed for this particular requirement?
That's not currently in the instructions however that's certainly something that we can include
if you have a desire for if the board has that desire.
Thank you. Member Rucker.
Thank you. I have so many questions about the instructions and the information in this template
but I'll start with this particular clarifying question on setting the who. Do the goals need
to set differentiated growth targets for these student subgroups as a way for these specific
student subgroups? For example if I'm sorry for example if African American students are consistently
the lowest performing student subgroup for all grades tested in all of the areas tested and we
also have Hispanic students who are also underperforming do the goal statements have
to differentiate what may be done for African American students as a subgroup and Latino
students as a subgroup or do they get to say all underperformance will be addressed in this way?
Okay so board member to your question there is currently in the statute it is not
prescriptive as far as making a clear distinction between the different student groups.
So then I don't understand how this is going to actually address I don't understand that I'm glad
you answered the question that way because I read the statute and the statute doesn't clarify that
so I'm not clear with these questions or these statements that you're saying will be added to
the LCAP I'm not clear how we will get to a greater level of clarity or subgroup identification
without that prescription so are you saying that you're going to be moving beyond that
description or prescription and adding to what districts have to address are districts still
because of the statute still not going to actually be required to identify or name those names?
Well I believe the legislative intention is truly to ensure that districts are addressing
their low performing student the consistently low performing student groups in their LCAP with
specific goals as far as where we are right now based on statute is how we have framed most of
the revisions that we bring to you and that being said we're open to recommendations and
direction from the board as far as clarifying this to make sure that it is accessible and
achievable for all of our LEAs. Okay so I'm going to stop right there but when we come back to a
broader board discussion I do want to come back to this concern. Thank you member Rucker just
remember we have several more parts and these are clarifying questions and as member Rucker said
after our public comments we're going to have a robust discussion about this and this is a not
an action but an information and some comments from the board today and it's you can imagine
that CPEG had a very complicated discussion about this as well. So Lindsay are we ready to go to the
I like the neck the way you organized it I think we have the next part now. Yes thank you yes so
the second requirement is the requirement to calculate carryover. So let's start with the why
the why is to ensure an LEA is implementing and not just planning to meet its full proportionality
obligation to increase or improve services for students who are low income English learners and
or foster youth over and above the level of services provided to all students. As we enter
so here we go when when will this requirement take place these new requirements to education
code sections 4223 8.07 and 52064 were signed into law on July 9th 2021 through AB 130 and will be
implemented beginning with the 2223 LCAP. This requirement is applicable to all LEAs so as we
enter into the what and how of this requirement I want to acknowledge that the steps to calculate
carryover are very complex and technical but we know that it is worth work it is worth working
through this complexity to achieve a clear and transparent accounting of how students who are
low income English learners and or foster youth are being served over and above the level of
services provided to all students. So the what has three parts the first one is looking at education
code section 4223 8.07 which says that it will ensure LEAs are implementing and not just planning
to meet their full proportionality obligation LEAs are required to document differences between
planned and implemented actions and services and any shortfall between the implemented level of
actions and services and the proportionality obligation will be carried over into the future
year to continue to serve our unduplicated students. This statute also establishes that
any shortfall between the implemented level of actions and services and the proportionality
obligation can be carried over into the future year to serve its unduplicated students.
In the how section Josh will walk you through this requirement as it appears in the template
and instructions. I also want to note here that there have been questions raised about whether
actions stemming from carryover can be either qualitative or quantitative we believe that
consistent with the original charge for increase increasing and improving services for our
unduplicated students the nature of carryover dollars would be the same allowing for both
qualitative and quantitative actions but I do want to make sure it's very clear we have requested
clarification from our CDE legal team to ensure we are interpreting this statute correctly.
So a second part of this requirement is that with this new requirement the need to introduce
new terminology to make a distinction between actions that utilize LCFF funds and actions that
do not utilize LCFF funds was necessary. So since the inception of LCFF LEAs have had the opportunity
to meet their minimum proportionality percentage in a number of ways that do not only require
spending money we have historically used the terms increasing or improving services but these terms
do not fully encompass the nuances we need to consider for carryover. The new terminology
quantitative and qualitative provides an opportunity for LEAs to categorize their
actions in two ways actions that have an associated expenditure and actions that do not have an
associated expenditure. The reason that these two terms were developed in statute is to make sure
that when districts are calculating their carryover there is a way to capture both of these types of
actions that meet the objectives of increasing or improving services for unduplicated pupils under
LCFF. So again LEAs can utilize both types of actions to meet their proportionality obligation
and the distinction between the actions is that a quantitative action has associated LCFF expenditures
they're considered to be increases they're expressed as dollar figures so an example of
a quantitative action could be the LEA will spend three million dollars to maintain increased staffing
ratios of counselors school nurses and classroom aides at sites serving a majority of students who
are expelled foster youth while on the other hand a qualitative action do not have associated
expenditures these are commonly thought of as improvements and are often expressed as percentages
so an example of a qualitative action could be a community-based organization sends volunteers
two days a week to a school to offer one-to-one reading practice with english learners in the
third grade this is a qualitative action because the district does not pay for this one-to-one
reading support and this action provides targeted services to an unduplicated student group
so to align with statute we also need to make some changes to the titles of the tables in
the current LCAP template so provided on this slide is a list of the changes to the tables
in the next section when we turn it back over to josh he'll point out these changes which are in
attachment three the proposed revisions to the template instructions are listed on the table in
this slide and i will turn it back over to josh to share screen and walk us through the how for
the requirement to calculate carryover
thank you lindsay so as as many of you are aware the increased or improved services for
foster youth english learners and low-income students page provides or asks LEAs to provide
the percentage to increase or improve services and the increase the amount of the increased
apportionment based on the enrollment of foster youth english learner and low-income students
in order to address some of these requirements in terms of this carryover
um the the majority of those changes or those proposed changes are within the LCAP summary
tables that were adopted to go along with them this is the data entry table and
it's very wide and so i'll make it a little bit larger
um all of the data that's on this page is entered by the LEA and then all of this then populates
into the additional tabs on on the workbook in order to generate the the required reports
we're proposing to add three data elements on this data entry table in order to
meet this requirement the requirements within statute the first is to ask LEAs to provide
the increased apportionment amount and the percentage to increase or improve services
which are already reported in the template within the expenditure tables we're also asking that they
then include a qualitative percentage of improved services for any action that is both contributing
but does not have funding associated with it so in an instance where there is a contributing action
that does have funding associated with it so for example this action here you would have a
0% percentage to improve service whereas for this action here because there are no funds
associated with that the LEA would then provide a qualitative percentage of improved services
then within the expenditure summary table there are no proposed changes within the contributing
summary table there are six proposed changes two of those changes are to include the estimated
apportionment amount and the percentage to increase or improve services also in terms of
addressing statutory requirements the total planned percentage to increase or improve services
so that those looking at the expenditure tables can have a comparison between what the required
percentage is and what the planned percentage based on the LCAP for the coming year is the
contributing actions table only provides those actions that are identified as contributing
towards meeting the requirement to increase or improve services as part of this table we are
proposing to include the expenditure quantitative percentage to play forward from the data entry
table into the contributing summary table a qualitative percentage of the qualitative
percentage of increased services and then to sum those to create a total percentage of increased
or improved services these percentages here are actually reflective of how much they are
contributing the percentages that are here are in reference to their proportion of this 6.34%
and so this is that when it says 20.62% that means that it's making up 20.26% towards the 6.34%
the sum total of the funding and the qualitative percentages then are calculated to
to provide this 7.83% that is the planned percentage so that here in this example we have a percentage
a required percentage to increase or improve services of 6.34% a planned percentage to increase
or improve services by 7.83% then within the annual update portion of the template where the
estimated actual expenditures from the prior year are provided this is the only piece of data
that the LEAs actually have to enter and there are no changes being proposed to this page
and then the contributing updates table which is completely new is being proposed this
is similar to the annual update table this takes the contributing actions and compares both the
prior year the planned expenditures from the prior year with the estimated actual expenditures
as well as the planned qualitative improvements and the estimated actual improvements in order
to generate the total estimated actual percentage of improved services so that here's the
required percentage by which the LEA must increase or improve services for the year
here's what they had planned to do here's what they are reporting they actually did the difference
between what they had plans to do and what they actually did and then the difference between
the what they actually did and the required percentage so that if the amount if the percentage
difference is is less than what the required percentage is then there's no carryover that's
required if if this amount change if the percentage changes and is in the positive
then there would be a carryover amount that would be generated here so if if the estimated
actual amount here was changed to say 75,000 then there's a 4.5 difference between what was
actually done and what was required and there's and then the funding the required carryover funding
generates within this field and is then reported here in terms of in addition to what the LEA must
the proportion percentage that they must meet in the coming year so so the LEA here would report
what the any any carryover amount that would be required for the 2022-23 LCAP in addition to
the percentage to increase or improve services based on their fund their their estimated funding
within 2022-23 so it's really simple and easy for everyone to understand
so at this point in time I'll turn it back over to Lindsay.
Thank you, Josh.
So we'll pause and ask for clarifying questions about this requirement.
If we have any more clarifying questions I see Member Rucker's hand up. Why don't you kick us off?
I'm just going to say you had me at the differentiation between qualitative and quantitative
so I let me begin by saying my qualitative interest in this particular section has jumped
100 percent. I don't see can you show me in the directions where it explains how to calculate
this qualitative increase or qualitative percentage because that's the part I couldn't understand and
I'm not sure I saw it in the direction. I hope that's a clarifying question. Absolutely.
Can we please share screen with Josh one more time?
Well actually if I could we don't need to do that at this point in time Member Rucker there
aren't any instructions within the LCAP template related specifically to how to work how to calculate
that percentage in part because that's something that we're asking for seeking input on. We've
already received a fair amount of input on various ways in which that could then be calculated.
Part of the struggle is to look at the various ways that a qualitative improvement could be
that requirement could be met. Okay so I'll save my second question for the more detailed discussion.
All right are there any other clarifying questions? I don't see any hands raised.
Seeing none I would encourage you to proceed ahead. Okay thank you so the third requirement is to use
a concentration grant add-on for increased staffing. So the why behind this requirement
is to ensure LEAs who receive concentration grant funding have additional resources to hire
staff who will provide direct services to students at schools where students who are low income
English learners and or foster youth make up 55% or more of the student body.
This requirement takes place because the 21-22 budget was signed into law on July 9th of 2021
and it provides applicable LEAs with an additional 15% concentration grant add-on
and this 15% concentration grant add-on will be ongoing into future budget years.
This requirement is applicable to all LEAs who receive concentration grant funding
and the what behind this this requirement is that LEAs who receive these funds are required to
demonstrate that the additional funding received as a result of the increased concentration grant
add-on percent will be used to increase the number of credentialed staff classified staff or both of
those that provide direct services to pupils including this includes custodial staff on school
campuses who with greater than 55% unduplicated pupil enrollment in the prior year as compared
to the staff to pupil ratios at schools within the local educational agency with any with an
unduplicated people enrollment in the year of 50 in the prior year 55% or less. So I'll just
pause there for a second to process that slide.
Will there be a quiz?
So in other words the LEAs who receive concentration funds are required to demonstrate
how they use these funds to increase the number of credentialed staff and or classified staff
or both that provide direct services at high need schools.
So for the how of this requirement the proposed changes in the template can be found on page 7
and the instructions related to this proposed revision can be found on page 29. So Josh go
ahead can we please kick it back over to Josh one more time?
Thank you Lindsay. So as Lindsay has already shared the prompt related to this is proposed
at this point in time to be included in the increased or improved services section
and to provide a specific prompt here. The instructions that are specifically
typed in the template are to be included in the increased or improved services section
the instructions that are specifically tied to this then are in the increased or improved
services section and specifically on page 29 as it relates to describing the specifics of
how that funding is being used as well as including the number of staff members that
are either hired or transferred and the type of direct services that are provided to students.
Part of the caveat and you know maybe to address some of the questions that I hear member
running around in member Rutgers head at this point in time this is kind of a moving target
in fact there's even some proposed changes to this particular piece of ed code included in
assembly bill senate bill 167 related to this carryover to this additional 15 concentration
grant. It's something that we've received a lot of input from both in terms of providing more
clarity of related to the requirement itself but then also in terms of a couple of different
proposals for how this information could be captured that might be cleaner than simply a
narrative prompt and so those are things that we're looking into but are also interested in
receiving the feedback that the board might have related to this requirement as well. Lindsay?
Thank you Josh. Okay so we'll pause for clarifying questions.
All right do we have any clarifying questions at this juncture?
I think our brains are full.
Okay please continue. Okay so the fourth revision that out of five that we bring to everyone
to discuss about the LCAP is the requirement to add a one-time supplement to the annual update
to the 21-22 LCAP. So the reason behind this one-time supplement is to provide local governing
boards or bodies, parents, families, and other educational partners with additional information
related to the additional funds provided to LEAs in the 21-22 school year. These additional funds
of course are the additional LCFF funds and the elementary and secondary school emergency relief
funds also known as ESSER funds and also to show for LEAs to share their story of how they're using
these funds in a manner that is consistent with other applicable plans and in alignment with their
21-22 LCAPs. This requirement will take place so there are a couple pieces. The state board must
adopt the template for this one-time supplement on or before November 30th of 2021. Following the
anticipated adoption at the November meeting the CDE will post the one-time supplement template
and instructions to the CDE website. LEAs must present the one-time supplement to the annual
update to the 21-22 LCAP at a regularly scheduled meeting of the governing board or body of the LEA
on or before February 28th 2022 and I just want to note that this supplement once it is presented
and completed in February it will be included in the 22-23 LCAP that will be submitted on or
before July 1st of 2022. This requirement is applicable to all LEAs and the what behind it
is LEAs must use the one-time supplement template to present an update at a regularly
scheduled meeting of the governing board or body on or before February 28th of 2022.
The proposed draft of this one-time supplement is attached as attachment number four
and I will turn it over to Josh to talk more about the how.
Thank you Lindsay. So in terms of the one-time supplemental template to
the LCAP this is providing a mid-year update to local governing boards and to the LEA's community
as a whole of how stakeholders were engaged in and consulted as part of the use of various funds
as well as a way of including the description of how the additional 15 percent concentration grant
funding is being used to increase staffing at schools that serve greater than 55 percent of
low-income English learner or foster youth students. In an effort to really streamline
the approach that we're proposing is to keep it as simple as possible, allow LEAs to be able to
provide relevant information to their governing boards and their communities without having to
to use something that's overly complicated or complex. Obviously there's not a whole lot of time
between when the supplemental template is released and the time in which LEAs have to use it as part
of the report. In terms of the instructions we begin the instructions related to the
supplemental template with the requirement to provide that update to the local governing
board in the community, what that needs to include as well as some specificity related to
how the supplement then is also included within the LCAP for 2022-23. And then in the instructions
related to the prompts themselves providing some description of how that should be done,
what it should cover. We've already received some requests to provide additional information
to provide some clarity about what funds provided through the budget act of 2021
are being referred to within the prompts so that there's more clarity for both LEAs and
for their communities and that's something that we'll be including moving forward as well as
the way in which some of these prompts provide additional information on what needs to be included.
And so again this is something that we're open to feedback on and interested in hearing
thoughts and ways that this could be improved while providing clarity for both the community,
the governing board, and as much as possible reducing that duplication of effort for LEAs.
Thank you, Josh.
And I think also to build on Josh's last point, we acknowledge there's work to be done still on
this LCAP template and the instructions and the one-time supplement and so we are very excited
to be able to bring this item to all of you board members today for your input and we'll be using
that to inform the hard work we're going to be doing over the next two months. So we'll pause
for clarifying questions. I don't see any hands raised at this juncture so let's carry on.
Okay we have made it to the fifth revision. So the fifth revision is actually not prescribed
by statute but is an important one. We would like to ask the board if we may replace the term
stakeholder throughout the LCAP template and instructions. We have received some feedback in
speaking with some of our LEA partners that the term stakeholder is offensive to some people and
is creating a barrier on participation for some of our community members particularly our Native
American communities and the reason behind this is that this term connotates the practice of
staking a claim to land during colonial times which was used as a justification for not recognizing
the rights of Native American communities to their land. This term does not acknowledge the
fact that Native American tribes are sovereign nations with constitutionally protected rights
and therefore the use of this term in the LCAP template and instructions
has created a barrier to engagement for some of our Native American communities and members.
So again this who is the CDE had received some feedback from various educational partners
throughout the state. Now for the one of this the CDE has begun to receive some recommendations
for new terminology to replace this term however we don't have a recommendation for a new term
today. We would like to continue to collect terminology recommendations throughout the
revision process before to bring back to all of you at the November meeting and we actually have
a couple of educational partner meetings coming up. One in particular is we have the American
Indian Education Oversight Committee coming up which is an advisory group to the superintendent
that is next week and I want to thank board member McQuillan who attends those meetings
and provides a board update and is going to work with us to summarize the recommendations
going to work with us to summarize the discussion that happens today
to those members and we will be asking for them to give input of recommendations.
We also will be creating a snap survey which will be live during the month of October of 2021
and the link to access the survey will be posted to the LCAP web page. We will also send it out
through our listservs and all members of the public will be invited to submit recommendations
for a new term. And so the what of this is again to remove the barrier CDE is recommending
that throughout the template we replace the term just as statute requires that school districts
and county offices consult with parents, students, teachers, principals, administrators,
other school personnel, local bargaining units, and the local community and charter schools are
required to consult with teachers, principals, administrators, other school personnel, parents,
and students. So we are definitely seeking all of your all the board members feedback on our
tentative next steps for choosing and recommending to you a new phrase. We also for all of you
watching we invite members of the public to submit suggestions for new phrases by emailing us at
lcff.cda.ca.gov and then again or if you would prefer to wait for the survey link we will have
that live during the month of October 2021. And with that we will pause for clarifying questions.
Now is this the point at which we are going to shortly go to public comment?
We have just two more pieces of content to share
and then we'll go to public comment. Okay we'll pause for anyone who dares to have a clarifying
question. All right let's continue please. Okay so we want to take just a moment and acknowledge
that we know the pandemic has shaken our system upside down and inside out. We have all had to
innovate and collaborate to develop new ways of thinking and doing that will support our students
and schools. Our LEAs have been and continue to be champions for continuous improvement
in putting students first while navigating new state and federal requirements and constantly
changing public health guidelines. So to all of our LEAs who are watching this presentation
we applaud you we acknowledge you and we appreciate you and we the CDE want to make sure that we are
doing everything we can to to collaborate with our LEAs and support their implementation of
these new requirements that impact the LCAP amidst all the other requirements they are currently
juggling. So in this next section I want to show how the CDE plans to engage with our partners in
the field to inform the revisions of the revisions that we are working on and also to provide
comprehensive support and guidance. So before we got here today we met with the LCAP advisory group
we held a Tuesday at 2 webinar we presented at the California practitioners advisory group
we met with educational partners and state board staff throughout that period and we also received
some written comments and recommendations. After this board meeting we are going to host another
Tuesday at 2 in October to discuss the revisions that that are proposed today. We are continuing
to meet with our partner organizations and advisory groups we are going to bring the LCAP
advisory group together again we are going to outline and launch our snap survey to collect
recommendations for a new term to replace stakeholder and as always everyone is always welcome to send
input through email to our LCFF inbox. At the anticipated adoption of the LCAP template
instructions and the one-time supplement for the annual update at the November board meeting
following that we will host another we will host a Tuesday at 2 webinar series.
LASSO is available for office hours and technical assistance upon request and also we are very proud
to say that we are working closely with the region 15 comprehensive center at West Ed. We are going
to be rolling out some examples of well-written LCAP sections inclusive of new requirements as
two-page handouts. We are also going to be releasing some guidance that is how to use
your local data more than your state data as a metric in the LCAP and also to support
in timely posting of additional guidance documents to accompany our Tuesday at 2 webinar series.
We acknowledge those are very content heavy and that the slides are very technical and so we are
going to have some translation documents to summarize them that are going to accompany these
webinars. And then finally just to show that again we all know LEAs have a lot going on right now.
We want to acknowledge all the plans that our LEAs have created and are implementing
in a crosswalk format so that you can see the intersection of these plans.
So each of the plans listed down the left-hand column are all playing critical roles in safe
return to in-person instruction and ongoing in-person instruction amidst our ongoing pandemic.
This crosswalk is organized that each row identifies the plan and then the columns the
adoption date the implementation time time frame and any required revision dates of that plan.
The one-time supplement to the annual update will give LEAs an opportunity to bring all of these
plans together to share their story of how they're spending their LCFF and federal emergency relief
funds in a manner that is consistent with their 21-22 LCAP.
And we are working on making this 508 accessible and posting it on our webpage
on the LCAP webpage. So I'm gonna just jump here and then we'll go to public comment.
So for more information I have some listed commonly used webinars or sites. I just want to
highlight the fourth bullet. Our government affairs team created a COVID emergency relief
funding summary chart and it is fantastic. It lays out similar to the crosswalk of plans. It
is a crosswalk of funding so I highly recommend it. You can find it via search in our CD webpage
by typing COVID emergency relief funding summary chart. So now that is the end of our presentation
of this item and I'll pull this up for public comment or turn it back over to you President
Darling-Hammond. Thank you very much for that very thorough presentation and thank you for all the
incredible work you've done on this revision of the template as you said the revision of the
revision and for all the work you are yet to do after we give you our advice and you hear from
many others in our education partnerships. So we are while we're waiting for members of the
public to call in who can provide comment on this item I'm going to remind you this is for item three.
You could do so by calling the telephone number and using the access code provided on the slide
that is shown now and while we're waiting for members of the public to call in I want to ask
Vice President Strauss and member Burr as our accountability liaisons if they have initial
comments. So Vice President Strauss. So Lindsay and Josh thank you so much I just think Josh
did an amazing job at CPAC walking through this detail by detail just like he did now
and it was a really thoughtful very deep conversation and the comments generally
obviously this is complicated this is generated by the need to address legislative requirements
the general comments are that a lot of the prompts and guidance are improving in the LCAP template
but I will say many many people see the LCAP template as guiding all the work and decisions
and so so many people still want to put more and more in the LCAP template so let me just say
I think the work has really improved it but I'm making a request that Lindsay and Josh and the
team come back to us in November with with areas they believe are redundant that they can reduce
the LCAP template so again I think the improvements are clear the wordings the stakeholder groups have
helped us in a lot of the prompts but I think it has gotten so long the intent is to be transparent
to help people understand what we're doing to meet the needs of students with the funding and
actions that districts take but I feel like we've gotten the point now where it's longer and longer
and it is just I'm not sure it's meeting all the needs by the length of it and the complexity
so I would like you through your next meetings to come back to us with some recommendations of areas
you believe could be shortened and wouldn't compromise the intent and would help the public
and the staff really use this as a planning tool as it is intended now again I want to thank you
so much for the thorough Lindsay I really liked how you laid out who what why I think that was
really helpful in the process I'll turn it over to member Burke. Thank you Vice President Strauss.
I too want to express my appreciation I said to Lindsay and Josh when we did our review of the item
when I read the draft it made my head explode and I was really worried about how we were going to
have this conversation but you did a magnificent job of taking the comments we had at the late
liaison call and putting in the who what why where to clarify why these changes are needed
I just also want to echo everything that Vice President Strauss said
and and sort of take us back to the very beginning as the historian of the group here
when I think about what the LCAP was intended to do to be a strategic document to guide
instructional planning and provide services to our most needy students I'm afraid that it has turned
into a complex accounting document that only CPAs can understand and only CPAs can fill out
so I really want to take Vice President Strauss's comments to heart about how can we make how can we
return to what the original intent was while still keeping the needed accountability thank you.
Thank you so much I think with that we will turn to public comment and I understand we have a
number of callers in the queue. Is our public comment moderator available? Yes there is.
Hello caller please state your name and affiliation for the record you have one minute
your time begins now. Good afternoon board members this is Louise Guillen with public advocates I'm
wanting to underscore the letter that we submitted with the LCFF equity coalition.
The changes and transparency required by the budget trailer bill addresses a real life scenario
it's not a hypothetical problem and it's intended to ensure that LEA fully plan and actually deliver
on their equity obligations under LCFF and when they don't the shortfall and increased or improved
services is calculated and carried over to the next year as unused supplemental and concentration
grant funds. We don't see how qualitative improvement can make up a large proportion of
the proportionality obligation but the explicit directions and statute concerning carryover are
important to get right so that when it's present high need students will get the full benefit of
LCFF. What I heard Josh present is a proposal to trap qualitative improvements action by action
and we thank the department staff for making that change. Your time is up and advocate
that carryover funds to be limited to quantitative.
Hello caller please state your name and your name and affiliation for the record
you have one minute your time begins now.
Jessica Focco on behalf of Children Now I'd like to thank Member Rucker for her clarifying question
regarding how to calculate the qualitative percentage of improved services this is indeed
the million dollar question that is critically answered before November when the board is set
to take action on the LCFF template. In addition education code 42238.07 is clear
carryover funds must be extended and therefore their use is limited to those quantitative actions
which were previously described. I would like to thank Josh and the team in Lasso for
their welcoming of our comments over the past couple of months and we look forward to continuing
working together in order to ensure that this document serves the needs of families community
members and the schools they are designed to support thank you.
Hello caller please state your name and affiliation for the record
you have one minute your time begins now.
Good afternoon I'm Jennifer Hicks Assistant Superintendent of Educational Services at
the Foster County Office of Education and the 2021 Fifth Chair. I'm sharing these
comments on behalf of SISC in two seconds. We support the CBE's recommended timeline for
adoption and appreciate bringing the draft revisions in September within an intent to
adopt in November. This timeline allows both county offices and LEAs the necessary time to
understand the new requirements prepare for the changes and provide thoughtful and comprehensive
training and calibration. Additionally we advocate for the revised template and supplement to
include only the components required by statute. It's essential that the revisions not require
additional items beyond what's required by statute and that the LCAP continue to be used as a tool for
strategic planning in order to best serve students. I appreciate board member comments about returning
the LCAP to its original intent to something that is not overly complex or burdensome. I also want
to thank the CBE staff for the ongoing partnership and engagement with county offices.
Hello caller please state your name and affiliation for the record. You have one minute your time
begins now. My name is Lexi Lopez from Ed Voice. The current template is not clear that LEAs must
report on specific actions funded with carryover resources for the ensuing year. Ed Voice urges
the board to provide explicit direction to LEAs that aligns with AB 130 to ensure unused LCFS
carryover funds are additive and expended to benefit targeted students. Ed Voice also recommends
the board ensure district report by school the staff position supported by the 1.1 billion
and target funding to ensure staffing levels at schools with a higher concentration of
unduplicated students have improved. Please refer to attachments one and two from the
alliance for students letter for an example. Lastly we recommend guidance on specific actions
resulting in qualitative improvements and detailed instructions on how to calculate the benefit to
targeted students. Thank you. Hello caller please state your name and affiliation for the
record. You have one minute your time begins now. Caller ending in 4339 your time begins now.
Thank you.
Hello caller please state your name and affiliation for the record.
You have one minute your time begins now.
Caller ending in 2619 your time begins now.
Are you there caller?
Hello caller please state your name and affiliation for the record.
You have one minute your time begins now.
My name is Lorraine Richards I'm a classroom teacher representing California teachers
association. CTA is part of a coalition of labor and education management organizations
that supports the changes made in AB 130 that would ensure LEAs are following through on the
commitment made to our most vulnerable students. We urge the board to consider that the LCAP should
be strategic planning document and our state's accountability system is intended to focus on
outcomes and continuous improvement. Efforts to further evolve the LCAP into compliance
documents should be disregarded. We appreciate that the template provides
options for LEAs to increase or improve services for unduplicated students either qualitatively
or quantitatively as outlined in statute. We also urge the board to simplify the template as much as
possible and not include additional requirements beyond current law. With this school year
underway the pandemic continues to place substantial stress on family students teachers and administrators.
Thank you. Hello caller please state your name and affiliation for the record.
You have one minute your time begins now.
Hi I'm Leticia Garcia on behalf of the Riverside County superintendent of schools and the 23 school
districts in Riverside County. We're here today as part of a coalition of LEAs and education
organizations. We thank DeafWork on the proposed template and emphasize the following points.
Our districts embrace accountability for student outcomes. The templates meet AB 130 requirements
and maintain the original LCFF intent that the LCAP is a tool for strategic planning to search
students needs and not an accounting document. The templates also hold districts accountable for
their LCFF obligations and allow for qualitative actions to meet these obligations. We do believe
LEAs and communities could benefit from additional guidance on how to calculate the percentage of
qualitative actions that contribute to meeting these obligations. Lastly the one-time supplement
could be enhanced by including a table for LEAs to demonstrate how they have met the concentration
grant funding requirement. Thank you and we look forward to working with you.
Hello caller please state your name and affiliation for the record.
You have one minute your time begins now.
Good afternoon my name is Melissa Elder. I'm calling from the Lincoln Indian Education Center
located in San Diego County which is a county with the most reservations in the country.
I'm calling in to support the change of requiring specific goals and measures for
specific subgroups as the member record alluded and additionally I would like to express that
Native American Indian students need to also be included as a subject subgroup because otherwise
they will be intentionally left out. These subgroup communities need to be directly consulted
and included in the conversations regarding the activities planned to address the goals to make
sure that these will be effective and meet the needs of various communities that are intended on
helping. While changing words to be more inclusive is important even more so is making concrete steps
to actively reduce trauma in our communities by being specific to include our Native communities
in subgroups and specific goals for them as a requirement. Thank you.
Hello caller please state your name and affiliation for the record.
You have one minute your time begins now.
Caller ending in two six one nine your time is now.
Hello caller please state your name and affiliation for the record.
You have one minute your time begins now.
Hello Madam President this is Brian Rebus calling on behalf of the Education Trust West.
I wanted to comment on the changes relative to qualitative improvements.
We think that many communities are going to be surprised and unhappy to learn that the law
permits LEAs to draw down money for unduplicated students but the law permits
LEAs to forgo spending those monies and we think that you could mitigate possibly
some of the negative reactions by making sure that the LCAP uses language that is clear,
that is easy to understand, what a qualitative improvement is, how it will help students,
and why it's a better choice of action than actually spending the money. So I would ask
try to think about it from the point of view of a low-income parent whose child is counted among
students to draw down funds and then think about how you would feel when you find out the district
isn't actually using the money. So the recommendations data.
Hello caller please state your name and affiliation for the record. You have one minute your time begins now.
We're not hearing anything. There appears to be a problem with the line. I'll see if I can get it to work.
Hello. Hello caller please state your name and affiliation for the record. You have one minute your time begins now.
My name is Kim Kenny and I'm a board member in Pasadena and the board member rep on the CPAC.
In the interest of helping LCAPs be clear and understandable to their readers I have the following
concerns which are detailed in more clear language in the late correspondence folder.
Number one, six new fields for showing carryover are called out specifically in Ed code section
52064B8A but are not included in this template thereby making it non-compliant.
Number two, for the new calculations for qualitative improvements and transforming dollars to percentages
it is important that there is public guidance on how these calculations should be done
either in the LCAP template itself or the instruction. Number three, it would be
beneficial to include all elements of calculations in the tables for instance A minus B equals C.
One example is that it's not clear how the proportionality obligation is calculated since
one component the LCFS base amount is not shown. Transparency is key to building the trust of the
community in our education system and in truly implementing local control. I appreciate the
modifications and clarifications that have been made in response to the feedback.
Hello caller please state your name and affiliation for the record you have one minute your time begins now.
Good afternoon, me Angela Reed on behalf of the Humboldt County Office of Education and the Small
School Districts Association. I greatly appreciate the comments of members Burns,
while we embrace accountability we believe the LCAP must stay a planning document if anything's
become clear over the last two years is that we don't know what the future might bring so we need
to be able to adjust. In addition we would greatly appreciate the addition of a table allowing us to
describe the actions taken because while folks will be working to meet the requirements that
we need to meet they may not be able to find the staff in an early time and we want to be able to
show the demonstrated that they are attempting to do so. Thank you for your consideration and
look forward to working with you. Hello caller please state your name and affiliation for the
record you have one minute your time begins now. My name is Anastasia with the Taren Organization
Network thank you to CDE staff and board members for your commitment to continuing to improve the
LCAP template. Overall the template doesn't address the parents have been requesting for a while
reporting the budget and expenditures of the school site level because financial information
is primarily available at the district level it isn't clear if district funding trickles down to
schools with more high need students. Also we advocate for more meaningful guidance for everyone
to understand quantitative and qualitative actions or services for high need students.
Providing more rules in LCAP templates without building capacity to qualify and quantify services
or implement them is not likely to yield better results so we agree with the idea of providing
more examples as well as different ways to calculate qualitative actions or concerned
qualitative funds may become a loophole or casual category for districts is not fully explained.
Thank you.
Hello caller please state your name and affiliation for the record you have one minute your time begins
now. Good afternoon this is Sarah Lewis with Teach Class. We want to associate our comments with those
of the LCFS Equity Coalition and the Alliance for Students. We appreciate all of the work
that the department staff has done over the last several weeks and beyond that in incorporating
many of our a mess of our feedback and the feedback from the CPAC. Unfortunately we don't
believe that the new template goes quite far enough to really allow local families students
and educators to engage in a meaningful way in the planning and accountability processes locally.
To that end we think that there needs to be additional instructions and reporting on the
qualitative improvements as well as you're concerned about how the guidelines around
the carryover funds do not follow the law on ABH 130 and really it's required that those
carryover funds be expended in the following year to benefit targeted students. Thank you.
Thank you caller.
Hello caller please state your name and affiliation for the record you have one minute your time begins now.
Good afternoon Carlos Machado with California School Board Association. I echo the comments made
by our fellow members in the education management and agriculture. Specifically we request the board
ensure that the revisions in the template and update to implement only those requirements
specified in statute to ensure the most effective transparency for each community. We appreciate
your recognition of the extensive work that districts and community leaders are engaged
in with the returns and personal learning. The recommendations made by our coalition will ensure
that they're able to focus on this important work. We appreciate your work your effort on this and
thank you for your time. Thank you.
Hello caller please state your name and affiliation for the record
you have one minute your time begins now.
Hello this is Shelly Stevel Coleman from Californians Together. We appreciate the quantity
of work that the department has put together and all of the attachments that we were reviewing.
In the template we believe clarifying language is needed as to how districts report the use of
carryover funds. On one hand the Edco section we reference indicates that carryover funds need to
be extended to improve or increase services. The word extended leads us to conclude money spent.
On the other hand there's a reference to a process that districts can use to meet the
proportional obligation through qualitative improvement that do not require funding. We are
concerned that districts could deliver could deliver all of their improved services meeting
the proportionality obligation and not extend any of their carryover money. We recommend that all
carryover money be spent quantitatively. We'd also like to reinforce what board member record rates
and reference to the new specific goals that emanate from legislation.
Hello caller please state your name and affiliation for the record
you have one minute your time begins now.
Good afternoon Dr. Darling-Hammond and board members. AXA would encourage the state to develop
a tool for county superintendents to use when reviewing district LCAPs to ensure calibration
and consistency around the state for LCAP review. In addition AXA is part of the coalition
education management and labor group. Continuing to underscore the importance of transparency
at a local and state level we believe the template with some minor adjustments will meet this goal.
With some minor adjustments will meet this goal. The coalition's recommendations include
appreciation for the draft focus on implementing statute and consistently allowing alliators
the ability to demonstrate how they are meeting the proportionality obligation quantitatively
and qualitatively. Requested guidance on calculating the percentage for qualitative action
conclusion of a table reference in our letter to provide additional information regarding
how additional concentration grant dollars are invested and provide clarity and increase
usability. Thank you. Thank you caller.
Hello caller please state your name and affiliation for the record
you have one minute your time begins now.
Tim Taylor executive director of California small school district association representing
60 percent of the school districts in California and we agree with the labor
administration associations. We have no interest in shirking our responsibility to be transparent
and accountable to our students and families. In small districts our students and parents are
family and we don't feel we'll be more accountable to them on paper than we are in person with
providing a more useful document. Many of our families are overwhelmed by the LCAP and we want
it to be open and accessible as possible. The majority of small districts use infographics
to help summarize their funding to improve student achievement. They do not use a 50 plus
page document. We request the department continue to work with small district leaders to continue
to create a more useful and family-friendly document that parents and the community will
read. We also appreciate CD and the board for working together on this document. Thank you.
Thank you caller.
Hello caller please state your name and affiliation for the record.
You have one minute your time begins now.
Good afternoon Madam Chair, John Affeld from public advocates. To address member Rucker's
question there is a standard and direction in AB 130 for how to establish the percentage
for qualitative improvement. 52070D1E makes clear that LEA LCAPs need to demonstrate and
counties need to verify that the degree of quality improvement claim is commensurate
with the amount of SEC funds apportioned that that claim percentage represents. So in other words
if you have a hundred million dollar MPP and you're claiming a one percent qualitative
percentage you need to show how that action is contributing roughly a million dollars worth of
quality to high school students over and above what all students are receiving. Secondly the
single catch-all prompt asking LEAs what you did with your carryover doesn't cut it. Those
actions need to be separately identified and justified. Thank you.
Hello caller please state your name and affiliation for the record. You have one minute your time begins now.
Thank you. Good afternoon President Darling-Hammond and members of the board. Patty Herrera on behalf
of the Oakland and Corona Norco Unified School District who join a coalition of education
organizations to support and offer improvements to the proposed LCAP template and one-time
supplemental template. We want to underscore our commitment to transparency and accountability
to the state and our community partners to ensure optimal use of resources for the benefit of our
students. In this spirit we believe that the proposed table describing how LEAs are using
their increased concentration grant funds to staff their high poverty schools achieves transparency
without making the LCAP an unreality strategic planning and engagement tool. We'd also like to
restate the importance of retaining the value of qualitative service improvements some of which
may not be monetized for students when calculating any portion of unimplemented or partially
implemented actions for unduplicated students. The state has long recognized that the quality
of the services we provide students is just as important as the quantity of the services we
provide. Thank you. That concludes our public comment.
All right thank you very much. I'm aware that we were anticipating a break for lunch after this
item but it is 12 51 and some of you may really need to eat in order to be able to have a good
discussion. So I suggest we take a 10 minute break so you can grab food we can eat during our
discussion as we have many times in this board and reconvene at about one o'clock to pick up
our portion of the discussion because I know there's a lot that people may want to contribute.
So take a moment grab whatever you would be sustaining yourself with and we will see you
back at one turn off your video camera and mute your mic but do not leave. Thank you.
Okay so we are now ready to really dig in and discuss and provide feedback to our team on the
LCAP template. I apologize would you like me to re-establish the quorum? Yes I would like you to
do that. Happy to do so. Please do. President. Vice President Strauss. Here. Member Rucker.
Present. Member Rodriguez. Here. Member Petillo-Brownson. Here. Member McQuillan.
Here. Member Glover Woods. Here. Member Escobedo. Present. President Darlene Hammond.
Here. Member Burr. Here. Member Bonacca. Here. Have a quorum. All right now we are ready to
dig in and discuss and I see that member Rucker is ready to go so kick us off please Pat.
Oh joy okay well first of all I do want to thank the staff for their effort in presenting
this document and I appreciate that this is for conversational purposes so for that reason my
comment my compliment is going to be well that was a good start so here's not what my I have a couple
of questions and some concerns that I want to share here that I hope can inform how the staff
the staff does in their continuing conversations not only with their technical design team
but with our very savvy staff of legal advisors as well as the stakeholders I think first and
foremost the point we need to begin with the pivotal question what do you want and you know
there's a difference between what is needed and what do you want the statute clearly defines
what needs to be included in the LCAP template but as was pointed out by board member Burr
this document is changing in both scope and aspect to be something that I'm not sure is clearly
what is wanted and so that's the reason why I asked the question you know where are the directions
that define how you compute this qualitative input the staff must have had some idea about
what that meant by putting the charts together that they offered as an example for illustrative
purposes in today's presentation so somehow or other there was some magic some computation some
thought put into the numbers that were in that column about qualitative improvement and so let
me begin by asking you to define what do you want actually represented when you talk about quality
just like any number quality has a number of facets to it is uh is the quality you're asking
districts to evaluate about their program inputs a peculiar or essential character so if it's going
to be that then you have to target students because there is some peculiarity about decisions
districts will make about their programs and where they direct those funds based on the students they
want to target is there some inherent feature about the district that these funds or these
expenditures are supposed to have an impact on based on what cindy kazan has said earlier
in going forward to not only implement the recommendations for identifying schools and
districts who would continue to be referred for the system of support but also in ways that will
inform how we compute the growth metric there's going to be some historical data included so are
we actually surprised that we have historical data that goes even beyond 2017 that says we have a
lot of underperforming student groups that can be easily identified by ethnicity and in that case
i'm particularly talking about african-american students so is there some inherent feature about
school districts who cannot for some reason figure out that they're under their african-american
students are specifically underperforming other student subgroups across all grade levels
in mathematics and they cannot for some reason feel compelled to call that out
in their qualitative evaluation of their program what i did see in the examples given really did
address the next two facets about quality one was capacity and role in the example that was
given by the staff it was a qualitative investment in staffing and in particular ways that staff
would provide specific direct services so that's one element but that's the only element that
was shown and the directions or at least the information that i saw in the template don't
quite align with that example is there something about the degree of excellence the investment in
professional learning or professional development that's an example of a qualitative investment
that is that but that's not a direct service yet those were things that were that also were talked
about or called out there is there needs to be some attention paid to what are the distinguishing
attributes about this program that are going to be different from previous efforts because that
is a recognition that what we've done before hasn't worked and here's what we're going to
take a look at and that takes us to the why so that's both the what and the why and linking
those things together but quality also comes down to leadership and the work that has to be done
to in the stakeholder engagement process and i'm very mindful of that fifth amendment
that's going to be made to address stakeholders because this is something that continues to be
called out with every successive meeting we have it's about stakeholder engagement it was painfully
pointed out by the complaints of district leadership at the july meeting when they were
complaining about the requirement to sit in their office by themselves and to write a plan concerning
school reopening and the use of the federal esser funds we're still stuck in this loop where
stakeholder engagement is an afterthought or something that happens after the plan is drafted
and then presented in some ways to stakeholders or at least that's the feedback i heard heard very
clearly from district leaders who called in and spoke to us in july so these qualitative investments
have to be based on a conversation that genuinely comes from discussion with stakeholders yet the
opportunity for this department and this board to exert some leadership to make sure that is the
kind of conversation that happens is not apparent or evident in this draft so i offer those criticisms
as gently as i can but as harshly as i believe needs to be offered so that we again can see
and say this is our board's opportunity to show leadership in this space about school improvement
but in particular i need to know that for the school districts that i have been following ever
since we implemented the l cap they have there's only six districts in this county and for all i
mean there's only six for all six of these leas african-american students are underperforming in
every single state test that is offered far below the other three larger school student subgroups
for this entire county yet if i go through the program section for all six of these districts
i can't count where african-american students are identified as the priority in all six of those
districts even six times i do not see where what you have written here is going to improve the
attention these six school districts in this single county will be paying for their underperforming
african-american students thank you thank you um member escapado then member sun i see your hands
up member escapado some suggestions i i do believe i i mean thank you for the presentation
it was an elegant way of seeing where the monies are being concentrated however i think it's very
important to have some ability to include an academic return upon investment again uh this
pretty much connected to what trustee rucker stated is that we have to ensure somehow that
we don't repeat strategies that do not work or have historically failed and and and is there
any type of research and development there no especially you know we've identified these
positive outliers so what you know how can we ensure that some of these research-based practices
that have demonstrated significant growth with either african-american or english learners
how do we we make sure that's part of this conversation and i do know that a lot of this
conversation occurs between the district and the county level however in my experience there's a
significant amount of time that focuses just on the formatting of the l cap document and and it
is my hope that that conversation shifts and because this i mean i'm a huge fan of the l cap
and and really the l cap has enhanced uh parent engagement it has been a great tool if if if used
properly i i think we need to tweak in in the area of how it's being used that really focuses on on
those populations that have not historically uh improved thank you all right members done
thank you i i just want to preface um these comments first by saying that this is not a
direct critique to the cde staff who worked very hard to put something together trying to meet
legislative requirements and various groups that have wanted various things to be tweaked within
the l cap but um i think that we have completely lost the force for the trees we have really lost
our way on lcff i appreciate um member burrs and member strouss's comments um at the very beginning
this is not what the intent of the l cap was supposed to be and we just continue to go down
this road of complexity uh you know i i completed l caps for my school and work with other schools
in l cap and in the what is it now seven years that we've had um the l cap it has become more
tedious and repetitive and completely taken us off the track of the strategic instructional plan
that that board member burr referred to if i think about my own parents who did not speak
english and were not educated in the united states they may have been able to understand
the l cap in the first maybe three additions of it if it had been translated into chinese
at this point in time it doesn't matter if it's translated or not they would not be able to
understand it and know why why would understand the purpose of it so i i just think that we need
to kind of re-look at it structurally and i'm hearing comments from um member rucker as well
is that we just really kind of need to step back and look at the whys of this um first of all
i you know so i just offer a couple of things one is that we still are using a one-size-fits-all
template for so many such a diversity of lea's within california we pride ourselves on diversity
and equity in this state and yet we've created this one template that's for all sizes of of
districts which does not make sense for me um and then when we're i now identify certain
districts to have to complete different parts of the l cap that just makes it even more complex
the second is that and i i think i mentioned this three versions ago when we were working on the l
cap is that i think we have evolved because the nuances and because of the details we it's it
doesn't fit into a 2d template we need something that's more 3d 4d whatever it might be so that
to get to some of the nuances and details it isn't a matter of looking at one 100 page document
that it needs to be more interactive in some way so that's a technology piece and that's something
that that we really need to consider moving forward the fourth is operational agreements
or principles i believe that we when we developed i believe it was the assessments we had some
operational principles that we wanted to adhere to as we were developing the assessments it may
have been accountability but we used to get michelle center used to remind us of that all the time
what our our principles are we haven't developed that for the l cap i think we really need to
develop some operational principles around this l cap before it gets further and further away from
us um and then the last piece is the quality piece that that member rucker was speaking to
i don't think that we get at quality through a form or template we get at quality through
coaching technical assistance professional development and that kind of work and we we
don't emphasize that enough when we say that lea's are not lea's are not
adhering to accounting for all of their funds and all that i think that is a role for the
county offices and cd staff to provide those types of technical assistance rather than try to cram
more and more things into this 2d template that doesn't fit what the intent and purposes were
in the first place so that's my comment thanks thank you okay vice president stroust and then
member bananca so um i want to build on what member sun and member rucker talked about um and
talk about first i think it's too complicated i think i made that comment in the beginning and
i would like some guidance and recommendations from cd staff and the input sessions they're going
to get about areas we can improve and reduce the redundancy and make this more useful but once we
get this template approved which we have to do by the end of november my question is then how does
it get translated and as we know we have more than a thousand lea's half of which are 2500 or less
which means they have a very small staff in the district office and the 58 counties and we know
that every thing is a little different based on size one la county 25 of all the kids in california
some counties one district so how we translate this now then back to school districts through
county offices is going to be incredibly important that we're consistent and so i'm hoping that
through cd and success that we can build a support and a communications tool which gives
clear messaging on how do you complete this based on the intent to meet the intent of the law and
the guidance of what we did and so again i think that would be something else i would request for
our november meeting which is once we get it to a point where we've met the legal requirements and
we've done the best we can this round how does that now get communicated to lea's through county
offices so that the communications on how to complete it are clear and the review process
is fair because my understanding from the field is county offices do this review differently
based on staffing and how they approach it so i think it's a whole system issue and i don't want
to deal just with the template and then have all the frustration at the district level which is
already there and how we you know and maybe member glover woods as a county office administrator
could help us think about how do we communicate this and get some continuity and some fairness
and consistency across the process as we go forward thank you thank you member
uh bananka and then member glover woods thank you so before i begin i'd like to thank the cdc
the cde staff yet again for breaking this item down so well through your presentation
beginning with the first part of this item regarding the underperforming student groups
and underperforming schools i completely agree with member ruckers comments that educational
partners engagement should not be considered as an afterthought when it comes to l cap so i would
recommend that we stipulate somewhere in there that lea's must consult students who are either
members of the low lowest performing groups or the students at those low performing schools when
writing their goal because i think it's so important just because of the fact that those
students are in the schools more than likely they understand what their school is missing out on
better than arguably anyone else because they're actually living that system and also i think we
should make sure that students aren't there just to check a box but their input is actually noted
and listened to i know that on my l cap committee it sometimes does feel like we're just there to
fulfill a requirement and that we're not necessarily being listened to or adults aren't making room in
the conversation for us so i think we need to include their input in these decisions for how to
write these goals addressing the underperforming student groups and schools and then in regards to
the second part regarding qualitative improvements and turning those into percentages
i completely agree with the many members that are stating that we need to clarify this a lot more
there needs to be more direct and explicit instructions on how to do this because it's
extremely subjective and it's definitely not something that you know an lea can just think
up off the top of their head and i also think that we really do need to make trainings accessible we
need to provide context give examples when we're explaining this so that it makes sense and i want
to echo vice president strauss and member burr's comments on ensuring that we don't convolute l cap
to the point where it only makes sense to the experts and not to the community members because
the whole point of l cap is to include the community it's to include the people that are
living the education system or being affected by it and so when it gets to the point where it's way
too convoluted then the entire purpose of l cap kind of fails to to be realized so i think that
the easier it is to understand the easier that we can make it to understand for just the common
person the more accessible it is and the more leas can truly receive community feedback and
engagement and i can just say as someone who did start on their l cap community not or committee
not really understanding um all that much about it i felt like when i started it felt like i was
reading a whole another language like a foreign language uh because there's so many technical
terms it's very confusing to someone especially students who are busy have extracurriculars may
be applying to college this isn't what they do for a living and so we have to keep that in mind
when developing these instructions on how to necessarily translate these qualitative
improvements into percentages
thank you um we have in the queue um member glover woods member burr and member patio brownson
member glover woods thank you um just a couple of points and not to rehash a lot of what has
already been said by my fellow board members but i think there are two key areas that we have um
talked about and i'm thinking about what has been asked in this item which is to provide feedback
one of the areas is to look at the recent requirements and see how to best represent
that in the template format the larger looming question which is not necessarily called for in
this item but which has been echoed by many of the board members especially those who've been
there from the onset is how to ensure that the LCAP retains its original purpose and i remember
the first template um reviewing and all of those different things and it has evolved into quite a
different document than what was originally intended um and quite a complicated document
and um i don't think it's of any fault of anyone who's provided feedback and input or the hard work
of the staff the CDE staff and the educational partners who provided input it's been a result
of a lot of different requests and requirements and it's just taken on a life of its own but at
the end of the day if it's to be a strategic planning document uh if no one can understand
what it is i'm not quite sure how it helps to direct the strategic plans that are to actually
be implemented so what i would um just encourage under the lane of feedback is that as uh staff
goes into conversation between now and the next november state board meeting um one is to grapple
with again the requirements and there were two things that were really brought forward how to
represent those qualitative supports and services for unduplicated pupils in a way that um maintains
the qualitative aspect of it but also is able to address some of the needs on how do we know
that um funds that were expended for quantitative purposes don't get lost in the shuffle the other
is really again i'm going to go back to one of the first ones which was clarifying goals
and for those requirements related to student groups that are performing below their peers
or schools within an lea it really seems that there should be something very clearly called out
in the goal section so that it is clear that those two areas are being addressed for the leas in
which that requirement would apply and then i just encourage moving forward i don't know that it can
happen between now and november but it seems like a very larger piece which is just convening more
conversation and more groups around what was the original intent of the l cap how does the story
and how does it maintain its purpose as a strategic planning document that's easily understood and
into and really uh contains the feedback from all educational partners that's a larger conversation
but i encourage that that conversation take place because i think we can get back to the
original purpose it's just going to take all of the educational partners together
um engaging in that conversation to do so thank you um i have member burr member patio bronson
and member mcquillin uh in in the lineup member burr thank you so i won't repeat what has been
so eloquently said by my fellow board members about returning to the original intent and having
that conversation but i want to take a little bit of a different tack here because one of the things
i'm concerned about is um knowing the context in which these requirements were enacted and i want
to return to i think our very start of this meeting and something that president darlingham
and said when we put the budget together this year we thought the school environment was going
to look very different and we thought the pandemic was going to be over and we were all celebrating
that has changed a lot and the um requirements that we have put on school districts with respect
to the pandemic all rightfully done and in the interest of public health and are especially the
health of our students and our staff are good ones but i worry a little bit that these requirements
about all of this very specific accounting and what's happening and are you going to spend all
your money were put on at a time when we thought things were going to be a lot better in terms of
the educational environment so i would just ask both our staff and the department staff to sort
of go back and think about that a little bit and also talk to legislative staff about what was your
intent here and i'll just give you a very specific example every time i heard the conversation about
carryover i thought oh my gosh these school districts just got a boatload of money which
they deserved and they but they're having a heck of a time hiring staff and they're going to find
themselves in the middle of the year with half a boatload of money because they can't hire the
staff they need especially staff counselors nurses folks who are in short supply anyway and if i
heard the details correctly we're going to expect them to expend all that money in the year we're
in right now or next year so i again i just i worry that we're setting our lea's up for failure
by a circumstance that has changed and i so appreciated president darling hamlin's comment
about we have been humbled by this and i feel like we are we have legislation that is still in a place
where we're not and we're not going to be for a long time so i don't want to be implementing
things i feel like we're trying to hit a moving target here a little bit that really are not
workable and i think that's a lot of what you were hearing especially from our lea partners
in the feedback so i i just want to think about that a little bit and i just want to circle back
to one thing that member sun said about operating principles what are our operating principles here
and maybe if we set some up in the content context of the environment in which we know
we're going to be operating and for some number of months and as president darling hamlin said
we don't know what we're going to happen as these additional variants come on board so
i just don't want to put our lea's and all of our education stakeholder partners
in a circumstance that's just not doable and make things even harder than they already are
oh well said member patty o'brownson
and i also wanted to thank the team for the eloquent presentation and also for being really
in the midst of so many people who have such high aspirations for how this document can work
it's only i think really a testament to how important it is that people are
sort of giving this level of feedback and interest and really giving voice to the aspiration that we
get it right i also wanted to align myself with the comments earlier from board member rocker
and escapado around the importance of actually naming the student populations where we are seeing
chronic underperformance and also naming the specific interventions and why we think they
will work this is i think been a continuing thread and it is it is the perfect place to sort of shine
a light on this and help lea's actually think through how to actually break through and actually
see some progress where we know there have been pockets of progress in some districts and where
of progress in some districts and where we have seen either a plateau or a lack of
attention in other districts the other theme i think that that has come across consistently
is a desire for greater clarification as to what a qualitative improvement should be defined as
i think the percentage designation that's on some of the charts gets to this idea but also
sort of flattens the idea of what a qualitative improvement might look like
it doesn't get to or yet address the idea of what a more effective intervention might look like
or necessarily urge that conversation to think about effectiveness beyond sort of what a percentage
calculation of on a chart might look like i'd also recommend that folks consider some of the sample
templates that have been offered in public comments the lcff equity coalition offered
what i think are actually quite helpful sort of back-to-back tables as suggestions for how
you could actually draw attention to what is different and what the change of strategy could be
and then the last thing i just wanted to raise which is is actually less than a part of the
conversation of the five amendments that that cde has presented for our consideration and is more
in the the bucket of general improvement and clarification potential for the l cap
so as as was mentioned earlier by the superintendent with the universal tk
budget and legislation that was enacted this year there is an opportunity i think to help
districts understand what that means through the l cap process i recall when the original
samidian legislation was passed back in 2010 which created the first cohort of
transitional kindergarten eligibility and i as then an advocate working with several school districts
recall hearing administrators superintendents tell me directly that tk students didn't generate
ada once we got to lcff i recall people directly saying tk students didn't need to or couldn't be
incorporated within a district's lcff l cap plan that they didn't generate supplemental grants that
they didn't count towards uh concentration configurations and all of that obviously is
and yet this is a prime document that could actually communicate that tk to 12 is the grade
span so i would encourage us as we think about clarifying moments where we can actually put in
language to reference the tk to 12 grade spans to call the district's attention to the opportunities
better before them
thank you uh member mcquillin and then member rodriguez
thank you i won't i'll be brief i know we're way over time now and uh we gave up our lunch i'm
feeling that uh thank you for all the great comments and thank you uh to our staff members
for presenting a very complicated uh the changes or amendments to the l cap that has become very
complicated and really should not be i i really appreciated our student members comments in that
the l cap has become very daunting and really should be a document that communities
can understand and can be made more succinct and understandable
but i i also agree with the comments that the low performing subgroups there needs to be a mechanism
that those groups are mentioned in the planning process in this planning document you know in our
areas of the north state we have many american indian students that are performing very low
in terms of their their scores across the board and many districts are not setting goals or
mentioning the subgroups there i know one of the callers pointed that out also so i agree that we
need a mechanism to ensure that those subgroups are a part of the plan and being addressed within
the plan and then the other part i will um carry this forward to the american indian oversight
committee i think it was amendment number five where some changes in the language moving away
from the stakeholder words and and looking for suggestions there of maybe partners or
interested parties or looking for other wording there you know we we do live in a more compassionate
world now and you know the changes that we're undergoing when we look at the mascot issue or
sports professional sports teams that are changing and dropping their names and
or even ski resorts that need to look at their names and changing those that
are insensitive to the first peoples and the indigenous peoples of of the land here
so i appreciate that that component and that possible amendment also thank you thank you
member rodriguez yes thank you um and i want to thank everybody um and especially the cd for this
very complete um presentation and you know i echo everything that's been said especially naming the
students um and one of the things that that really struck me because this has been on my
mind a lot member bananca your very articulate um exposition about the experience with the l cap
and just how um it feels like a foreign language um and so i i'm all for more clarity and making
it understandable and digestible too so that people feel like they can contribute you said
something that really struck me because i've been thinking about this a lot and that's the checklist
and i think that what happens is you know because of nclb districts are still kind of in that
mindset of very compliance oriented and so there's this checklist instead of thinking
we have these students right that we've named that we really need to give extra supports to
how can we creatively do that and as opposed to like oh they all came to the meeting and so we
met that requirement so i really hope that we as a board look a lot more at those students and
name them and see how we can best serve them so that they can achieve their academic goals
and dreams because they they do have them you know just for they they they start letting go of them
when our schools can't serve them or won't serve them and lastly i want to comment on the stakeholder
um expression i've always found that to be very aggressive and violent and for that reason like
i pictured like oh i'm laying my stake here and so i was really excited to hear hear um us looking
for another word uh for to express the the partners the communities that come together
for the betterment of our schools thank you thank you and i think everyone has commented i will
simply associate myself with a lot of the comments that have been made i want to thank the staff
again for the enormous work that's gone into the process i think we have some clear goals in mind
and i know that it's challenging when on the one hand we have legislation asking for you know much
more specificity of certain kinds and on the other hand we still want to preserve the nature of this
document as the strategic planning tool and as something that is both understandable by
constituencies and manageable by educators i want to hold up member burr's comments about you know
how much adjustment and readjustment and re-readjustment educators have had to do over
this last year and we'll need to do over this next year and that we need to have that frame of mind
and we need not to box people in so that they feel like they have to do things that are sub-optimal
you know because they're trying to meet a compliance requirement you know educators
across the state for the most part are focused on trying to serve the you know children and
families i think there's a strong message from the board that students who are struggling and
performing less well in any respect need to be explicitly attended to in the thinking about
the strategic planning and in the communication on the tool and then you know we need to make
ways for that tool to be useful and legible i also want to affirm the thanks to the staff
for raising up the issue of changing the language around stakeholders and for that sensitivity
and look forward to the new language that will emerge and finally i want to recognize that
member mcquillin noted that he gave up lunch and i don't want anyone giving up lunch so let me
suggest to you that if you need a personal break as i said at the beginning just text brooks when
you have to go off camera and take a personal break get food if you need to eat it off camera
do what you need to do to be fortified because we are only halfway through
i need you strong and engaged and no one should be angry here because they had to give up lunch
so we do want you to take care of yourselves a little self-care here and with that we are
going to conclude this item and it's an information item i i'm sure that the staff
has taken away a great deal to ponder and to work on and we will work with them in a
collaborative spirit to get to the to the goal we're not going to take a break formally because
we are about an hour behind where we had thought we might be so i do encourage you if you did not
grab some food to take a personal break if you need to grab it don't be embarrassed about eating
on camera whoever's talking is actually i think spotlighted so if you're not talking you're
probably safe to eat your lunch and we will go on to item number four which is the new targets for
state performance plan indicators in the annual performance report for part b of the individuals
with disabilities education act of 2004 and the cde is recommending that we review and provide
the department with feedback on the proposed new targets and they'll return in november
to present the final targets for consideration for approval and the item will be presented by
heather calamities of the cde so heather please do you
thank you so much and
good afternoon um president linda darling hammon and sb members i'm glad to see you all and hope
all that is well today's agenda item tells an exciting story of the trajectory of the special
education in california the state performance plan which is part of the apr is much more than a
required federal submission to the office of special education programs it is the heart and
soul of our special education system it's our north star it's why we do the work that we do
the presentation of this material is a culmination of many meetings
many hours and many discussions over the past several years the efforts by our community led
by cde special education staff and our partners to meaningfully make changes to our system are
heroic the spp targets are our key levers of improvement to systems which ultimately result
in improvement to student outcomes our new proposed targets reflect input from a wide variety
of the special education community here in california and it is an honor and an opportunity
to present our roadmap as we believe our paths will continue to get brighter in the days and
weeks and months to come in regards to the timeline that has been mentioned previously
the cde is required to submit the spp targets and the 2020 apr in february of 2022
in order to meet the required deadline you will be reviewing and providing feedback
on the proposed targets in this presentation in november you will be voting to approve the
proposed spp targets in january of 2022 you will be reviewing and approving the 2020 annual
performance report which is known as the apr in february both are submitted for review and
approval by os by osep once submitted the cde staff meets with our osep assigned contact for
comments questions and clarifications and the typical process concludes by april of may of each
year in terms of the experience for students with disabilities in california the next slides will
walk through some basic demographic information for our students and about our students so that
you can get to know them a little bit better you have seen these slides before in previous
presentations but i think it's important for us to ground ourselves in the demographic specifically
of who we're referencing in this presentation and we know that the numbers in the next slide
present the faces of our students in our communities and in our schools and in our families
but the numbers tell a story of a system in need of intervention we have identified a need
and we have provided support our education system is deeply complex and deeply rooted in social
justice our society chose not to educate students with disabilities in the 1970s and instead we
chose institutionalizing and pathologizing our students with our students with disabilities
special education remains an issue of social justice and equity and invisibility and the
state of california has made significant historic and visionary investments in special education
the education experience of students with disabilities is just one of the foundational
experiences that frame and shape and influence who our students will become the experience is
much more than a series of academic events or progressing from grade to grade the experience
includes making meaning of living life with a disability developing skills to navigate the world
and knowing that disability includes a stigma in part of our society and also the pursuit of
excess full access and opportunity is our ultimate end game so in 2020 2019 and 2020 school year
there are just north of 804 000 students with disabilities ages 0 to 22 0 to 22 served in the
california public school system 752 000 are k-12 students with disabilities which represent
12.2 percent of california's k-12 population of just over six million the numbers in terms
of the representation of percentage of students with disabilities in the state of california
is on par with many of the other states across the country in terms of proportion of students
with disabilities identified in their total student population the next slides in which
you've seen before point out specifically students within each group who are identified
as having IEPs in the local control funding formula from 2019 to 2020 so the first pie chart
that you see before you outlines that 13 percent of our students with IEPs are also identified as
socioeconomically disadvantaged students that also have IEPs in the local control funding formula
there are 27 percent of foster youth with IEPs and then there are 17 percent of english learners
with IEPs as well
the next pie chart here outlines out of the students with disabilities total how many
students actually are identified in one or more LCFF student groups in 2019 2020 so in this pie
chart here you will see that 70 percent of our student groups or 70 percent 70 percent of students
with IEPs are also located are found or identified as also being identified in the LCFF student groups
in terms of our demographics and how we monitor and support students with disabilities across
the state of california in the special education division we tier our LEAs in terms of
needing support direct support from the CDE and our technical assistance partners
and so on the right hand side you will see i'm sorry the left hand side you will see
the the levels of one intensity in which we engage with our LEAs across the state
and two the number of LEAs that are found or that have been identified in each tier by the CDE
so in our intensive targets there are 204 LEAs identified in our targeted
tier there are 1400 just over 1400 LEAs and then in our universal tier there are just over 500
and the corresponding inverted triangle that you see is an indication or visual representation
of how the CDE and our technical assistance partners provide support to our LEAs across
the state directive support assistance and then resources it is also important to note that
there are 203 LEAs as noted that have been identified for differentiated assistance for
student outcomes so in that left hand triangle that you see somewhere along the line those 203
LEAs are somewhere either in the intensive targeted or universal tier
as we walk through the rest of the presentation and the rest of the data here today it's important
to note the conditions that are placed or or actually upon our system that present challenges
and barriers to alignment of our systems and ensuring more inclusive efforts across the state
first and foremost the teacher shortage which many of which you've heard about today
severely impacts the field of special education and the impact is felt at the student level
for students with disabilities not only as a teacher shortage you know at the teacher level
but we also are experiencing shortages of related service providers,
paraprofessionals and special education administrators there's a need for additional
access to the general education environment and we'll talk a little bit more later about
we'll talk a little bit more later about inclusion inclusive environments through one of our
indicators indicator five the need for additional universal design for learning resources and
training across the state of California in talking with one of our SELPA improvement leads
the one of the number one requests for our teachers by our teachers across the state of
California additional opportunities to learn more about implementing UDL in the classroom
the conditions also in terms of having two side load systems that run parallel both at the LEA
level and also the state level as well we know that special education is part of the general
education system however over time those two systems have existed and crossed paths only
when necessary or needed and more intentional efforts are needed to bring greater alignment
to both of those systems statewide and also the need to examine and address
the implication of inherent bias and systemic racism in our systems of identification placement
and discipline as well as I mentioned in the opening slide the annual performance report
contains the state performance plan so the APR consists of 17 indicators indicators are
categorized as either compliance or performance and then there's one indicator that has a both
of compliance and performance elements the state performance plan that you will be hearing about
today is about setting the state targets for the next six year cycle the annual performance report
that is also part of the package is merely our annual reporting on how California is progressing
towards those targets as well the combination of these two activities is known as the SPP APR
so the past cycle started in 2013 and ended in 2019 and our new targets will be set from 2020
to 2025 over a two-year period nine meetings were held in terms of engagement in the feedback and
the development of the new targets as well the meetings began in August of 2019 and included a
diverse educational partnership group that you see before you today these meetings were designed
to engage community members from various backgrounds included educators included parents
school administrators policy advisors school psychologists family empowerment centers and
early education and advocacy groups these meetings were held in person prior to covid and then
virtually during the pandemic in terms of the feedback timeline mapping from August of 2019
to now the associate director Shiloh Duncan Bessaril and said staff presented the performance
indicators to our community the presentations included an explanation of how each indicator
is defined measured and calculated and an in-depth history of the statewide performance trends over
the past five years along with data forecasting these meetings provided time for the community
to discuss statewide data target setting and and how the CDE can provide supports for LEAs
to meet the more rigorous targets the community was actively engaged and asked critical questions
in their pursuit of developing the suggested targets and the community members also brought
their unique perspective and also worked in small groups to discuss and develop the suggested targets
The I will first walk through the compliance indicators and rather quickly and then move on to
the performance indicators which is the meat really of this conversation today. I want to recognize
that compliance is certainly important and the foundation of the work that we do to ensure that
there are appropriate services timely services and timely assessments for students with disabilities
but however in 2014 OSAP shifted their focus from compliance to results to work with states
to develop their systems to mirror the the fact that compliance is is one measure
but really looking at results is is the direction that the state and the federal government will go
The first of our compliance indicators are 4B, 9, and 10. These targets are set by OSAP
not by the state of California or our community group and the followed the following indicators
also comprise what we know are what are typically referred to as the disproportionality indicators.
4B is rates of suspension and expulsion by race race and ethnicity. That target is set at zero as
are all the other compliance targets that are set by OSAP as well and so this target measures the
percentage of LEAs that have a significant discrepancy in by race or ethnicity and the rate
of suspension expulsion is greater than 10 days and the rate of suspension expulsion is greater
than 10 days in a school year and also include policies and practices and procedures that
contribute to that discrepancy as well. The second of those is what we call disproportionate
representation. This compliance indicator also set at zero measures the percent of LEAs that have
disproportionate representation of racial ethnic groups in special education related services.
The third compliance indicator is what we refer to as indicator 10 which is again
disproportionate representation in race and ethnic groups in specific disability categories.
Indicators 12, 13, and 14 are also considered compliance indicators and those targets are set
at 100 percent. Child fund comprises indicator 11 ensuring that students
have an appropriate evaluation within 60 days of receiving parental consent for that initial
evaluation to be conducted. Early childhood transition in terms of part receiving students
receiving part C transitioning to part B services and those who are found eligible prior to age three
must have an IEP developed and implemented by their third birthday.
The third compliance indicator comprising this group is secondary transition and again this
compliance indicator measures the percent of students with disabilities ages 16 and above
with an IEP that includes measurable post-secondary goals. It's important to note that the age of
transition in California is the age of 16 which is the federal sort of bar that is set though
many states often choose grades lower than 16 but California currently at 16 a student must
have a transition plan with appropriate goals in their IEP.
As we move on to the performance indicators we know that a healthy start to education begins
before birth. We know it starts with high quality prenatal care early learning experience experiences
that develop the whole child that really set up young learners for success. We know that timely
assessment is critical for students suspected of having a disability so that interventions
can be provided at an early age to mitigate the impact of the identified disability.
Second to that is timely assessment accurate assessments performed by qualified staff
and conducted in a collaborative manner lead to identification of the right supports
for students so that instruction can be aligned to the goals set forth within the student's IEP.
Moving along on our road in terms of the pathway of success is notated in the in the indicators.
Ensuring the appropriate supports and services are provided in the right setting also ensures
access to the general education curriculum most appropriate to student need in order to maximize
impact. LRE or least restrictive environment is more than just a description of the supports and
services that often encompasses a belief and a mindset about students with disabilities.
While a continuum exists for a reason it's critical that IEP teams discuss ways to support
challenge and foster growth and independence for our students.
Moving along on our roadway or highway the right evaluation and setting ensures that students are
also supported from a social emotional standpoint including behavioral needs. Too often students
that are receiving the right types of supports can be can become disengaged which often result
in being placed in more restrictive settings or disproportionately being disciplined and or
suspended which includes then of course missing instructional valuable instructional moments in
the classroom setting. Statewide assessments play a critical role on the road map as well
ensuring the best possible result on assessments are the result of many of the other factors and
indicators that you will see before you and so that some of it compromises or not compromises
comprises the result of timely assessments, identification and the right provision of supports
to students. As students prepare for the off-ramp of education with graduation and the on-ramp
towards independence, graduation plays a huge role in ensuring that students have full access
to a post-secondary experience that is most appropriate for our students. After leaving
the formal K-12 setting our goal is to ensure that students are able to meaningly participate
in our communities. This means continued partnerships with our partners at the Department
of Rehabilitation and others because whether students are seeking a college experience,
a technical trade experience or an employment experience we must ensure that options exist
that do not relegate our students to narrow pathways of what it means to be an adult with a
disability. Starting with the first of our performance indicators we begin with our
preschool indicators and they're comprised of six sub-indicators and so preschool LRE as we call it
is essentially where a child ages three to five receives the majority of their special education
supports and services. The notable changes that have been implemented by OSEP for this round
of this cycle means that five-year-old kindergartners are excluded from the calculation
and that there is a new sub-indicator 6C that measures home settings and services being
provided in the home. Indicator 6A is essentially as stated before the percentage in which where
students three through five are receiving the majority of their special education
supports and services in a regular early childhood program. So you see here before you and in your
packet the performance on the old targets from 2013 with the top column in row indicating the
new targets that have been set by our community and our community engagement. California would
like to see better growth in this indicator with no universal pre-k. This is a challenge that
California is trying to address. The national mean for this indicator in particular is about 50%
and we are performing way below but we have set our targets closer in the coming years to get
closer to that result. As a comparison to other sort of like states in terms of demographic and
size to California, Texas's results indicate 26.7% and New York right at 42%.
6B the other sub-indicator for preschool LRE is children with disabilities three through five in
a separate special education class, separate school or residential facility and you see the
targets here that California has not been meeting the indicator for the past few years
and with fiscal supports and additional technical assistance CDE expects the result for this
indicator to improve over time. The national mean for this indicator is 20% and again in other
states comparison in terms of Texas and New York, Texas is right at 26%, New York is right at 23%.
The last which is the new indicator that I mentioned before is a percentage of students
three to five receiving special education services in the home. The guidance obviously is
that this target in the indicator is supposed to decrease. It's important to note that our
community members that engaged around this target setting activity felt very strongly that this
indicator should that parents should not be discouraged from having their children receive
services in the home and that LEAs should not be disincentivized for providing this option.
Our community believed that the target should stay stagnant
with the 0.1% drop in the last year to meet the OCEF requirement.
The next indicator is indicator seven which is centering preschool assessment. The assessment
indicators measure preschool assessment across several indicator areas and so you will see a
7A, 7B and a 7C. 7A essentially measures the social emotional progress for our students
with disabilities. 7A, I'll just actually go through the table now, shows that
the of those children entering into preschool program below age expectation in each outcome
the present who substantially increased their rate of growth by the time they turned six or exited
the program. The 7A2 that you see below 7A1 is the percentage of children who are functioning
with age expectations in each outcome by the time they turn six or exited the program.
And again we have varied results over the years in terms of this indicator. 7B measures the
percent of children with disabilities who demonstrate improvement in essentially learning
communication and literacy and so looking at these targets and the previous target performance
summary 7B1 which you see in the first row and column indicates the children who entered preschool
below age expectations in each outcome and the percent who substantially increased their rate
of growth by the time they turn six. And 2, 7B2 is the percent of children who are functioning
within age expectations in each outcome by the time they turn six or exited the program again.
And again you see mixed results in this indicator and 7C is really centers behavior for students
with disabilities and so the improvement in the use and appropriate behavior is really to meet
their needs and so again statement one entering and below the age expectations and then who
substantially increased their rate of growth and then the summary statement two which is the same
across all who are functioning with age expectations in each outcome by the time they turn six or
exited the program as well. That takes care of our preschool indicators moving along on our road map
that you saw earlier centering students assessments for school age students.
This indicator saw the most significant changes at the federal level hence why states are now
pivoting to really begin a substantial or substantive discussion on this indicator as well.
Focusing on these three grade levels grade four, grade eight, and grade 11 will provide the
following advantages that should be seen and felt in the state of California. One it mitigates
prevents the masking of high performance low performance or no improvement or improvement
that would occur if all grades were combined to generate an average. It focuses on the effectiveness
effectiveness of early elementary education or instruction i.e. K-3 literacy programs which
is a critical time in literacy development and then also focuses on a successful transition to high
school from middle to junior high school to high school and then also continues to focus on high
school with the post-secondary outcomes of students transitioning into adult life.
It's important to note that the dashboard assessment rate is different than this assessment
calculation here and so the dashboard combines the smarter balanced summative assessments
and the California alternative assessments for grade three through eight and 11 to determine
performance and the opposite here where student groups are broken out.
So staying with indicator three wanted to provide a few or a couple slides in terms of just the
performance and talk about the achievement gap of students with disabilities. This data was pre-COVID
in 2018 to 2019. The blue bar that you see to the left indicates the proficiency level for students
with disabilities and the percentage of students who tested proficient compared to all students.
This chart really meant to show the visually the physical gap between proficiency levels
and students with disabilities for all students. Moving into the sub-indicators of 3A.
3A measures the participation rate and it's quite simple as is that did the child sit
and take the assessment and it's important to note why this indicator is important and why we
still measure it at the state level because historically students with disabilities were
excluded and not given opportunities to to take or access statewide assessments. So it's important
to ensure that our students have equal access to take the assessments to learn more about their
growth moving forward so that we can continue to provide improved supports and services to them as
well. In terms of our participation performance you will see here that again broken out the grades
four eight and eleven that we our our targets were at 95 previously and our targets will continue to
be 95 moving forward as well and to keep in line 95 was chosen to keep in in line with the
recommendation that with the by the ESSA and the CDE is maintaining the the targets at 95 percent.
Indicator 3B discusses the proficiency level against the grade level standards.
3B measures the rate for children against the grade level standards again calculated separately
in ages four eight and eleven and as you can see by these target charts the proficiency has
been grouped by LEA type and while some of these targets are low particularly in grade eight and
eleven the benefit of setting targets by grade is it enables CDE to see where to focus our resources
lower than what we had before. We recalculated the prior years with a new calculation
in the grade eight and eleven were lower performing so again it allows an LEA
you know to to see where they might be able to focus their resources a little bit with a little
bit more intention and a little more specificity as well. Previously the old targets were clumped
together by district and again it's you know much more beneficial to
really look at these grade bands to provide additional opportunities for growth and learning.
Indicator 3C again measures the proficiency in terms of the California alternate assessment
and again we're referencing a group of students that have the most significant
disabilities and are unable to take the traditional standard statewide assessment
and typically in California that number hovers near one percent as it does nationally at the
national level and this is new again because the APR previously combined the grade level and
alternate standards assessment and again we have a grade breakout which again mitigates the high
low performance and also provides I think real-time information for the state and the
LEA to to respond and react to. And as you can see by these target charts the proficiency
again has been grouped by LEA type and again the the targets were set by the community groups
and then used by recalculating data from prior years as well.
3D, proficiency gap rates. This does not include data for the students that take the California
alternative assessment but 3D measures the proficiency rates for students against those
grade level academic achievement standards as well and the gap that remains in between.
So this visual is meant to you know visually represent the achievement gap in that indicator
that goes along with 3D. Each chart is what the gap is for that year so how the data will be
represented in the future obviously is that we want the gap to close as you see and take a look
from the right to the left and grade grades four grades eight and grades 11 in terms of the gap
of the proficiency gap for students with disabilities. We still have much work to do
to ensure that our students are decreasing over time and that we are sure that
you know students are receiving the right supports and services as well.
And again this is an entirely new indicator for the state of California
and so our targets are set as such.
Indicator four suspension expulsion measures the rate of suspension expulsion. Again there were no
notable changes however it is important to note two things. One the way this calculated is is
different than the dashboard calculation and that this data is lag year data which means it's one
year behind in terms of reporting. In terms of the difference between the dashboard and special
education the year this indicator four measures the percentage of LEAs that have a significant
discrepancy in the rate of suspension expulsions it's greater than 10 days and the dashboard
captures the numbers of students suspended for the aggregate of a total of one day.
And then moving on to indicator five indicator five is is what we call our LRE
our least restrictive environment indicator. Again this is measuring sort of how and where
the students are receiving their supports in you know in terms of accessing the general education
curriculum. To put a perspective in moving the needle and changing this indicator to see a one
percent change in this indicator would nearly be the equivalent of moving the needle for seven
thousand students. This is traditionally is a very slow growing indicator nationally the average
rate of change at the national level is 0.21 percent in 5a as well. So LRE is slow growing
for a variety of reasons as it calls in philosophies beliefs mindsets programming it touches on teacher
shortage it touches on all the sort of considerations that we mapped or talked about before.
And so again you know I think that while California and you see here the current
placement of students with disabilities you see that you know we are
here in terms of students receiving their their performance or they're receiving their education
in the general education classroom with 80 percent or more of the day you see our performance targets
here previously and then the new targets
for the coming years. While we have met our targets California lags behind other states
in this indicator. We have seen consistent growth over the past six years but we would like to see
increased numbers for this indicator over time which is reflected in the targets. The national
mean for this same time period is 65 percent and we're getting closer but we're not yet there.
Other states in the comparison again Texas and New York Texas 71 percent New York 58 percent.
The other sub indicator 5b measures the students that are served in a regular class less than 40
percent of the day. California has been meeting the targets for this indicator and has seen a
steady decline over the past seven years and so with additional TA and supports California can
make progress in this area. The national mean for this indicator hovers around 11 percent
and we've set our targets closer to get us to that number. A comparison of Texas and New York
New York is at 19 and Texas is at 14. It's important to note that this sort of band of
supports and services that students receive oftentimes includes students that sometimes
are close to progressing to being educated in lesser restrictive environments in the in the
next sort of category or 5a category moving forward. So there's a very I think sort of
strategic conversation that should happen regarding within LRE in terms of how we're supporting our
students is sort of each sort of band of the way and this group here I think is critical to
part of that discussion. Indicator 5c is the percentage of students that are placed in a
completely separate environment that would be a separate school that could be a separate facility
that could be homebound or a hospital setting. Like the rest of the syndicator 5a and 5b
California has seen a steady decrease and has been consistently meeting the target every year.
The national mean is 2.8 percent and California is is seeing some progress but we'd like for
this indicator to continue to improve as well. That takes care of it for our LRE indicators.
Next we move into graduation and we are winding down our indicator tour.
Indicator 1 is a graduation indicator and the one change is that the OSEP is requiring that
states use a one-year calculation not a four-year adjusted cohort rate. This graduation indicator
is different than the dashboard graduation indicator calculation and again this is lag year data as well.
Our data from 2015 to 2016 is a is is a little looks a little interesting. I should just say it
that way but the again this is lag year data. This is calculated from exit data and the one-year
calculation could make the results from graduation subject to more volatility.
We may see more ups and downs as well.
14 post-school outcomes so here we come at the end of the road of the road map and so
it's important to note in terms of whether students are enrolled in higher education
employed or enrolled in other post-secondary education within one year there was no change
and so there are there's a small change that actually I think will produce I think big results
and interesting conversation to follow is that states now must choose to get two categories to
measure the representative of respondents to the survey. Critical to this conversation is CDE will
use not only disability category in terms of the survey but also collect race and ethnicity data
and I think it's really important for us to in order to address our continual issues of equity
within special education to ensure you know that students that fall within various race race and
ethnicity categories are represented in the survey so that we see if they're enrolled in higher ed
if they're employed or enrolled in other some sort of sort of post-secondary education within
that one year window. 14a again is another sub indicator role and students enrolled in higher
education within the one year and we see our targets here that we do see increased growth
over time for these students. 14b is students are students that are educated in higher ed
or competitively employed within the one year and here we see the results again we continue to see
steady growth we'd like to see continued growth in the future and 14c measures the the percent of
youth no longer in secondary school and are enrolled in some sort of education or training
program or competitively employed. And again here we do see an increase we'd like to see that
increase over time as well. Last but not least is our combo indicator which is the
our state systemic improvement plan or ESSEP as we call it. It is a combination of performance
and compliance. The ESSEP was developed in phases and was evolved to align with our
statewide accountability system and statewide system of support. And again the goal is to
obviously achieve coherence and alignment across our systems in order to better meet the needs
of our students. Our theory of action for our ESSEP as we call it is our sort of state identified
measurable result you know is looking at the performance of all students with disabilities
who took the California assessment of student performance and progress in both ELA and math.
And so our ESSEP is focused on creating systemic and sustainable change including the necessary
alignment as well. Prior to 2016 as we look for continual efforts to align
accountability systems between general education and special education
the accountability system was largely separate. The inclusion of students with disabilities in
the dashboard including DA and the statewide system of support has really I think for us
elevated some of the the gaps that we need to address in terms of improving the outcomes not
only for all of our students but also students with disabilities as well. The SPP and APR
is part of the general supervision system. It's a requirement of our federal government as well.
The you know the shift to compliance to results you know is important and I think it's an
improvement to ensure that our approaches remain structurally sound and really
rooted and integrated into our local state and federal accountability measures.
And again discussing some of the alignment activities between our accountability systems
for students with disabilities is we've invested 10 million dollars per year through our SELPA
LEAD and our SELPA LEAD grants. We have moved from a separate system from CASEMAS to CALPATS
and then we use in the special education department our dashboard data to select LEAs
to ensure alignment. In terms of our state systemic improvement plan and our targets
there's some notable changes here but OSIP only allows one target for the ESSEP
and so our community group that gave input into our targets indicated and agreed
to keep the targets similar to our 3B math and ELA targets on the same trajectory.
In terms of next steps in where we go over the next six years really I think you know in terms
of our efforts starts and ends at the classroom level. Everything that we do from the state,
county, LEA, to the school, SELPA really rolls upwards and down and back and forth
in terms of ensuring that our efforts, our system of support, our state funded technical assistance,
the IDEA funded technical assistance that we receive along with our legislative investments
that you will hear about in just a moment are aligned and focused on our students with
disabilities as well. So our SELPA LEAD contents focus on getting training into the classroom,
into the teachers. Our Golden State teacher grants around 486 were awarded last year totaling 7.5
million. We have our supporting inclusive practices project which again promotes and
fosters inclusive environments for our students and then obviously MTSS, our MTSS system ensuring
that both the academic and social emotional needs of our students are met and supported
from early identification. In terms of the pathway forward you see another road map in front of you
with some key levers I think that we think are sort of the cornerstone of change.
LRE being one of them as you see increasing you know inclusive practices at the pre-k level
including universal pre-k with dedicated slots for students with disabilities.
Addressing some of the teacher shortages and credentialing issues
ensuring that we have teaching staff that is appropriate credentialed high quality in the
classroom. In addition to ensuring that there is effective communication between community and
school and also addressing equity and disproportionality as we know that many of our students are excluded
or suspended are students of color with located within special education and so focusing on
addressing some of those impacts to the system along with some of the other
measures here will provide I think a solid road map moving forward. Some of the investments that
you see on the right hand side are the vehicles to move this work. You will see 260 million of
early intervention special education funding. We've got 500 million in the golden state teacher
grants 350 million in the residencies 125 million in the classified school and employee teacher
teacher credentialing program. 450 million in the special education learning recovery grants
which provides opportunities for LEAs to ensure that the impact of COVID is mitigated and students
are receiving and progressing and growing as they return to in-person instruction.
There's 100 million in alternative dispute resolution grants which is meant to provide
additional opportunities to solve and resolve issues at the IEP table versus progressing through
more serious sort of progression in terms of resolving disputes and then a notable
increase to our supporting inclusive practices which will allow to expand SIPP's reach
throughout the state almost doubling the amount of grantees that they will be able to work with
to improve support and improve inclusion across the state as well.
That concludes today's presentation and a tour through our indicators.
Thank you very much and happy to take questions at this time.
Thank you. Oh wow what a very very comprehensive tour. We really appreciate it and we'll start by
getting folks queued up for public comment. The members of the public who are wishing to
provide comment on this item can do so by calling the telephone number listed on this
slide and using the participant access code. While we're waiting for members of the public
to call in I want to ask Vice President Strauss if she has any initial comments.
Then we'll take any clarifying questions public comment and come back for discussion. Thank you.
So Heather I just want to thank you for a really clear presentation on a lot of indicators and I
think what I want to say is this really gives us a big picture of the many many complexities
that special needs students that we have to consider for them what school districts need
to take into account and I appreciated earlier in the presentation the conditions that you
discussed which really impact our ability to meet some of these goals. So my understanding is this
is comprehensive and it's required at the federal level but as you said it is guidance for us that
can actually help guide our work forward to improve practices for students. I just think we
have to remember that we're focusing on an inclusive environment which wasn't the way it
always was and you said that I think actually as of 2016 so this is a big change both in teacher
skillsets and strategies and the issue of capacity building for teachers at a time when
we have a huge shortage of teachers particularly in the area of special education. I appreciated
all the investments that you had toward the end of the presentation and the commitment by the
governor and the legislature to really dedicate but putting the money there we still have to get
the staff and the support to do the work. The other thing I would say is that as we look at what the
needs are this document is sort of the top down and then changes the bottom up. It's sort of how
do you get the pressure to pay attention to these issues and then build the capacity and I appreciated
the second to the last slide which showed how the system of support is connected and I actually would
like a little bit more enhancement on the on the role of the CELPA leads because as you said it's
a very siloed system and these are our students who need so much support in a variety of ways
and how we actually move to build capacity and get the system. I would say when you listed the
numbers of LEAs who qualify for assistance in a variety of areas I would say most districts
identify the need to support special needs students. So with the goal of coherence and alignment
if you did all these goals you would never make progress you really have to help
districts stay focused to make some progress toward their goals. So I'm interested just as
the state lead on this how you see the system of support and the CELPA leads guiding it and then
I'll turn it over for any clarifying questions to more members before we go to the public comment.
Thank you. Sure thank you Vice Chair Strauss. In terms of the the CELPA improvement leads that
you that you mentioned the the our CELPA leads are tasked with with ensuring that the the data
use and data governance they're focusing on continuous improvement also the implementation
of high level practices are instituted implemented across across the state as well.
The the the work that they do is is foundational and critical along with our content leads
to ensure that we are addressing a multifaceted group of students as students with disabilities
and empowering our teachers and educational staff across the state to ensure that they are equipped
and resourced to address teaching and learning the way it looks now and moving forward as well
and you know the shift that happened during the the COVID-19 pandemic amongst our leads and amongst
our content leads is is monumental taking many in-person trainings taking them online having
maximum capacity and maximum reach and so you know we are pleased to continue the work with our
with our improvement leads but we are also increasingly excited to begin to sort of take
that what what is could be considered or somewhat feels like a silo system in our state system of
support and also look for those alignment opportunities within our larger statewide
system of support as well as we know again our students with disabilities are not separate and
siloed in in terms of their educational experience so all the sort of mechanisms and arms that we
have across the state should be operating in coordination and includes our self-improvement
leads and our content leads and so we're looking forward to you know taking some time out and
carving some time out in terms of discussion about how sort of this sort of subset or specialized
subset of of system of support it fits into the larger system you know for the for the benefit
of all students that's great uh i don't see any other hands raised for clarifying questions at
this moment so we will go to public comment and then we'll come back for discussion
all right we have several public commenters
hello caller please state your name and affiliation for the record you have one minute
your time begins now
good afternoon my name is cammy martin on behalf of the california county superintendent
educational services association in general we believe the new targets are attainable
set appropriate expectations and have captured much of the stakeholder feedback an area of concern
we raise in our letter is the new targets for indicator 5a while we believe ambitious targets
will encourage better placement and earlier intervention for students with disabilities
health percent growth over six years may be unattainable the cde may want to examine the
technical help to help provided to support lea's to improve policies and practices in this area
thank you for your important work on this item thank you caller
hello caller please state your name and affiliation for the record you have one minute
your time begins now
good afternoon my name is deborah schlegel i'm a parent um i want to thank director calamities for
the wonderful presentation uh of of the strategic plan um including
where we have been in the past i think that is very important when uh delivering this type of
information i just hope that going forward we can really concentrate on literacy for tk through
three and consider targeted grants to improve teacher education in that area and consider
aligning the data that we take in for ieps across all platforms including those needed
for the l cap information iep information i think alignment of those data
inputs would be very useful down to the lea level thank you thank you caller
that concludes our public comment for this item
um okay um so we're open for discussion both about the uh targets themselves and about the
um thinking that goes behind where we're going uh maybe i will kick us off with a few uh comments
and again kudos to heather for the presentation um you know my my favorite uh slide was your path
you know my my favorite uh slide was your path forward for special education funding and policy
that might get us to the targets i think that's so critically important i'm excited that we are
where we are and thinking systemically about this with so many elements of policy uh coming online
to help us you know really make a change in the in the outcomes for our students it was about five
or six years ago that when mike kerst was the chair of the state board and i was chairing the
commission on teacher credentialing that we joined forces to try to get resources for a special
education task force and some of you will remember that that task force really came out with a
set of proposals for how do we get to one system from what had been you know a dual very segregated
system um that was not making progress you know going forward and it began to identify
some of the needs and i think we're making progress every year on addressing more and more of those
needs so it is exciting to see it coming together and to have the targets presented with you know
something of a roadmap for how we could actually meet them i do want to flag as what our color
flagged as well the challenges of target five a which is the target to get more and more students
in mainstream classrooms we all want that to be accomplished in a way that supports
teachers in those classrooms with the knowledge skills and supports that they will need to serve
the kids well that supports the kids well with all of those um knowledge skills and supports and we
know that we have particular challenges in that area we also know that when children are
in mainstream settings without adequate support often some of the other dysfunctional consequences
happen including exclusion suspension expulsion and so on so i think that's the place where
we're going to have to dig in the most intensely on both ensuring that we end the teacher shortages
that have played this state for so long you know with two-thirds of people coming into specialist
positions being unprepared underprepared when they get there that means that kids have you know
teachers who want to help them and don't know how those teachers that also need to be able to help
the general ed teachers we're going to need a system in which we can authorize generalist
teachers and special ed teachers to work together in teaching teams where they can both work with
all the kids in the in the classroom with the knowledge bases that are needed there's credentialing
reform underway at the ctc to help us get there but we don't have programs yet in the state in
adequate numbers to train up all the people who will be needed to meet those those requirements
and to be knowledgeable that's the key thing the most important thing that a student in special
education needs is knowledgeable teaching everything else you know all the other things that get
talked about in terms of services and so on all rest on whether we have people who have that very
very extraordinary set of knowledge and skills and that we support those people we know that
getting and keeping those folks is going to depend on the right kind of preparation
right kind of support for them to be able to afford to be prepared the right kind of
credentialing programs the right kind of student loads and working conditions that allow them to
do their jobs well and it's also going to depend on the kind of training we can give to educators
around social emotional learning and restorative practices because students with disabilities
and african-american students followed by native american students are the
ones that are most often to be excluded and there's a big overlap in african-american
students and students with ieps in that circumstance so i just want to be sure that
we have a really strong full complete picture of what we will need to do to achieve those targets
in a way that really works for children so that they are well served in those classrooms
by educators who have the knowledge skills and supports to serve them well and i would
like to suggest that because so much of this is the interaction between cde's work in the field
and the credentialing commission's work are getting the preparation programs and authorizations
to line up that we might even want to consider inviting a joint presentation next time around
that component because it is going to be one of the most important and challenging
pieces of the work it's something we all want to lean into those goals and we want to lean into
them in the right way that really works for for children and for for the educators who want to
serve them and with that i will go to member rucker who has raised her hand and anyone else
who wants to join in the discussion thank you so much and first of all i do want to say thank you
to the department and the staff for this very comprehensive presentation i look forward to
seeing the overview on this particular report every year and i always learn more not only about
the challenge of providing appropriate support for special education programs to our district
but really understanding what the instructional challenges are to meet those to meet the targets
that are articulated here dr darling ham and thank you also for the suggestion about the joint
presentation with the commission because that was something i was going to suggest but i also think
that there's a need for us to talk about what is the level of the type of planning and the scope
and depth of planning that has to happen at the school level to address these targets
in my experience as a classroom teacher and working at a school campus discussion about
special education programs and planning for those programs was often separate and segregated from
planning for the jet for the general school program itself special education students are
general ed students first and how are they reflected in the planning that we are now tasking
school districts to do in the l cap regardless of whatever the form the l cap template takes
how is the needs of these students as reflected in the expectations of these targets also being
reflected in the l cap and i think that's also a worthy conversation to pursue because frankly
in the meetings i've gone to in several board meetings and at several sites where i've listened
in on their l cap discussions special education programs don't come up it's always a focus on the
general education and we don't pay attention to these students but those outcomes are not only
integral but they directly overlap on the accountability outcomes that are tied to the l cap as well
so thank you are there other folks who want to weigh in
this is an information item so we have been well informed and we really thank heather for that
we've made a couple of suggestions for looking towards potentially towards the next meeting and
towards our adoption of the of the targets and with that we are in a position to take a
10 minute break and we will be almost caught up with our timing so good work and we'll see you
in 10 minutes at three o'clock and continue from there remember to turn off your microphone and
your video but don't leave the room all right welcome back and thank you to all of my fellow
fellow board members for your stamina and your diligent participation with so few breaks i want
to move us to agenda item five which is a public hearing regarding an appeal from an action of the
riverside county committee on school district organization to approve a petition to transfer
territory from the kocheli valley unified school district to the desert sands unified school
district the cde recommends that the state board reverse the action of the county committee
to approve the proposal to transfer territory from the kocheli valley usd to the desert sands
usd and this item is presented by larry shirey of the cde larry please begin excuse me president
darl hampton i apologize but can we reestablish the quorum oh thank you please do all right uh
member son present vice president strauss present member rucker okay member rodriguez
yes
member patillo brownson present member mcquillin here number glover woods here number escapado
here president darlin hamd here number burr here number bonaka here we have a quorum all right
sorry larry thinking away larry no larry shirey school fiscal uh school facilities division
i'm here to present as uh president hamman darling hamman indicated uh the cde analysis
and recommendations regarding an appeal from uh uh an action of the riverside county committee
to transfer territory from kochela valley unified to desert sands unified i want to put
our recommendation up front we'll come back to this at the end but again we're as indicated
we're recommending that the state board reverse the actions of the riverside county committee
to approve the transfer although the transfer substantially meets all the standards in statute
we determined that there's no compelling reason to transfer the territory but we do find a
significant concern with with the uh with the issue the proposed transfer area is 124
single-family homes located in the northwest corner of the kochela valley school district
the petition began uh with uh or the proposal began with a petition signed by 25 of the voters
in that area again in that in that red shaded area uh i'm this is the rationale that was in
the petition provided by the petitioners i'm going to skip that slide in the interest of time
because i'm going to come back to that information in a moment and i want first to start with just
kind of a reminder of what is involved in approving a territory transfer it's a two-step
process there is a legal requirement to determine that the proposal substantially meets nine
minimum threshold standards that are in statute if those standards are substantially met then the
county committee and the state board has can take discretionary action to approve the transfer
the statute the education code does provide that the legislative intent that that reorganization
should be based on local educational needs and concerns and the courts have established that
simply meeting the minimum standards step one is not a compelling reason for approval
the riverside county committee took that first step determined that all minimum threshold
standards are substantially met however that they did not provide any information regarding
the merits of the proposal the you know the reason behind their discretionary action
other than it meets minimum thresholds you know we reviewed all the actions through minutes
and and audio tapes of the meetings and and it was our opinion it is our opinion that the
county committee granted approval solely on the basis of the proposal meeting the minimum threshold
standards coachella valley this is opposed to the transfer the desert sands unified school district
is neutral and retains that neutral stance here are the reasons for the appeal of coachella valley
again i'm going to skip over this because i'll come back to it in the next slide
those appeal issues are part of the minimum standards and i i mentioned there are nine the
coachella valley school district unified school district brought up four in their appeal the first
one is that the to transfer would have a negative effect on the district's ability
to educate students in an integrated environment the district position is that even though only
one student currently is affected right now with a district that has a 99 minority student enrollment
the loss of any non-minority student is substantial you know we disagree we believe that the removal
of one student is not going to have a substantial negative effect on either the district or any
school to ensure that it can educate students in an in an integrated environment
the district states that the loss of the assessed valuation of this transfer plus other transfers
that might be spurred by approval of this would increase state cost in terms of financial hardship
assistance when it comes to building schools or getting getting funds for renovating schools
we disagree again that we find that the loss of less than one percent of assessed valuation will
not increase state cost the district had planned at the time the proposal was considered locally
to build a school close to the transfer area to serve that that subdivision and also other
students in the surrounding areas and they felt that if this transfer is approved and other
transfers follow that would lead to relocation of that school and that would have a negative
effect on educational program currently there's no funding for that proposed new school
and and the project has been shelved so the appeal concern is really a non-issue at this point
and the district also claims that they believe that the petitioners
primarily brought forward the the proposal to increase their property values there was no
evidence of that during the local consideration and we found no evidence in in our so we don't
think that's an issue now moving on to the petitioners reasons again this was step one
that was just step one finding that all the minimum conditions are substantially met now we
move on to finding a reason to approve the proposal we look first at the petitioners reasons they
claim that the desert sands schools are closer to their area than our Coachella Valley schools
in reality the elementary and middle schools there's not a whole lot of difference so there's
not a significant difference in terms of the distance from the schools for the transfer area
in fact the elementary school in Coachella Valley is closer than the desert sands schools however
the high school the Coachella Valley high school is significantly farther away from the area than
are the two desert sands high schools that are that are closest to the area a difference about
eight miles to two or three miles however we also found that those two high schools are on the
opposite side of highway 111 which is the primary north south route through this Coachella Valley
and it's also a primary retail corridor for the area so there are safety concerns that
that kind of mitigate the proximity of the schools there is a misstatement in the in the item
we indicated in the item that the two middle schools in desert sands also were on the opposite
side of the of the freeway the highway but actually only one of the middle schools are
on the opposite side along with the with the two high schools at the time the proposal was
considered locally no area student ever had attended the Coachella Valley Unified School
District that's not true now there are a few students that are have attended and currently
attend Coachella Valley but regardless we don't see that as a compelling reason to change school
district boundaries the petitioners also state that desert sands has higher test scores in
Coachella Valley and they want their students in those schools with the higher test scores
though true it's still not a compelling reason to arrange school district boundaries in our opinion
so we don't find any compelling reasons and what the petitioners offer us to recommend approval
we also note as I indicated before that the county committee provided no reason for its actions other
than that the transfer proposal meets minimum threshold standards but we do have a concern that
approval of the transfer will set a precedent for future transfers out of Coachella Valley into
desert sands there's been a history of those transfers and there's also been hysterical
hysterical historical statewide concern that such attempts would continue
1985 the Riverside County Committee approved the transfer this was undeveloped land
that has since been developed into an upscale resort area
india springs in 1995 there was another transfer proposal that was approved
by the Riverside County Committee in this case the Coachella Valley Unified District
did appeal to the state board there was some interesting there was an interesting situation
at that time because Coachella Valley had a emergency state loan and the state superintendent
had taken over control of the district from the state board so it actually the department could
not analyze and make a recommendation because of its relationship with the district to the state
board so the state board's executive director actually analyzed the proposal and made a
recommendation that the state board reversed the county county committee's decision the department
did go on record with concerns about the transfer and the state board eventually unanimously reversed
the county committee's approval
1998 there was another one that contained all the error that was in the 94 petition in this case the
county committee did disapprove it and there was no subsequent appeal about that time the legislature
became concerned that these attempts to pull territory and assess valuation and students out
of Coachella Valley would have would have a negative effect on that district in terms of
it trying to get out from under the the financial concerns that prompted it to get an emergency loan
so it notified it it listed a number of conditions that if met a territory a territory could not be
transferred out of a district unless the governing board approved it
that moratorium stayed in effect for 10 years after the district repaid its loan so that was
about 2012 so in summary we find that the territory transfer proposal substantially meets all nine
minimum threshold standards we find no compelling reason to transfer the territory as i indicated
before the petitioner's reason for the transfers are in our opinion not compelling local
educational needs or concerns and again the riverside county committee didn't help us here
and and we also find a reason to disapprove the transfer in other words uphold the appeal of the
Coachella Valley Unified School District because it would establish a precedent for future efforts
transfer territory from from that district again our recommendation is that based on our findings
we recommend that the state board reverse the actions of the Riverside County Committee
approving a territory transfer from the Coachella Valley Unified School District to the Desert Sands
Unified School District I can take any clarifying questions now and I certainly
will be here after the public hearing that that will follow
I don't see any hands being raised for clarifying questions at this time so I will hereby open the
public hearing at 3 15 p.m and first we will hear from the petitioners in favor of the territory
transfer then we'll hear from the Coachella Valley USD in opposition to the transfer and each side
will have 12 minutes after each side makes their presentations we'll then open up the phone lines
for public comment from members of the public who are not part of the presentation each speaker will
have one minute for their public comment so the petitioners in favor of the territory transfer
you may begin good afternoon honorable president and members of the board Coachella Valley Unified
School District and members of the public my name is Makayla Wilkie and I'm here today as a parent
that resides in the Bridget Jefferson community and are asking for the approved district boundaries
to be honored for our community to be in Desert Sands Unified School District the first thing I
would like to point out is that the state's educational code has been met in approval of
the district boundaries all nine conditions were passed unanimously by the Riverside County Board
of Education in June of 2016 report by a third party place works district boundaries were established
in 1964 before population growth and community developments took over our development of 124
homes was not completed until 2013 and the petition was signed by 107 registered voters
in the community in 2015 this process has been taking place since 2015 with no other community
coming forward trying to establish new boundaries so I asked the question if the claim has been made
that this would open more district rezoning wouldn't that have taken place when we were
approved back in 2016 it has been five years and no other applications this leads me to my next
point Coachella Valley Unified School District promised a new school closer to our development
we know that proposed land has been leased for profit during the Coachella Valley music and stage
coach festivals the festivals just signed a 20-year deal with the city of indio and do you really
think a new school is going to be built at this site that was promised six years ago with much of
the surrounding communities having far more vacation rentals than families who live in them
I don't think so the 1994 district transfer request was never approved by the county
it is a mute point it was asked for by a developer and contained a long stretch of corridor on avenue
48 this is not brought forth by the voters or the people who reside in these communities
the community encourages the board for the betterment of our children to transfer the
territory to better balance student populations and accommodate growth in the future with minimal
disruptions to our families according to a document obtained by the city of Coachella
general plan update from February of 2012 Coachella Valley Unified School District had a
total of 13 schools exceeding capacity by a total of 1562 students and this number has continued to
increase along with their enrollment totals through the last few years also contained in
this document is a section called out for desert desert sands unified stating the schools serving
the planning area meaning closest to our community had a total enrollment of 3252 students with a
capacity for 412 presently none of these schools exceed capacity in their space for 858 new students
currently the schools we are zoned for in the Bridget Jefferson are all over capacity some by
as much as four to six hundred students this was extremely evident when we went to one of our
hearings and we're sitting at the elementary school and there are modulars out on the playground
where kids are supposed to play so I ask you would you want your child going someplace where there's
modulars and not enough room for them to even have outdoor activity in 2015 there were 15 new
residential developments that are within the Coachella Valley Unified School District borders
that have come to completion or are close to completion furthermore increasing the growth
and the overcrowding in the Coachella Valley Unified School District there is also potential
for more growth as there is much more open space yet to be developed in Coachella Valley Unified
School District this is not the case in Desert Sands Unified with these new developments and
the funding fees for local schools in the Coachella Valley Unified School District our community
does not feel that transferring our territory would be any sort of financial hardship for the
Coachella Valley Unified School District the Bridget Jefferson is the furthest most community
of the Coachella Valley Unified School District distances to the schools in the Coachella Valley
Unified greatly restricts student involvement in extracurricular activities in essence by
honoring the district transfer you are disenfranchising our children in our community
as quoted in an article from the Desert Sun from June 21st of 2015 from the director of technology
from Coachella Valley Unified School District some of these students spend nearly four hours on a bus
each day these are our children as they are the furthest away attending Desert Sands Unified
School District our children are able to walk and ride bikes home this also helps with global
warming and taking care of our environment the big point here is 90 percent of Indio is located
in the Desert Sands Unified School District it makes sense that our community should be able to
identify with the city that they live in and attend the schools that 90 percent of the city
attend the community members that support our city we want to be able to identify and attend
public schools in the community for which we have the closest ties currently my husband is a coach
at Indio High School in Desert Sands Unified and I volunteer at Desert Sands Unified this is due in
part because Indio is where we live it is the community to which we identify with keeping
children away from where they live and where parents commute to and from work is a detriment
not only to the children but to our district this is the norm in our community we are not only the
community members who have the same route to and from work but we are the ones who give back to the
community in which we reside safety is another major concern of the community when we discuss
transportation and safe walking distances to and from school there is no safe walking route
for the community to use in Coachella Valley Unified School District as the schools are just
too far away from our community Coachella Valley Unified School District prepared a document back
in 2011 of May for the board meeting to discuss why change needed to happen in school boundaries
their main concerns were to relieve student overcrowding live within walking distance
enforce walking walking distance policies and reduce transportation costs
by honoring our community to transfer territory you are providing Coachella Valley Unified School
Districts with the changes that they have been asking for in regards to fiscal solvency and
providing our community with a positive and safe environment the schools that we our community
would attend in Desert Sands Unified are all within safe walking distance and provided lighted
sidewalks and safe routes for our children to bike and walk as a parent we want what is best
for our children honoring the boundary transfer is not only what is best for our children but we
feel is best for both districts involved the evidence has been presented as to why honoring
approved district transfers is beneficial for all the bridge at Jefferson community is asking to be
the standard not the exception the community is asking for consistency and community identity
we want to thank you for this time for your time this afternoon at the bridge
and everybody at the community watching we recognize how difficult this process is and
we hope that we can offer stability going forward we know that this is that the board's
responsibility is to make sure quality education is available and we do appreciate you taking that
time I'll now turn it over to again Glenn Cavalero for some additional comments thank you
you're muted
there we go is that better yes okay um thank you all very much for allowing us the time to
state our case here and especially me I'm just I'm a resident of the bridge of Jefferson I've
been here for 13 years um I did not have I'm retired and I did not have any children that
attend the schools and that was one of the points that was made was that with such a low number of
students uh that were in the district that were looking to transfer um why were there so many
people that signed the petition and that had to be that the primary concern really was to increase
our property values which is totally untrue the bridge of Jefferson is a little bit different than
the bridge of Jefferson is a little bit different than a lot of communities
I think almost everybody here knows everybody else everyone's out walking in the evening and
sees each other and if there's a community concern everyone is going to jump on board
you just don't have to have children to see that as a need for the community and if it's good for
the community is good for us I want to make a couple of comments also in what was presented
earlier about highway 111 um how 111 is an east and west corridor it's really just called highway
111 as it was never given a name if you look at highway 74 that's monterey avenue that runs
through palm desert and up into the mountains it's really no different than Jefferson street which
is where the street we live on highway 111 is three lanes in each direction running east and west
Jefferson is six lanes three lanes in either direction running north and south
crossing highway 111 is just a daily fact and a matter of everyone that lives in the area so that
being a safety issue is really not a safety issue at all and I guess you'd really have to just come
down and take a look at it to see that it's not unlike any other intersection anywhere and again
from the bridge at Jefferson you know I attend all the Friday night football games at Lakita high
school and I walk there doesn't take very long so that's basically it there's one one other thing
that was brought up and it's kind of a touchy situation and I don't even like to bring it up
it's just that there's the comments that are put into the presentation that was put out about this
encouraging white flight and when I hear the term white flight that kind of brings the racial
overtones into it which is really a shame yeah I'm a second generation Mexican American whose family
came to the United States from Monterey Mexico and I am that that that type of thing never enters my
mind no matter what the situation is and I hate when that when it comes down to in some cases
desperation on the on on one side or the other that that has to be brought up into it because
that really really does need to stay out of this 100 percent the only thing we're looking for here
is for our children that live in the neighborhood to be able to go to a school that they identify
with and if you think about why they identify with this because if you go out from my house
go two tenths of a mile to Jefferson street and look across that's the Coachella that's the desert
sand unified school district that's where our our children's friends live so they should be able to
go to school where their friends go to school and sir I'm sorry your time is up thank you
I think we want to move at this point to the Coachella Valley USD representatives
Yes, thank you. Good afternoon President Darling-Hammond and members of the State Board of Education.
My name is Luis Valentino and I am the Superintendent of the Coachella Valley Unified School District.
We are here today to request that you support the appeal from the action by the Riverside County
Committee on School District Organization to approve a transfer of territory from the Coachella
Valley Unified School District to the Coachella Valley Unified School District.
As you have heard of the California Department of Education's recommendation that the State Board
of Education reverse the action by the Riverside County Committee after finding no compelling reason
to transfer the subdivision. We hope the additional comments shared with you today by our leaders
including our Board President Mr. Acuna and our Council Mr. Barankowicz and others speaking
through public comment as well as the comments submitted to the State Board of Education.
As well as the comments submitted to you via email earlier will demonstrate the importance
of your decision in concluding that it is critical to protect the existing territory
and keep our school district whole. And with that I would ask Mr. Barankowicz to
address the board. Yes and I will go ahead and share my screen with you and
again again you just heard from Dr. Valentino our Superintendent and Unlico Council for the
District and then last up will be Joey Acuna who is the Board President. Again we so we support
Coachella Valley USD or Coachella Valley USD supports the CDE recommendation but we also
wanted to discuss why we believe that conditions four nine five and eight are not substantially
met. First a little bit different depiction of the bridge territory it contains 37 acres and
124 parcels as you can see here the aerial on the right and the parcel layout on the left.
This development is gated it's well appointed and very high end. This is a picture of its entrance
into into this gated community. Here is another picture of the bridge showing
a pocket park of the bridge that again is gated and very well appointed. Contrast these
with pictures of with a picture of what's a typical subdivision in Coachella Valley
has. They've got very meager homes people are working class and there's nothing like that
in in the bridge and it's true that the areas adjacent to the bridge are similar to them but
they are not representative of the Coachella Valley as a whole. Coachella Valley as a whole
is it's got much more meager housing subdivisions.
Here is the boundaries of the Coachella Valley district as you can see here in the
dark outline you can see the Indian palms cut out here on the left hand side or the
west hand side of the property or the boundaries and then off to the west a little bit is the
is the the bridge portion.
What we do agree with with CDE is that there is no compelling reason for the transfer
and there's no rationale provided and none was addressed by the county committee. The although
Desert Sands has has higher test scores than Coachella Valley this is due in large part is
found by CDE that there's a higher population of of English language learners in Coachella Valley
than there is in in Desert Sands but what's really key and important that was I think missed out of
CDE's presentation is that that that was found that both districts have sound educational programs
between the between both districts both Desert Sands and Coachella Valley.
The precedent for future harmful petitions CDE notes that there were three different attempts
prior to the transfer these were in 85 which was the Indian palms transfer that did happen
and then the 1994 and the 1998 ones that were rejected and and all all of these areas except
the the the first one went through and the other two got rejected but the other two that were
rejected also included the bridge territory at the time and what's important is staff CDE
recognizes and acknowledges that there are racial ethnic and socio-economic
disparities between the districts. This was so evident that as mentioned by CDE the legislator
acknowledged that the harm to Coachella Valley from potential transfers that it actually had to
adopt education code 35706.5 which at the time was senate bill 997 which had the 10-year moratorium
to free Coachella Valley's USD boundaries to allow an acceptable bond program to to move forward with.
What must be high what must be highlighted is that CDE also applying that this transfer goes through
others will follow and could exacerbate the already existing racial and ethnic
and socio-economic disparities between the districts and would have substantial negative
effects on Coachella Valley USD. So with that where we reach disagreement with the
CDE is that we believe that conditions four nine five and eight are not met
and we bring them in the order of importance and condition four talks about preserving an
integrated environment and will not promote racial or ethnic discrimination or segregation.
Based on CDE's opinion above that the future potential transfers will exacerbate racial
ethnic and socio-economic disparities this condition cannot be substantially met.
This is demonstrated by looking at the extreme high minority
extreme high minority rates within Coachella Valley as opposed to
desert sands you can see that Coachella Valley is 99 over 99 minority less than one percent white
yet desert sands USD is only you know not not as quite it has 18 white population
and then the rest minority so far less integrated it has a far more integrated
environment in desert sands than that's certainly in Coachella Valley. Also here is the
the slide showing the the schools the the amount of the percentages of minorities from Coachella
Valley at district serving schools versus what would serve at desert sands again still very high
and and tracking what what I just mentioned earlier is very high minority rates in Coachella
Valley as opposed to desert sands and what's important about this
is that we're talking about Coachella Valley only has in its enrollment 177 white students out of
its 18,000 in enrollment whereas desert sands has 5,788 white students the bridge area has an
enrollment of 17 and 15 of them are are white now that means that the 15 white students that amounts
to eight percent of the total white population of Coachella Valley that gets transferred as a
result of this and if you just look at the number of students that are now attending desert sands
which is seven students that's four percent of Coachella Valley's white students that is
a substantial amount of white students percentage wise that are being transferred out would be
transferred out of Coachella Valley to desert sands and such a large portion of white students
transferring does not serve an integrated environment but it does promote racial and
ethnic segregation and discrimination even CDE's regulation on condition four talks in terms of
future impacts under title five CCR section 18573a4 it says to determine whether new districts
will promote racial or ethnic discrimination or segregation the effects of the following factors
will be considered and b it states that the trend and rates of present and possible future growth
or change in the total population and the districts affected in each racial and ethnic group within the
total district and in each school and the affected areas so this is talking about terms of of future
potential transfers so with that there cannot be that condition four cannot be met because of these
potential future transfers and the wide disparities between the districts
also condition nine is not met because you can see based on the assessed values that desert sands
has over almost four percent more or 400 percent more assessed value over over Coachella Valley
Valley also we have declining enrollment which further exacerbates the the fiscal impact of the
district and then the increased cost of the state the CDE we did not see them look at the potential
costs of desert sands having to house 80 students from the bridge also this is is primarily designed
to increase property values as you can see by just looking at the inferential information from
it that only 17 students are from the bridge seven are attending desert sands yet more than
25 percent of bridge residents signed the petition i'm now turning this over to our board president
Joey Acuna
go ahead Joey
am i on now yes yes good afternoon chair and members of the board my name is Joey Acuna i'm
the current president Coachella Valley Unified School District
i gotta tell you this has been happening since 1985 30 plus years now that initial
board i don't think understood that they could stand up and fight this is my personally my third
one i am more than willing to stand up and fight for our districts from these attacks and please
these are attacks these are not requests these are attacks and they've been going on for 30
years now and i say enough is enough additionally i was going to say something else but in lieu of
what they said you know they came up and said look this is just about us wanting to be in our
community in the city of indio you know we want our kids to go to community schools the problem
is that last year seven of their middle and high school students that transferred did not go to
indio high school or indio middle school they went to la quinta high school and john glenn twice as
far as the current community schools this isn't about yes you only have 10 seconds remaining if
you'd like to wrap up so again we can go on and on i want to thank the board for their time we
requested to uphold the request for the the staff's the staff's decision to
accept our appeal and deny their request thank you very much all right thank you very much
at this point we will have the phone line open for public comment so we need to have the
public comment card there we go members of the public who are not part of either presentation
wishing to provide comment on this public hearing may do so by calling the telephone number and
using the access code provided on the slide that is being shown members of the public we do encourage
you to please state your name and affiliation for the record please remember to turn down the speaker
volume of your computers if you are following the live feed and speakers will be limited
to one minute each and we also ask as always that callers be respectful comments at this time must
be related to the item before the board and that is item number five are there any public comments
yes we have several all right hello caller please state your name and affiliation for the record
you have one minute your time begins now
good afternoon my name is I am council member and then mayor for the city of indio
I've lived in indio for 60 years and have lived in this district that is shared by both cattela
valley unified and desert sand unified district for the past 20 years I represent district five
of the city of indio which is two-thirds located in cattela valley unified and one-third located
in desert sand unified school district we're here today to talk about the local needs and education
of our students not to talk about race not to talk about property values but what is in the best
interest of our children back in the late 1980s this area was not a part of indio so back in 1964
when the boundaries were drawn this was in the sphere of cattela so the area that is now
part of cattela valley unified sister but sits in the city of indio is all one community I have
the demographic follow your time is up thank you hello caller please state your name and affiliation
for the record you have one minute your time begins now
hello caller please state your name and affiliation for the record
you have one minute your time begins now
we have no more callers
okay um that's it for public comment given that there's no other public comment
I hereby close the public hearing at 3 43 p.m. and we will now begin with board discussion and
I'd first like to ask member sue burr if she would like to make some initial comments
uh thank you president darlin cam and um as those of you who have been on the board a long time
these are never easy discussions particularly when there are strong feelings from local
communities about their school children I will have to say I you know I spent a lot of time with
larry shirey and as usual the department has done I think a really thorough job of reviewing
all of the components and the statutory requirements relative to
a territory transfer and I think in this case they've come to the correct conclusion
that the action of the county committee which we normally will affirm because they have the best
finger on the pulse in the community but in this case the county community or I'm sorry the county
committee for riverside county um really didn't find a compelling reason to approve the transfer
and the department is recommending that we reverse the action of the county committee
um and based on my review and discussion with larry and cde staff I would concur with that
so I will if board members have other questions and of course comments we I'd like to hear from
those but I'm prepared to support the department's recommendation thank you so much and we do have
some comments from vice president Strauss member rucker and member son so vice president Strauss
please carry us forward thank you so I just want to thank the presentation I have a couple of
questions so larry if you're available I have two different questions I want to clarify I kind of
know this area and um my question is first do we know the number of students who live in the
bridget jefferson area and where they currently attend school that's my first question yes there
have been I think they're over the past five or six years the numbers have ranged from I don't
have the report in front of me between 17 and 18 and I think that's the number of students who
I don't have the report in front of me between 17 and 7 um uh one or two attend
five years ago they all were granted inter-district transfers uh to if they if they requested them to
attend desert sands or some other school district uh the the Coachella Valley school district when
they realized they were were losing more of than of their non-minority students that they
thought was good for the educational program they cut down on inter-district transfers that
they that they were approving so as of right now we do have I think there's one student
who is from the area who is attending Coachella Valley and I believe the number who are attending
desert sands at the last number we had was seven for the 1920 school year 18 19 it was 10
and for 17 18 it was 16 thank you so my second question is and I don't know if you have this on
a map but based on where the Bridget Jefferson is I'm interested in on where the Coachella Valley
schools are that students would attend and where the schools for desert sands are because what I
heard was Coachella was going to build a school but then there are no funds that are not going to
and um and I hear about the distance of getting to school and what I heard at least in
the petitioners was that the kids are much closer to desert sands but then I heard Coachella saying
no I understand the difference in the communities just my question is the location of the school
students would attend from this area where they are in Coachella Valley and where they are in
desert sands location wise Coachella Valley schools are are all located south and east
of the community the desert sands schools are for the most part located north of the community
you know the the distances are you know I could go through the distances I believe I have that here
if you want to do the specific distances or isn't a really a substantial difference
in the elementary and middle school in terms of the the the how far away they are from
from the proposed transfer area but there is a significant difference between the high schools
the Coachella Valley high school is eight miles southeast both both the desert sands or sorry both
the Indio and La Quinta high schools are are between two and three miles north of the of the
proposed transfer area and are you saying that the elementary and middle are similar in distance
right the elementary actually the Coachella Valley elementary school is closer
but and but in terms of the numbers the distance for elementary is in Coachella Valley is 2.2 miles
versus 2.3 miles in desert sands very similar but slightly closer in Coachella Valley the
middle schools for Coachella Valley is four and a half miles and the two two desert sands
middle schools are two and three miles thank you
that takes care of those uh I have member Rucker member Sun member Rucker you're next
um Larry I just wanted to get a clarification on exactly what would be the result of what is being
recommended so the county found no compelling reason to approve the request and your recommendation
is that we reverse the decision of the county so what would be the outcome from taking that action
I want to make sure I'm clear on that I just want to clarify your comment uh it's not that
excuse me it's not that the county committee did not find a compelling reason um again there's a
two-step process look at the nine required minimum threshold standards and statute if those are
substantially met then the county committee could have taken the discretionary action to approve
uh as I stated the legislature said that should be based on local educational needs and concerns
it's not that they didn't find actively they did not consider any reasons or any they did not take
that second step at all which led to us not having any information from the county committee
regarding why they took the action they did other than it seemed very clear to us
that uh they took the they they assumed they approved the territory transfer because they
found the nine conditions substantially met in terms of what's this yeah yeah please go ahead
so in terms of what happens if if the uh if the uh appeal is disapproved the state
board allows the transfer to take place because Coachella Valley um is opposed to it it'll be
required to go to a local election if you allow the transfer to go forward then we'll have to
take another step which is to set the election area for the for this proposal if so just wait
just be clear I think I think the question is if we approve the CDE recommendation
then the territory will stay in Coachella Valley where it is now and the children will continue
to go to school in Coachella Valley USA that's correct there'll be no change in that's what I
was trying to get clear yeah that's thank you Dr thank you Dr Darling-Hammond you're welcome
Member Sun yes so uh all right so for the county committee are they required by law to
do that second step to find the compelling reason there's no requirement to find a compelling
reason in statute or in regulation what we have is the intent of the legislature which states that
uh any reorganization needs to be based on educational needs and concerns there is also
the excuse me I'm suffering from allergies right now um the courts have told us that uh you know
just meeting these nine minimum standards is not a reason that compels approval
and the our interpretation of that has been twofold one is that the courts have established a legal
standard um and the second thing is that you know this is just in line with with what boards do
on on a regular basis in terms of taking discretionary action you need to find make a
value judgment on the uh on the proposal on the petitioner's reason for the process for the
proposal if they don't if those reasons do not compel you to vote for them then then uh it
should you shouldn't be voting to approve the territory transfer okay and then in the comments
um between the two the two groups the Coachella Valley is saying that by the transfer they would
lose a large percentage of their white students um is but then in the CDE presentation you said
that there was really just one student so you didn't feel that that was a compelling that was
not a well we look at this uh threshold we look only at the merits of the uh at the individual
transfer in the circumstances there currently though there may be 17 students uh in the area
and only one uh attends Coachella Valley uh the transfer is only going to result in the loss of
that one student it's not going to result uh for our purposes in the loss of all 17 students
because those students are gone not part of the district as it is so we look at the direct effect
of the territory transfer which in this case is one student and we don't see that as a as a
substantial or a significant negative effect on the ability of the district or any school in the
district to provide an integrated educational environment okay very good so the the reason that
the CDE's um recommendation to uh to prove the appeal and overturn the county committee is based
on one that the county even though they were not required to should have um done the compelling
reason and then the second is there's been some history sort of uh our our rationale is twofold
is that we didn't find any compelling reason to uh to recommend that the transfer be approved
you know we when we do these things we typically look to what the county uh circumstances are with
the county's issues are and they didn't take that action so they didn't provide us anything to help
us in our determination and then secondly of course so is the issue that we're concerned that
this would be a precedent setting effect a setting event you know we've seen it in similar
circumstances across the state uh these things i should i should add it's not within a very short
time frame these issues go on for decades yes you know i like to point to the ravenswood school
district in san matteo county when territory transfers out of that district uh started again
about the same time frame in 1985 and they just and they're continuing to this day efforts to
transfer territory out i understand i it's just it is a little bit on this one for us to overturn
a local decision um i'm not sure i'm finding a really really strong reason so i have to kind of
think a little bit more on this okay yeah we we get great weight to to the local decision it's
just that we really didn't have anything here so we needed to go with our uh with what we thought
the issue was and that that's where that question of compelling rationale comes in it was hard to
know why they made the decision because they didn't state a rationale um i'm going to go to vice
president strouse and then i'm going to ask member rucker is your hand up on purpose or did you forget
to take it down i forgot to take it down i am sorry so vice president strouse thank you so
there's one student currently in this area who goes to coachella valley the other students who
live in there do not attend they attend desert sands on a permit so my first question is
if if we if the board supports the cd recommendation the students then
will can can continue their attendance pattern and in fact continue to attend the schools they
currently attend is that correct that's that's up to the coachella valley school district in terms
of its approval of interdistrict transfer uh request and extensions of current uh you know
my assumption is and perhaps if the district could provide more information is that since
we do have continuing students on interdistrict transfers that they are grandfathering in
the previously approved transfers but as with any school district the school
district has the authority to deny or approve a interdistrict transfer request
my second question is if the board was to support the riverside county decision the local decision
and not support the cd recommendation over turnin what would be the next steps
next step is that we would have to ask you to determine who's going to vote on the issue
since coachella valley is opposed that requires an election to finalize transfer of the territory
so if the board votes to uphold the riverside county decision we will need we would need to
then to move into a a recommend or not a recommendation but an establishment of
election area by the board we recommend that because there are really this territory transfer
itself has no direct effects that the election area would just be the the territory proposed
for transfer should the should the board decide to go with the riverside county approval thank you
uh are there any other questions comments any further discussion from members of the board
before we solicit a motion member burr you look like you're
gearing up to say something no well i'm ready to make a motion if you're ready for that i just
don't want to shut down discussion okay now i think i think this is a good time for a motion
okay um so i am i also going to point folks to page three of the item because i think
this one is a little bit confusing not completely consistent with the way we are usually we usually
hear these recommendations and act on them i think uh remember ruckers nodding her head because it
did cause some confusion but the finding and recommendations i think are very clearly articulated
here that the cd is making this recommendation or that we should consider that although all
minimum threshold standards are met there is no compelling reason to transfer the bridge at just
jefferson subdivision and further and this is what i think is important the cd finds that the
approval of the transfer could promote future transfers from cochella valley based on previous
efforts as larry articulated and i think we heard from cochella valley the lack of alignment
among city and school district boundaries in the area which as we know exists throughout the state
districts are not concurrent with cities and and this is the most compelling thing to me
the racial ethnic and socioeconomic disparities between the cochella valley
um school district and desert sands um so for those reasons i would move approval of the
department's recommendation that the board the state board reverse the action of the county
committee to approve the proposal to transfer territory thank you do i have a second
i'll second it thank you very much uh any further discussion all right i think we'll do a roll call
vote so brooks can you please call the roll member son member son uh yeah i i will say
i will go i vice president strouse abstain member rucker yes member rodriguez yes member
patillo brownson yes member mcquillin yes member glover woods yes member escobedo
yes president darlene hammond yes member burr aye member bonanca
aye the motion passes all right thank you very much uh and you have earned another
10-minute break uh we are almost through the major items when we come back we'll be dealing
with the consent calendar uh and our consent agenda and our state board priorities so we'll
see you back why don't we give ourselves until 4 15 see you then turn off your camera and your
microphone but do not leave the room
i think we need brooks to reestablish the quorum and call the roll
member son present vice president strouse member rucker i am here member rodriguez here member
patillo brownson here member mcquillin here member glover woods here member escobedo
yes president darlene hammond i am here member burr here member bonanca here everyone's presence
all right i want to be uh i don't know what pat did over the break that made her so enthusiastic
i want some of that i've got my green tea latte so
so all right folks we're going to get into public comment now on our waiver consent calendar
the phone line will be open for public comment members of the public wishing to provide comment
on this item may do so by calling the telephone number and using the access code provided on the
slide that is shown now and so we're ready for that are there any public comments on waiver items
w1 through w15 we encourage you to state your name and affiliation for the record
and the waiver item and district name to which you are speaking please remember to turn down
your speaker volume on your computer if you're following the live feed and the speakers will
be limited to one minute each there are no people on the line for public comment at this point
all right given that there is no public comment i'll now ask for a motion on waivers w1 through
w15 i would move approval of the consent calendar for waivers thank you i second thank you very much
we'll now hold a roll call vote brooks please call the roll member son
yes yes member rucker yes member rodriguez
member rudriguez oh i thought i said yes i'm sorry i must have been muted yes
yes member patila bronfen yes member mcQuillan
yes member glover woods yes member escapado yes president darlin hammond yes number burr
aye member bananca aye motion passes unanimously
okay now we're going to take up the regular consent items which are items six through nine
we'll open the phone line again for the queue for public comment on consent items six through nine.
Members of the public wishing to provide comment on this item may do so by calling the telephone
number and using the access code provided on the slide that is being shown. Are there any public
comments on regular consent items six through nine? There are not. All right. Given that there's no
public comment, I'll ask for a motion on consent items six through nine. I'll move the consent items.
Thank you. Is there a second? I'll second. Thank you very much. We'll now hold a roll call vote.
Brooks, please call the roll. Member Sun. Aye. Vice President Strauss. Yes. Member Rucker. Yes.
Member Rodriguez. Yes. Member Petillo-Brownson. Yes. Member McQuillan. Yes. Member Glover-Woods.
Yes. Member Escobedo. Yes. President Darlene Hammond. Yes. Member Burr. Aye. Member Bonacca.
Aye. All right. We're now going to move to agenda item one, which is our state board priorities item.
We're reopening item one to take action on the preliminary report of the actions
draft July 2021 meeting minutes and to report on our liaison assignments.
So while we're waiting for any members of the public to call in, and once again we need that
public comment slide up there. Terrific. Do I have a motion from a board member to approve
the July 2021 State Board of Education draft preliminary report of action and meeting minutes?
I'll move to approve that. Thank you. Is there a second?
A second. Thank you very much. Are there any public comments?
There are no public comments. I know we're doing a little wait time. Okay. There are no public comments.
Any further discussion?
Okay. Board members, would you please raise your hand in the participant panel of the Zoom
and Brooks will keep track of the raised hands. Oh, that's if there's discussion.
It's like, what is that about? We'll now hold our usual roll call vote. Brooks, please call the roll.
Yeah. And just for the record, I will do a roll call of those members who were present for that
meeting. Member Burr. Thank you.
Did you call my name, Brooks?
I abstained. I was not at that meeting. Thank you. President Darling-Hammond.
Yes. Member Glover-Wood.
Yes. Member McQuillan.
Yes. Member Petillo-Brownson.
Yes. And I appreciate that you gave member Burr a trick question.
I appreciate the appreciation. Member Rodriguez.
Yes. Member Rucker.
Yes. Vice President Strauss.
Yes. Member Son.
Yes. Motion passes.
Okay. So we're going to invite state board members to report on any liaison activities
that are not related to any items on our agenda. Let us begin by calling on board members
based on we're going to go back to reverse order and start with member Son.
Hi. Yeah. So the California Workforce Joint Advisory Committee is meeting.
Sorry. When I'm first, I don't have all my information together yet. Okay. On the 29th
of September, where we will continue working on our the CTE plan for California. It's been quite
a few years in the making, but I think we are starting to really get some momentum on that.
I just wanted to note, too, that we have two grant application deadlines out there right now for
CTE. The Strong Workforce K-12 program is the application went out on August 16th
and is due by August 15th by 5 p.m. The CTIG program, there was a modification in
the requirements for that program. So CTE had submitted or had released an RFA.
That has been modified a bit. And so there will be out the week of September 20th. So
I think next week sometime. And it will have a quick turnaround. So those who have already
started applying will be notified. But just wanted to note that that application has been modified a
bit. And there will be that the next due date will be October 15th. And I think that was all I
had. There's a number of charter didn't have really any charter items in this on this meeting,
but there are a number of charter issues and that we're having conversations that we're having with
especially with regards to non-site based and independent study of laws and how that applies
and works with charter schools. And I think that is all I have. All right. Vice President Strauss.
So I'll just follow up. I have a couple things to talk about and thank President Darling-Hammond
for reminding people at the beginning of the meeting that we are recruiting for a bunch of
our commissions for the Instructional Quality Commission, for the Advisory Commission on
Charter Schools and the California Practitioners Advisory Group. We are looking for a lot of
different people and then for the student board member as well as the student member of IQC.
So please, if you know people who would really help and serve, have a strong voice that would
help us and inform and advise the board. I just encourage you to reach out. The applications are
due later this month. The screening committee already has the dates for screening and interviews
and we plan to bring our recommendations to the board at the November board meeting. Also,
IQC had a actually pretty quick public hearing on the World Languages and Arts Education
Instructional Materials Adoptions. A couple of my colleagues, Member Glover Woods and Member
Rucker also heard that, so we might be able to make a few comments on that. The Advisory Commission
on Special Education, you know, our item today talked about the need for inclusive practices
and the Advisory Commission recognized the Orange County Special Ed Preschool Program
for an incredible model of inclusive practices. So I just think it's wonderful to see these great
programs that are actually implementing what our vision is for student engagement and inclusive
practices and improving for all. They're really sharing. They had a wonderful early childhood
program. I just wanted to acknowledge that as well. There was the state budget update which you
heard Director Calamese list all the money that's being invested in special education.
The State Superintendent Thurmond was present at AXE and did engage with the members on a variety
of issues. It was very, very helpful and I think much appreciated. So there's two different reports.
One, the Special Education Funding and Governance Report update which CDE had contact with the West
Ed to look at improvements to ensure transparency. There's a lot of systemic work that's necessary.
They talked a lot about inclusive vision and communication. Some key takeaways
on the need for longevity of teachers and instructional staff and administrators,
which those of us who try to lead improvement in schools know that that's really important.
There's a report. That report will go to the legislature in November and really had some
focus on aligning the roles of self as in county offices and reducing redundancy. So I'm sure we'll
hear more after that goes to legislature. A second report was on the IEP and alternative
diploma work group update. That report is actually going to the legislature in October.
They had a number of recommendations on ways to improve the IEP process, the template,
training. So we'll hear a lot more about that. But again, this work group did a lot of work.
If you're interested, you can go to the AXE link and watch that meeting. I think you'll find it
very, very helpful. And then the last comment was that NASB, which is the National Association
of State School Boards, which many of us were part of, has office hours. And actually they had
an input session on September 2nd of which there was a guidance for how to use ESSER funds. And
there was some highlights of LPI's work, which I thought was actually quite helpful. I wanted to
comment that because as people think about how to use these funds, I think the guidance is quite
helpful. And so I did want to share that as well. And they talked a lot about how state boards of
education can help school districts in the year going forward. So I think that that was really
quite helpful. So that ends my report. Thank you. Terrific. Thank you. Member Rucker.
I want to thank Board Member Sun for her report about the California Workforce Pathways Joint
Advisory Committee. And I also want to thank Member Strauss for her report about the IQC.
I'm just going to report about the Military Interstate Children's Compact. While the board
was meeting today, a component project of that collaboration was also having a meeting.
And this is a picture of me being in two places at once. I think that's the reason why
I suddenly felt energetic right after our break, Dr. Darlena. Today's meeting focused on continuing
issues related to the special education system of support for military connected children. I also
want to note that the California State Compact submitted an end of the year report earlier this
month. There were multiple accomplishments noted in the annual report. Activities listed included
the fact that the State Council met four times this year. Also that the panel attended and supported
multiple presentations virtually about the pandemic and the impact on schools.
There have been multiple training activities and workshops provided for the Interstate Compact that
took place six times. School personnel from highly impacted areas were invited to the trainings that
were held between January and May. We also had created a lot of new positive professional
relationships with multiple organizations including the Coast Guard, the Governor's
Military Advisory Council, the Space Force, the National Guard, the California Reserve Forces,
NOAA, the National Oceanic and Atmospheric Association, the Military Child Education
Coalition, and multiple MICC 3 Compacts from around the country. It's also worth noting,
and I did report on this earlier, the Department of Education and the State Superintendent have
approved and adopted the Purple Star School Recognition Program. I reported on that back in
the summer. The first schools and districts will be announced in 2022. I also do want to report
that the Department of Education has increased its support to the Compact and accountability
to the public by updating the Military Family Support webpage and providing digital resources
to schools, families, and the public. That ends my report. Awesome. Member Rodriguez.
Yes, thank you. All right. So even though the August Commission for Teacher Credentialing
meeting was light, there were very meaty items on the agenda. The CTC adopted the SMRs,
the Subject Matter Requirements for Art, Music, and Multiple Subjects Subtest 3,
to align with the California Art Standards for Public Schools approved by this body in 2019.
The RECA was discussed, and there continue to be concerns remaining, the pass rates,
especially for teachers of color, and there is a need to have the assessment updated.
As CTC does with all assessments, one of the things that Director Sandy said,
that doesn't mean that the test is lacking in validity or reliability at the moment,
it just needs to be brought up to date. So it's not irrelevant, and I'm quoting her,
it needs to be brought into its next iteration to address the needs of the current concepts of
literacy with regard to our English language learners and English language arts. Staff is
closely examining the specifications of this assessment. It will take at least a year to
develop new requirements. There are new frameworks. The CTC staff now has a lot of experience
and knowledge developing performance assessments, and the minimum time required for these
assessments is two years. So there's a 2025 projected update for the RECA. CTC staff is
incredibly appreciative for the inclusion of $2 million in the 2021-22 Governor's State Budget,
for a complete review and revision of the RECA. Staff will develop a statement of work for a new
contract, and without these funds, this could not have been possible. On August 31st, CTC leadership
attended the Universal Transitional Kindergarten, UTK, I knew that was going to happen,
design team launch meeting. The meeting discussed the planned collaborative efforts
across multiple agencies to prepare and promote implementation of the UTK state effort,
and also looking for applicants to fill a vacancy for the public member position
on the Committee of Credentials. The application can be found on the Committee of Credentials page,
and the final filing date is September 15th. So if you know any public members, this is
truly a labor of love, and it's incredibly important work that the Committee of Credentials does.
And then my next and final update. The summer session ended for the California Summer School
for the Arts. Congratulations Class of 2021. It was very exciting because the students
had this amazing program, and it was all online, and their commitment didn't falter. They continued
working hard. The CSSA Foundation supported students by providing rental laptops for those
who had technology needs. So thank you to the Foundation for their support. They were really
happy that they were returned in great condition. The executive directors in the third round of
negotiations with CalArts for the summer school site, which is where they've always been, but
there's a little bit of an increase in price, and they're hoping that they can make it happen.
The diversity and inclusion subcommittee will meet at the end of this month to strategize outreach,
and a student satisfaction survey will be shared in October with the trustees,
and I will pass it on to board members. And lastly, Matthew Gallagher, the executive director,
is working on a data dashboard to collect relevant data. It's a longitudinal six-year history,
although he's relatively new. I don't even know that he's been there for a year yet,
and it includes information on feeder schools, race, ethnicity statistics, admission data,
and more. His hope is that this information will be useful as we strategize throughout
the school year ahead. So thank you. And I would also like to say that a big shout out to
my students who are walking with their masks in 113-degree heat, and they are not complaining,
and they are walking like almost half a mile from my class to other classes, and they come in and
their old faces are sweating, and they just sit down and are absolute troopers. And we've been
doing this for a month and a half now, so I'm waiting for cooler weather. So thank you.
That's awesome. Member Patio-Bronson.
I'm going to build off of the last report and share a little bit about the
UPK Constellation Group that the Department of Education has been convening. They are basically
looking at the implementation roadmap and have convened a number of design teams to look at
local implementation and promising practices, research, workforce development, and then also
partnerships, which is the design team that I'll be supporting the liaison work with the state board.
In addition, the early childhood policy council met twice earlier this month. The first was around
shared services, which is sort of back-end function sharing among the CBO
organizations that provide that pipeline into Pre-K and eventually TK and the K-12 system.
And then the most recent early childhood policy council meeting focused on racial equity,
which was very exciting and actually had a lot of alignment with our conversation today.
We heard from Dr. Lee about equity in early education and the Department of Education plans
to bring that into the fold in terms of community schools, in terms of behavioral health,
and of course, obviously UTK. And I think that's it. Otherwise, I just want to say happy
California admissions day, belatedly.
Anyone else who's got school children who celebrated that holiday?
There you go. Member McQuillin.
All right. Not a whole lot to report on. I do also serve on the California Joint Pathways
Committee for Career Technical Education. I was asked to give some recommendations
of folks who can serve on focus groups because they're developing the plan, the California
statewide plan. So we came up with quite a number of folks that could give a voice to
American Indian tribes of California, as well as rural communities, rural counties,
to give a voice to these focus groups that's on a short turnaround over the next couple of months
to develop this California-wide plan. So tribes have something called tarot offices,
or tribal employment rights offices, and they develop lots of different career pathways for
tribal members throughout Northern California. So some of those officers were recommended to
serve on the committee to come up with the plan and have a voice.
That was good for me. And that's it. Thank you.
Terrific. Member Glover Woods.
Thank you. And thanks to Vice President Strauss for talking about the IQC and the
World Languages Public Hearing and also what's coming up for the screening committee.
I have just one other item to share with everyone today, and that's in regards to the virtual
convening that took place last month on P3 STEM policy. The Education Commission of the States
did convene that gathering in August, and I had an opportunity to engage in conversation with
educators from across the state, Tennessee, Colorado, Arkansas, and as participants we also
had educators from Georgia, Michigan, Vermont, and Virginia. The topic, again, was how to ensure
that robust STEM instruction takes place for our younger learners and how to make sure that
that doesn't put on the bath burner as students return to in-person instruction and we really
focus on accelerating learning. So it was very robust. A couple of thoughts that came through
was just the necessity and importance of networking professionals that are working in that area,
especially for those that are in smaller areas and rural areas, and also ensuring, again,
just professional learning support and keeping the authenticity with STEM instruction. So that was
quite exciting, and thank you for allowing me to share today. That's wonderful. We'll go to Member
Burr. Thank you. Because I wasn't here in July, I didn't have the opportunity to congratulate
Matt Navo on being selected as executive director for the CCE. I think all of you who had the
pleasure of working with Matt on the board know how fortunate we are to have an educational leader
of his stature to take over the organization. It probably also won't surprise you that he's only
been on board a few weeks, and he's already met with over 50 of our educational partners
to learn more about what our organization, CCE, can do with those educational partners to help
support learning in all of our schools. And I especially want to thank, on behalf of Matt,
and I said this this morning, the cooperation and collaboration with the Department of Education is
absolutely critical, as is the collaboration with the county offices of education. So,
just a big appreciation to all of those folks. And as we also heard this morning, Matt's busy
building his leadership team, which will now include Dr. Gregson as the deputy executive director
of the collaborative. I just want to highlight two pieces of work by the collaborative.
The playbook for accelerated learning is out and available on their website. If you haven't seen it
yet, I encourage you to take a look at it. It lays out current research on how best to improve
student outcomes, identifies models that practitioners can use to accelerate learning in
their systems, and proposes ways in which they can plan with their teams. And it suggests ways
and it suggests ways in which LEAs can leverage community-based organizations
and engage families as partners in this work. Related to that, the state budget included funding
for learning acceleration grants, and the CCE, in collaboration with our administrative partner,
Marin County Office of Education, has issued an RFP for those grants, and they will be holding a
webinar tomorrow, Friday, September 10th, from 1130 to 1215, to provide an overview of the
requirements. Specifically, these grants will provide professional learning for educators
to support, again, learning acceleration, particularly in mathematics, literacy, and
language development. So I encourage you to get the word out. People who are listening, please
sign up for the webinar on the CCE's website. And the last thing I'll say back to the leadership
transition is to say, express my deep appreciation to Tom Armalino, who retired and served the CCE
with great distinction. At our next board meeting, which is October 28th, we will have a little
celebration of Tom's leadership. So I hope everybody will tune in. Thank you. Thank you.
And member Badanka.
Yeah, so recently I've been publicizing the student board member recruitment for the 2022
to 2023 position. So I'm currently working with Generation Up to publicize it through their social
media accounts. Additionally, I'm working with the California Association of Student Councils
to begin the preparations for the SABE conference, which will be held from October 30th to November
1st, where we will be narrowing down the semi-finalist group of potential student
board members to a finalist group. And then finally, before the school year began, I collaborated
with Superintendent Thurman to moderate a webinar aimed at promoting vaccine awareness among students
and discussing essentially what a safe return to campus would look like. And that'll be all.
That's terrific. You're off to a roaring start. I love it. And I'll just add a few of my own
comments. You know, in the summertime, there's a lot of important business that the state
board gets involved in. Of course, you heard about the state budget when it was passed
and the additional $20 billion that the governor and the legislature allocated for a variety of
really important programs. So state board staff, and I want to particularly recognize Brooks Allen
and, of course, all the staff who work with him, have been busy not only moving those programs
forward and thinking about implementation with the department, particularly around TK and
particularly around community schools, some of the big investments that are coming that really will
reshape the nature of the public school system in California. Many, many details to be worked on.
But also the trailer bill, which, you know, has just been announced this week,
you know, clarifying and extending some of those initial parts of the budget. You know,
we've been working hard on safe school reopening, as I mentioned earlier, all of the policy elements
that lead to, you know, the excellent work IDAY students are doing wearing their masks.
Recognize that on behalf of all the students in California and Ronna, I'm sure that you are in
that number and all of your classmates. The vaccinating that is going on around the state,
the schools that are taking up the testing programs that the state's been offering, the
SWIFT, the team that responds to concerns from local schools when there are needs for more
testing, more vaccinating. So all of that has been going on this summer. So it's been a very,
very busy summer. I think, you know, the state board staff along with the CDE staff have been
just critical to the position we find ourselves in today, which is, well, one that has a lot of
challenge and complexity to it also has gotten us off to a really good start. I just
saw come across the transom and announcement in the papers that SFUSD announced this afternoon
that there have been zero outbreaks or transmissions in schools since they've been
going. And we, you know, see this happening in our districts across the state because they're
taking advantage of all of the supports that have been made available. So we're all thrilled about
that. I just want to both thank all the people who have made it possible and encourage everyone to
keep up the good work so that at our next meeting, we can really be even happier about how healthy
our state is and how successful the start of school has been for all of our students.
And with that, I'm going to move to taking up agenda item number 10, which is general public
comment, which is invited on any matter not included on the printed agenda. And we'll open
the phone line for the public comment queue. Once again, members of the public wishing to provide
comment on this item may do so by calling the number shown on the public comment slide and
using the access code that is there. And we're going to have a little wait time because there
is a lag for folks who are trying to call in. So we'll give it a minute to see if there is any
public comment. And if you do call in, we urge you to state your name and affiliation for the record.
Remember to turn down the volume on your computer if you're following the live feed
and speakers will be limited to one minute each. Are there any further public comments?
Yes, we do have public comment. All right.
Hello, caller. Please state your name and affiliation for the record. You have one
minute. Your time begins now. Thank you for the opportunity, Lourdes Medina,
resident of the Central Valley, parent of freshman Uniswap District students,
honorable board members and committee. This year has been a trying one for all of us.
Understanding the pandemic obviously has not prepared us or anyone with what's going on.
I would just ask for us to be more inclusive of communities who are not fluent in English
and who do not have the resources or the community system to reach out for help.
Unfortunately, in the Central Valley with the IAS and dependent studies,
this has been quite an ordeal for our community. They want the well-being of their children.
They want them to be educated and they want to follow the rules and the recommendations
from the state and the government. However, they're not being addressed. They're not being
helped nationally, not locally, and definitely not through the media. I would suggest and I
would urge for this board to seek to promote more Spanish language media via video, social media,
so that they can help them understand better independent studies.
Thank you so much for that comment. Are there any others?
There are no others.
All right. With that close of public comments, I will hereby adjourn our September 2021 State
Board of Education meeting at 4.52 p.m. Good work. Catch yourselves on the back. We'll see you soon.
Thank you. Bye, everyone.
Bye, everyone. Have a great day.
Bye. Take care.